Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr.
37 haben wir gehört?
36. 36.
Wir sind selber ein bisschen draußen.
Genau. Wir sind heute mal ganz weit draußen. Wir sind nämlich zu einer der interessanteren Forschungsstätten in Deutschland gefahren zum Wendelstein 7, dem Fusionsreaktor. Und wir haben zwei Gäste.
Ja, stellt euch am besten selber vor, aber ich mach das mit Sicherheit falsch. Ich hab hier schon am Eingang den Namen falsch gesagt.
Ich bin Adrian von Stechow. Ich bin hier im Institut Postdoctoran, hab im März promoviert und arbeite hier an einem Grundlagenexperiment zur Labor Astrophysik, könnte man sagen. Genau, das zu mir.
Ja und ich bin Thomas Klinger. Ich bin hier einer der Direktoren und versuche, den Laden hier zu schmeißen und bin insbesondere verantwortlich für den Aufbau, also den tatsächlich Aufbau dieses Wendelstein 7X übrigens.
X, wofür steht denn das X?
X steht für nix.
Ist einfach nur, damit es cooler klingt oder?
Nee, eigentlich wollte man da noch was reintun, aber das ist dann irgendwie, hat dann Eigendynamik bekommen, das ist dann so geblieben.
Okay.
Ja, erstmal vielen Dank für die Einladung, das hat uns sehr gefreut und wir würden das auch gerne anderswo wiederholen, wenn jetzt also irgendwelche Gehörer an einem Warp an Triebbrauen oder an irgendwelchen anderen unglaublichen Wissenschaftsgeschichten, dann schreibt uns doch am besten eine mail. Da kommen wir dann auch gerne hin. So, wir fangen vielleicht an, zu sagen, was hier eigentlich gemacht wird. Nämlich ist das hier das Farnhofer Institut für Plasmaphysik, richtig?
Nee, das Max-Planck-Institut für Plasmaphysik.
Entschuldigung, geht schon los, ich sag schon.
Farnhofer ist die Konkurrenzveranstaltung.
Tut mir leid, tut mir leid. Plasma, das heißt hier zweimal Fusion, aber es handelt sich nicht um ein Kraftwerk, sondern es ist nur ein Vorgänger davon. Nur? Na also, ich mein, hier kommt noch kein Strom raus.
Nee.
So, warum ist denn das wichtig, mit Plasma zu experimentieren?
Na ja, erst mal natürlich aus grundsätzlichen Gründen, denn das ist ein Materiezustand. Ein Materiezustand, der uns in unserem Weltall umgibt. Fakt ist, von dem sichtbaren Weltall sind etwa 99 Prozent oder gar ein bisschen mehr in diesem Plasmazustand und deshalb gibt es ja schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren sogar seit über hundert Jahren großes Interesse an diesem Materiezustand, der ja auch irgendwie ganz nett anzuschauen ist, weil der sich insbesondere dadurch auszeichnet, dass er nett leuchtet in allen Farben. Also etwa die Aurora Borealis, das Nordlicht, ist so eine der ersten Plasmazustände gewesen, die die Neugierder Wissenschaftler angezogen hat. Das war Christian Birkeland in Norwegen, der später Norsk Hydro gegründet hat, übrigens mit einer Plasmatechnologie, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Auf jeden Fall sich der dafür interessiert, wo kommt das überhaupt her, nicht dieses Leuchten. Und da hat er eben festgestellt, dass diese Nordlichter eben durch den Sonnenwind, der in die Magnetosphäre der Erde eindringt, dort Ströme erzeugt, diese Ströme, das Gas der oberen Atmosphäre ionisieren und damit dann diese verschiedenen Leuchteinscheinungen je nach Gasart hervorrufen, dass das die Erklärung dafür ist, dass es gar nichts mit Magie und Göttern, den nordischen Göttern zu tun hatte, was man bis dahin dachte. Und das war eben halt so einer der Pioniere der Plasmaphysik. Und da kommt ja auch schon die Sonne rein. Denn die Sonne ist dann ja wiederum etwas später, ist das so gekommen, so in den 20er-, 30er-Jahren, hat man festgestellt, dass die Sonne in einem Plasma-Zustand ist und dass die Energie der Sonne, also das, was sie überhaupt in diesen heißen Zustand fällt, ein Plasma ist ein heißes Gas, dass das ein Fusionsprozess ist, wo wir ja noch reden werden.
Das war eine der Fragen, die wir uns notiert haben.
Genau, das war eine der Fragen, die wir uns notiert haben.
Woher wissen wir das eigentlich?
Woher wissen wir das eigentlich, dass es in der Sonne ein Fusionsprozess ist?
Einfach durch Ausschließungsprinzip. Es gab da eine andere Spekulation. Man hat sich bei einer chemischen Verbrennung Gedanken gemacht, dass es ein Feuer ist, wie ein Kohlefeuer oder ein Gasfaser verbrennt. Dann macht man eine Energiebilanz. Das kann man ja ausrechnen. Dann stellt man fest, es reicht überhaupt nicht. Dann dachte man, naja, vielleicht eine Kernspaltung. Aber geht auch nicht. Also kam auch alles nicht hin mit den Beobachtungen. Im Prinzip kann man die Sonne relativ gut beobachten. Die ist einigermaßen nah. Das heißt, man weiß, wie heiß sie ist. Man weiß, wie groß sie ist. Dann kann man daraus ausrechnen, wie groß die Gesamtenergie der Sonne ist. Und dann hat Arthur Eddington in Großbritannien da in Cambridge, Oxford. Nein, von beiden.
Weiß nicht, wo er gesessen hat.
Ich meine, Oxford.
Das ist auch wie Frau Nufour und Max Planck.
Alles eine Mischporke.
Das war ein Schlumpffehler.
Ach was, ich schätze unsere Kollegen. Auf jeden Fall eine dieser britischen Forschungsuniversitäten. Der hat das letztlich mal zusammengebastelt und dann konnte er zeigen, dass das mit den Beobachtungen am vernünftigsten übereinstimmt. Natürlich in dem Sinne endgültig wissen kann man es gar nicht, weil man nicht die Sonne von innen untersucht. Aber mit allen Beobachtungsdaten ist das am allerallerstimmigsten. Es gibt einfach keinen anderen vernünftigen Vorschlag als die Fusion von Protonen. Und da gibt es eben mehrere verschiedene Fusionsprozesse. Also hier bei der Sonne, bei diesem Typ Stern, den wir da oben hängen haben, da ist die Proton-Proton-Fusion. Also der Proton-Proton-Zyklus ist dort der entscheidende Prozess. Das ist so eine längere Kette, die fängt mit zwei Protonen an, da gibt es mehrere Zwischenstufen. Am Ende kommt ein Heliumbaar raus und wieder zwei Protonen, dann geht es wieder von vorne los. Nicht so, dass die Sonne langsam ihr gesamtes Wasserstoff, also die Protonen, alle auffrisst und sich dann immer mehr in ein Heliumball verwandelt, bis sie dann halt irgendwann grepiert.
Und unser Vorteil dabei ist, dass dieser Prozess unglaublich ineffizient ist, das heißt, mit einer sehr geringen Wahrscheinlichkeit letztendlich auftritt und dadurch unsere Sonne auch nicht zu heiß ist, das hat sich auch schon längst ausgebrannt.
Und die Kernfusionen hat man ja immer so in der Presse so, ist immer so diese magische Energietechnologie, die immer noch so, die eigentlich immer so 20 Jahre konstant in der Zukunft ist. Seit man damit angefangen hat, ist es eigentlich immer so, in 20 Jahren sind wir damit fertig so.
Ich wollte Moving Target.
Ja, genau.
So wie der Esel mit der Möhre.
Was ihr ja gemacht habt, aber hier mit euren Experimenten, die ihr dann auch durch die Presse gegangen sind, erweckt ihr ja schon so den Anschein, als wäre man jetzt plötzlich doch wieder ein ganzes Stück weiter.
Ach, mit jeder Maschine ist man einen Schritt weiter. Aber es ist ein ganz mühsames Geschäft. Diese, das ist ja insgesamt immer heikel, in der Wissenschaft zu sagen, ja, dann und dann haben wir das rausgefunden. Die Natur der Wissenschaft ist ja das Unbekannte. Und man tappt da in einem unbekannten Gegend rum, so auf irgendeiner weißen Landkarte, und macht sich gewisse Vorstellungen, wie das so aussehen könnte da drauf. Aber dann erlebt man die mal zu oft Überraschungen. Also deshalb, ich scheue mich da auch, irgendwelche Zeitangaben da zu machen. Man muss es halt vorantreiben und dann eben sehen. Und man muss der Überzeugung sein, dass es nicht hoffnungslos ist, dass es wichtig ist, dass man nicht irgendwas hinterherläuft, was totaler Käse ist. Dann verschwendet man seine Zeit und verschwendet das Geld anderer Leute. Das heißt, da muss man sich immer wieder selber prüfen. Also, wie kam es denn mal zu diesen 20 Jahren? Da ist auch ein bisschen Psychologie dabei. Das ist ganz interessant. Denn Wissenschaftler sind ja auch euphorische Menschen. Sonst würden sie nicht für so wenig Geld so hart arbeiten. Also, sie sind relativ leicht in Begeisterung zu versetzen. Und die Erkenntnis, dass man diesen irren Prozess da oben auf der Sonne, dass man das in einer modifizierten Form auch auf der Erde machen kann, nämlich in einer modifizierten Form mit schweren und superschweren Wasserstoff, das besprechen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen, dass man das eventuell auf der Erde hinbekommen kann unter vernünftigen Bedingungen, unter technisch beherrschbaren Bedingungen, das hat alle unheimlich angesprochen. Weil, wow, insbesondere wenn man dann mal so auf den Bierfilz ausrechnet, wie viel Energie da rauskommt, das haut einen um, das haut einem vom Schlitten. Da waren alle total begeistert, das sah ich mir auch wirklich sehr, sehr gut aus. So im Prinzip mit diesen einfachen Vorstellungen, man sich gemacht hat. Und mit diesen einfachen Vorstellungen, da wär es auch eine Sache von 20 Jahren gewesen. Leider, leider hat man genau hingeguckt und das funktionierte alles überhaupt nicht. Das ging so gar nicht. Also entgegen dem Verständnis, wie es eigentlich sein müsste. Das hat man ja ganz oft in der Physik. Man überlegt sich was, so und so müsste das sein und dann ist das erst mal ganz anders, dann verhält sich das überhaupt nicht so. Gerade dieser Materiezustand Plasma, der hat viele Tricks drauf, das Leben sehr, sehr schwer zu machen. Genau das hat es getan. Und dann gibt es immer so Zyklen. Das heißt, dann gab es erst mal so in den Ende der 50er oder in den 50ern eine große Euphorie. Dann gab es eine große Frustration in den 70ern. Da waren alle ganz niedergeschlagen, so was das für ein Mist ist und so. Und sind dann auch schon wieder einige ausgestiegen. Dann haben wir auch schon wieder so Labors dazu gemacht und so was und wurden Projekte eingestellt. Und dann gab es plötzlich wieder einen großen Hoffnungsschimmer. Das war wieder eine Maschine. Das ist oft mit Maschinen, mit Instrumenten dann verbunden. Und damit kommen wir dann auch gleich zu unserer Maschine. Maschinen verbunden, das war der T1, der T1 Tokamak am Kotschartow-Institut in Moskau. Dieser T1, das war eine Fusionsmaschine, die gehört auf den schönen Namen Tokamak. Und damit wurde das erste Mal überhaupt ein 10 Millionen Grad heißes Plasmal erzeugt. Das hatte bis vorher kein Mensch hinbekommen. Das hat immer nicht geklappt, obwohl es hätte klappen müssen. Plötzlich haben es die Russen geschafft. Das war so ein freudiger Schock für alle, dass die Engländer wiederum, da wieder aus Kalem und bei Oxford, dass die sofort ihre Sachen gepackt haben, haben Koffer und Kisten voll geladen mit Messgeräten, sind nach Moskau gereist und haben das nachgemessen.
Weil sie es erst mal nicht geglaubt haben.
Weil sie es natürlich nicht geglaubt haben.
Und die gesagt haben, die Russen mit ihrem Vodka. Und in der Tat, das hat sich bestätigt. 10 Millionen Grad Ionen Temperatur hatte man dort. Und da waren alle wieder total euphorisiert. Und auf der ganzen Welt sind sofort Tukamaks gebaut worden. Oder wo andere Anlagen waren, zum Beispiel Stellaratoren, das ist das andere Konzept, da wurden die sofort umgebaut. Und in Tukamaks haben sich da alle drauf gestürzt. Und dann wählte man sich wieder, ja, jetzt sind wir durch, nicht so jetzt.
Noch 20 Jahre für die technischen details.
Jetzt haben wir noch 20 Jahre, nicht? Das müssen wir jetzt vorantreiben und dann haben wir das. Ja, und dann kamen sie die nächsten, die nächsten Dinger, wo man dann so plötzlich feststellen musste, dass es ja wieder alles ganz anders, ganz blöd. Und da hat es sich nämlich erwiesen, dass man, also es gibt das gute Theorien, die vorher sagen, je heißer man dieses Plasmar macht, desto verlustfreier wird es, also desto weniger Energie verliert das. So in diesem Magnetfeld eingeschlossen. Also desto besser wird es zusammengehalten. So ist die klassische Vorhersage, wenn man das wirklich ausrechnet. Es ist viel komplizierte Mathematik dabei, aber das ist ganz klare Aussage. Da hat man also diese Anlagen gehabt. Und endlich hatte man jetzt diesen tollen Tuckermarkt, mit dem man das richtig schön heiß machen konnte. Da dachte man, jetzt immer heißer wird es immer besser. Da hat man es immer heißer gemacht, es wurde immer beschissener, es wurde immer schlechter. Genau andersrum, nicht so, natürlich auch nicht in der erwünschten Art und Weise. Da hat man festgestellt, wenn man das Plasmar heißer macht, wird es immer turbulenter. Das heißt, es bilden sich da dann Turbulenzen. Diese Turbulenzen schmeißen wie wild Energiewärme raus. Und je heißer man das im Zentrum macht, desto steiler werden die Temperaturdifferenzen. Das ist wie so ein Sturm draußen, so nicht? Hoch Temperaturdifferenzen, da gibt es einen richtig tüchtigen Wirbelsturm. Das heißt, die Wirbel sind entsprechend auch größer geworden und intensiver geworden, haben immer mehr Energie rausgeworfen und es wurde halt immer schlechter. Das heißt, dann ist das Turbulenzproblem plötzlich eingetreten, die Plasmarphysik. Das war dann wieder eine große Depression, die man dann bekommen hat. Das heißt, dann war es in den 80ern so ein Mist. Dann wurden erstmal die Wunden geleckt und da wusste man gar nicht, wie man da weiterkommen soll, denn das Turbulenzproblem gehört zu den ganz großen, schwierigen Problemen der Physik. Also eines der ungeknackten Nüsse, die wir so haben.
Und das gemischt mit der Plasmarphysik.
Ja, und das mit der hin ekligen Plasmarphysik. Und das heißt also, Turbulenz im Plasma ist schon eines der ekligsten Ecken, die man in der klassischen Physik so haben kann.
Ist die eigentlich gravitationsabhängig?
Nee, zu wenig Masse.
Das heißt, die würde in der Schwerelosigkeit auch auftreten?
Jaja, also die Turbulenz, die wird alleine von der Temperatur und Dichte gradienten getrieben. Also von der Dichte und Temperatur unterschieden. Das sind Druckunterschiede. Ich sage, das ist wie Sturm draußen. Also einfach wie Hochdruckgebiet, Tiefdruckgebiet. Nichts anderes.
So eine Frage haben wir jetzt schon auf dem Weg beantwortet, die wir nämlich gewesen, mit welchem Material, den kann man denn so ein heißes Plasma überhaupt behandeln oder einfärchen und dann nimmt man halt Magnetfelder? Ja, das haben wir jetzt schon beim Durchgehen.
Ja, jawohl, schon beim Durchgehen. Als jeden Fall Magnetfelder spielen eine wichtige Rolle in unserem Geschäft. Und darum geht es eigentlich. Eigentlich geht es darum, ja, so ganz allgemein gesprochen, das richtige Magnetfeld zu finden. Und da kann man jetzt lange drüber philosophieren, was das richtige Magnetfeld ist. Also da kann man so eine lange Liste aufsetzen, was das Magnetfeld richtig macht. So oder so, Magnetfelder sind der Weg, den man da gehen muss. Denn ein Magnetfeld ist in der Lage, dieses heiße Plasma ja quasi einzufangen. So, und wie macht es das? Ein Magnetfeld zwingt alle geladenen Teilchen auf die magnetischen Feldlinien. Das heißt, die geladenen Teilchen können sich nicht mehr frei bewegen, sondern sie machen eine Spiralbewegung um die Magnetfeldlinien herum. Und damit, wenn man diese Magnetfeldlinien, wenn man die jetzt geschickt formt, und etwa eine geschickte Form ist ein Ring, wir reden von einem Torus, dann sind die Magnetfeldlinien in sich geschlossen und die Teilchen laufen bloß noch auf diesen Ring herum. Und berühren nicht mehr die Wände. Das ist gut, das ist dann schon mal gut.
Wenn man keine Wärme los wird.
Denn sobald, also ich meine, so ein Plasma ist ein zartes Ding, das ist ein superdünnes Gas. Das ist etwa ein Faktor, 10 Millionen runter verdünnt gegenüber dem atmosphärischen Gas, was wir hier atmen. Also das ist wirklich ein ganz wenig Gasteilchen in diesem Volumen drin. Und sobald das auch nur in geringsten Kontakten mit der Wand kommt, kühlt es sofort einfach ab und verliert den Plasma-Zustand und wird neutral. Und da hat man einfach nur so ein hauchneutrales Gas am Ende übrig.
Das heißt, wenn ich dich jetzt mal mit so einer Neonröhre vergleiche, was ja sozusagen so das Plasma ist, was die meisten Leute kennen, dann ist es noch viel dünner.
Noch viel dünner, ja.
Das heißt also ganz viel von dem, was sie so tut oder erforscht, hat damit zu tun, wie man Magnetfelder...
Richtig. Eigentlich ist das das ganze Geschäft, also das richtige Magnetfeld zu finden. Und das ist das Schwierige dabei.
Eure Anlage heißt ja Wendelstein, auch deswegen, weil sie ja so eine lustige Form hat, die halt eben nicht nur so ein einfacher Donatorus ist. Wieso ist die so gebogen?
Ja genau aus diesem Grund. Denn oft bei der Suche nach dem richtigen Magnetfeld... Ja, da... Wie geht man da vor? Also am besten geht man da systematisch vor. Indem man nämlich einfach mal alles aufschreibt. Was soll das alles liefern? Also was alles muss dieses Magnetfeld liefern? Also erst mal muss es ganz elementar diese geladenen Teilchen auf diese Kreisbahn zwingen. Also auf diesen Ring zwingen. Dazu ist auch ganz ganz elementar, das lernt man dann schon in den einführenden Vorlesungen, notwendig das Magnetfeld in sich zu verdrillen.
Und zwar warum?
Das muss man verdrillen, weil man damit sogenannte Driften ausgleichen muss. Diese Driften, die muss man sich so vorstellen, dass die Teilchen zwar auf den Magnetfeldlinien drauf laufen, dass sie aber durch eine zusätzliche Kraft, die auf diese Teilchen wirkt, dass sie von diesen Feldlinien dann doch wieder wegwandern und zwar in radiale Richtung.
Also das heißt, wie eine Zentrifugalkraft quasi.
Ein bisschen kann man sich das wie eine Zentrifugalkraft vorstellen. Das ist eigentlich equivalent dazu.
Oder ein ganz hübsches Bild dazu ist, finde ich, ein Carrera-Bahn. Da hat man quasi die äußeren Feldlinien, haben einen weiteren Weg als die inneren Feldlinien. Das ist natürlich bei der Carrera-Bahn unfair für den, der halt außen ist.
Der inner ist? Im Inneren sind immer benachteiligte.
Nee, den, der außen ist. Und die Lösung davon ist, dass man halt die Carrera-Bahn an einer Stelle kreuzt. Und genauso ist das bei den Magnetfeldlinien. Die mischt man quasi durch, sodass die Teilchen dann einmal außen, einmal innen laufen. Und das demokratisiert das Plasma vielleicht so ein bisschen. Also ein bisschen anders ausgedrückt.
Ja, also man kann sich da so verschiedene Bilder von machen. Am Ende, so ist das ja immer in der Physik, muss man Papier und Bleistift nehmen und das alles zusammenstöpseln. Und dann bekommt man aufgrund der Tatsache, dass die Feldlinien gekrümmt sind, aufgrund der Tat eine Sache, dass die Feldlinien auf der Innenseite dichter liegen als außen, bekommt man diese zusätzlichen Driften. Und letztlich ist es dann wieder wie beim Segeln, wenn der Wind so von Achtern kommt und man sagt, ich werde wohl da landen, wo der Wind mich hinbläst. Und man hat einen Untergrunddrift, dann landet man ganz woanders. Und was macht man dann? Dann steuert man dagegen. Und dieses Verdrillen der Feldlinien ist nichts anderes, als ein dagegen steuern.
Und das sind aber Sachen, die man noch relativ gut ausrechnen kann. Also da wart ihr einigermaßen sicher, das wird schon so funktionieren.
Das ist schon seit den 50er Jahren bekannt. Da hat schon Enrico Fermi gleich drauf hingewiesen, hat gesagt, also ohne verdrillen wird das nichts. Und dann haben sich da die ersten hingesetzt und gesagt, na dann verdrillen wir es halt nicht. Und dann ging es eben halt schon darum. Das ist der einfache Schritt. Wenn wir uns jetzt hier den Wendelstein angucken, da sieht das ja schon ein bisschen anders noch aus. Also insofern hat man da mal gerade mal eines dieser Kriterien, für das richtige Magnetfeld, da hacke ich mal drauf rum, nicht eines der Kriterien erfüllt, dass das alle elementarst ist. Sie müssen in sich verdrillt sein. Wenn ihr euch diese Feldlinien anguckt, das ist das erste, was einem ins Auge sticht. Die sind ja so verdreht. So, dann machen sie noch alle möglichen Wellen und Kurven und liegen mal dichter und mal weniger dicht. Also verändern ihre Magnetfeldstärke. Und da gehen dann weitere Kriterien ein, die dann schon komplizierter werden. Und die auch manchmal schon nicht mehr ganz so anschaulich sind. Da macht man einfach so eine Liste von Kriterien und diese Liste sagt, naja, also was wollen wir alles haben? Wir wollen also ein gutes Gleichgewicht haben, denn so ein Plasma, was in dieses Magnetfeld eingesperrt ist, das wechselwirkt auch wieder mit diesem Magnetfeld. Das ist nicht so, dass das Plasma gar nichts macht mit dem Magnetfeld. Das entwickelt auch selber Ströme und verändert wieder das Magnetfeld. Und diese Kombination aus den beiden, das bildet denn das Gleichgewicht. Das Gleichgewicht muss gut sein. In dem Sinne, das muss schön steif und stabil sein. Darf nicht irgendwie so...
Fluktuieren oder so.
Ja, ja, fluktuieren. Also das darf nicht so undefiniert sein, dass wenn man es heißer macht, dass es größer wird und wieder kälter, wieder kleiner und so ein Mist. Das muss schön steif sein. Dann muss die ganze Sache in der Tat stabil sein. Da sind wir beim Fluktuieren. Darf nicht fluktuieren. Da gibt es also einen ganzen Satz von Stabilitätskriterien, die erfüllt werden müssen. Und dann muss man die alle, muss man die alle heranziehen. Dann muss es in der Lage sein, den Transport, also die Diffusion, das ist das richtige Wort, dass die Diffusion dieser geladenen Teilchen senkrecht zu den Magnetfeldern durchstößt untereinander, die zu minimieren. Nämlich die Teilchen sitzen drauf und treffen sich ab und zu auf ein anderes Teilchen. Dann stoßen zwei aufeinander und dann macht der eine so einen Sprung zur Seite und sitzt auf einer anderen Feldlinie. Und wenn man das alles so statistisch nimmt, dann fließt das dann doch wieder auseinander, also diffusiv, wie braunste Diffusion. Und dann quält man sich damit rum, muss man das denn minimieren. Das kann man nicht ganz verhindern, das findet immer statt, aber man will es auf jeden Fall klein machen. Dann muss man dafür sorgen, dass es zwei verschiedene Gruppen von Teilchen gibt. Einerseits so die thermischen Teilchen, das sind so die, die sich in so einem thermodynamischen Gleichgewicht befinden, die einfach diese Suppe da, diese heiße Suppe machen. Und da drin sitzt noch die Gruppe der schnellen Teilchen, die noch oben drauf sitzen, die alle anderen überholen, die so zehn oder hundertmal schneller sind als alle anderen.
Die kommen letztendlich aus den Fusionsreaktionen selber. Da bekommen diese einzelnen Teilchen ihre hohen Energien. Und die möchte man natürlich im Plasma drin behalten, weil sie ihre Energie wiederum in thermische Energie oder an die thermische Population abgeben sollen. Das ist natürlich ärgerlich, wenn einem gerade die Teilchen abgehen. Und das ist tatsächlich, wenn man diesen Optimierungsschritte weglässt, hauen einem gerade die dann ab. Und das ist...
So nun hat aber der Tokamark, also das russische Modell, hat gar keine so eine Verwirkung. Wieso kommt da überhaupt eine Reaktion zustande dann?
Bei dem Tokamark muss man diese Verrenkung hier nicht so intensiv machen. Das ist eine feine Geschichte.
War das eher Zufall, dass Sie das noch nicht wussten und es halt zufällig funktioniert und alle haben gestaunt?
Naja, naja, naja.
Oder war das eher so eine Sache?
Na teils, teils. Die Geschichte ist eigentlich andersrum. Der Tokamark hat sehr überraschend, sehr gut funktioniert. Gleichzeitig der Stellarator, also dieses Ding mit diesen komplizierteren Formen, der hat überraschend schlecht funktioniert. So sah es dann erstmal aus. Das heißt, man war vom Stellarator erstmal sehr enttäuscht, aber wusste gar nicht warum, was denn da los ist. Also warum das eigentlich so schlecht ist. So schlecht in dem Sinne, man kann das übertragen im Sinne so sehen, dass es so eine, also man kann dieses Magnetfeld als so ein Gefäß ansehen, als so eine Flasche, in die man das Plasma reinfüllt, nicht einfach eine ringförmige Flasche. Das ist kein Beschleuniger, das geht nicht darum, irgendwie Teilchen möglichst schnell zu machen. Das muss man genau unterscheiden. Das ist einfach eine ringförmige Flasche, die ist ringförmig, damit sie keine Wände berührt. Man kann sich das so vorstellen, dass diese Flasche, dass die mehr oder weniger löcherig ist. Die Stellaraturflasche war halt einfach unheimlich löcherig. Da wurde man erstmal enttäuscht, man hat überhaupt nicht verstanden, warum. Gut, da hat sich eben alles auf den Fokamarkt gestürzt und da waren alle diese genannten Kriterien ganz gut erfüllt. Also das lief einfach so, kann man darüber streiten, ob es ein Zufall war oder ein bisschen Glück oder ob man sich das schon gut überlegt hat. Das ist immer ein Mischmasch daraus. Ein Teil war gewiss Glück, ein Teil hat man gesagt, naja, das wussten wir ja schon, das ist auch klar. Auch die Mathematik hat dann da schon sehr geholfen. Da kann man auch viel wirklich auf dem Papier ausrechnen. Und insofern hat man den Fokamarkt schon mal viel besser verstanden und hatte dann ziemlich schnell, nicht ziemlich schnell, also einfach mit Papier und Bleistiftphysik konnte man ziemlich schnell so die ganzen Kriterien durchgehen und sagen, ok, check, check, check, check, das ist ja alles hier bestens gegeben. Und dann konnte man das wunderbar vorantreiben. Da war der Stellarator immer so das Schmuddelkinn. Nicht so, hä, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht. Der geht ja gar nicht gut. Aber man wusste überhaupt gar nicht, warum. Irgendwas ist da faul. Meistens haben wir ihn aufgegeben, haben gesagt, Stellarator ist halt scheiß.
Welches war denn das frühere Konzept?
Die sind beide ziemlich gleich alt, ziemlich in die gleiche Zeit sind die vorgeschlagen worden.
Richtig lustigerweise im gleichen Jahr 1951. Das war auch beide damals geheim gehalten, weil das eine amerikanisch war, das andere war ein russisches Konzept. Es war auch eins der ersten Projekte, wo die Wissenschaft tatsächlich kollaboriert hat, durch den Eiseren Vorhang.
Obwohl es geheim gehalten wurde?
Dann nicht mehr. Aber schon fünf Jahre danach, 1951, wurden beide Konzepte entwickelt. Und schon 1956 oder 1957 gab es dann eine Tagung in Großbritannien, bei der...
1959 war die in Genf.
Alles falsch. Ich dachte, was betrifft die?
Nein, das war die große Fusion Energy Conference, IAEA Fusion Energy in Genf. Bei dem 50-jährigen Jubiläum bin ich in Genf gewesen, als die da wieder durchgeführt wurde. Wir waren alle ganz beseelt. Das war 2009.
Jedenfalls wurde da das Tokamark-Konzept dann auch vorgestellt und das Geheimnis quasi gebrochen. Und das war dann eins der ersten Projekte, wo dann tatsächlich Wissenschaftler aus beiden Nationen sich dann verständigt haben, was für die Zeit auch ganz ungewöhnlich ging.
Ja, nee, das muss ganz lustig gewesen sein. Da haben sie alle ihre Maschinen angestaut. Und das darf man nicht vergessen. Also da gab es noch ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Maschinen. Da gab es so 20, 30 verschiedene verrückte Maschinen, nicht so alle möglichen Magnetanordnungen und sowas nicht.
Man hatte damals also man hatte damals aber ja noch sowas wie Superleitender Magneten gab es ja damals noch nicht.
Nee, der Superleitungseffekt ist ja schon sehr alt. Man wusste, dass es die gibt, aber damit hat man sich dann auch nicht umgequält.
Das heißt, die haben Spulen gewickelt?
Ja, da wurden einfach Kupferspulen gewickelt. Da haben die eben alle ihre Maschinen in Genf angestaunt. Und da war es dann eben so, da waren das eben zwei Ideen oder zwei Konzepte von vielen. Jeder ist da so seinen Weg dann so gegangen. Aber man hat eben relativ schnell realisiert, spätestens ab diesem berühmten T1-Truckermark am Kotschardorf-Institut, dass der toll funktioniert und hat auch ganz gut verstanden warum. Man hat überhaupt nicht verstanden, warum der Stellarator nicht funktioniert. Und die meisten haben gesagt, lassen wir das halt. Irgendwas ist da faul, weiß ich auch nicht, verstehe ich nicht, interessiert mich auch nicht. Ein paar sind immer am Ball geblieben. Die haben gesagt, das muss man auch zumindest rausfinden, woran denn das liegt. Und sind da einfach der Sache nachgegangen. Sind aber da uns stecken geblieben, weil man aufgrund dieser verrückten Formen, wir reden auch von Dreidimensionalität, das heißt also, da hat man gar keine Symmetrien drin. Und das geht dann auch wieder in die Physik ein, dieser Verlust an Symmetrie bedeutet immer Verlust von Erhaltungsgrößen. Wenn man an Erhaltungsgrößen verloren geht, dann steht man in einem Regen in der Physik, dann weiß man gar nichts. Da steht man ganz dumm da. Das heißt, da ist man dauernd auch stecken geblieben dabei mit Papier und Beistift. Und erst, als die ersten vernünftigen Rechner zur Verfügung standen, das war allem voran die IBM 360, das war die erste, die sich damit beschäftigen konnte, da konnte man tatsächlich die Codes dafür schreiben, also eine mehrere Codes dafür schreiben, die sich mit diesen Problemen auseinandersetzen. Und da rede ich von der Mehrzahl Codes, weil dieser Kriterienkatalog für das Gute, für das richtige Magnetfeld, jedes von diesen Kriterien braucht eigentlich ein eigener Code, um dieses Problem zu untersuchen. Stabilität, Gleichgewicht, Diffusion und so, Diffusionsgleichung, magnetohydrodynamische Gleichung und so, das sind alles verschiedene Codes. Und das heißt, an diesen Codes wurden alle so entwickelt, wurden so geschrieben und getestet, validiert. Und dann konnten die alle jeder für sich laufen. Die mussten alle gleichzeitig laufen, mussten miteinander kommunizieren. Nicht? Weil alle Kriterien sollten gleichzeitig erfüllt werden. Das heißt, musste gekoppelte Codes laufen lassen. Das wurde natürlich irre aufwendig. Und eben halt auch schwieriges Code-Management, was gemacht werden musste. Und da ist man so mit diesen ersten sogenannten Supercomputern heute natürlich lächerlich, so eine IBM 360, konnte man schon mal so in die Richtung manövrieren. Also konnte man so Teil optimieren. Und da hat man festgestellt, aha, jetzt verstehen wir langsam, woran das liegt, was da eigentlich wirklich faul ist. Das hat eben viel mit dem Brechen der Symmetrie zu tun, mit dem Verlust von Erhaltungsgrößen. Das hat mit Krummungen und Modulation der Magnetfeldstärke zu tun. Viele, viele Dinge gehen da so rein. Das hat man ja alles auseinander gepuzzelt. Und man hat so festgestellt, na ja, im Prinzip, wenn man jetzt völlig freie Hand hätte über die Formung des Magnetfeldes, dann könnte man dieses Problem lösen. Und da war denn der entscheidende Schritt, sich davon zu lösen, was man vorher mal getan hat, dass man das Magnetfeld mehr oder weniger ad hoc geformt hat. Das heißt, da hat man so beim Stellarator, so eine klassische Anordnung ist einfach so ein Satz von ganz normalen flachen Spulen und dann so eine Doppelhelix noch drumrum, da im drin. Diese Doppelhelix erzeugt so ein Quattropolfeld, also so ein welliges Feld, was dann überlagert wird mit dem Feld dieser planaren Spulen. Und dann ist das halt irgendwie so ein verzwiebeltes Feld, aber es ist ad hoc. Also das ist einfach so, das hat jemand entschieden, mach ich so.
Also ohne tatsächlich eine richtige Modellierung da drin.
Ja natürlich, also quasi ohne nachzudenken. Das ist ein bisschen ein Gefühle, ein Wellenschlag, das machen wir so, das sind entweder in Konfiguration ganz vornehmlich, aber in Wirklichkeit ist das einfach irgendwas hingesetzt. Und sich davon dann geistig zu lösen, dass man also in seiner großen Weisheit, in der man das richtige Feld aus Versehen findet, das war ein nicht so einfacher Schritt. Und der war eben auch technisch anspruchsvoll, weil man sich dann gesagt hat, naja, jetzt lösen wir das ganze Spulensystem so auf und die Formung des Magnetfeldes realisieren wir durch die Krümmung der Spulen. Also indem wir die Spulen formen, können wir das Magnetfeld formen. Das ist ja unmittelbar miteinander verbunden. Der Stromfluss in den Spulen, nicht wenn er so eine Kurve macht, nicht wenn er mal so läuft und so läuft und so läuft, nicht dann bestimmt das jeweils nicht wie die Krümmung der magnetischen Fälllinien ist. Das heißt im Prinzip hat man es ja damit in den Händen. Und dann muss man einen zweiten intellektuellen Schritt gehen und sich dann von den Spulen lösen. Sagen, jetzt sind mir erstmal die Spulen-Bumps egal. Jetzt rechne ich einfach das ideale Magnetfeld aus oder das Magnetfeld aus, wie es eigentlich sein soll und rechne dann rückwärts aus, wie die Spulen dazu aussehen.
Also quasi derselbe Schritt wie in Atomwaffenforschung die Sprengstofflinsen von der Anforderung rauszurechnen, die man braucht, um die ideale Kompression zu erzeugen.
Keine Ahnung.
Also man hört letztendlich darauf, was das Plasma haben möchte, um eingeschlossen zu sein. Das spuckt einem dann irgendein Magnetfeld aus, was nicht unbedingt als Spulen realisierbar sein muss.
Und dann nähert man sich dem halt irgendwie ingenieurstechnisch an, so weit es irgendwie geht.
Man setzt dann halt Randbedingungen, was man dann noch bauen kann, also was für Toleranzen überhaupt möglich sind, welche Spulenkrimmungsradien überhaupt baubar sind und lässt sich das im Code dann einfach so weit annähern, dass es noch machbar ist.
Und das heißt also, die Anlage, die ihr jetzt hier habt, die ist eigentlich aus so einer kompletten Simulation erwachsen?
Ja, richtig. Aber das war natürlich mühsames Geschäft. Das war so eine ganze Forschergeneration, 20 Jahre oder so harte Arbeit von so einer ganz großen Gruppe.
Da sind wir wieder bei den 20 Jahren.
Ja, wir mussten wieder mal 20, wieder mal mussten wir eine ganze, ganze Forschergeneration verbraten. Also in dieses, in diese, diese schwierige Aufgabe. Und die haben dann immer weiter Fortschritt auch gemacht mit den besserwerten Computern. Zum Glück ist das in der Max-Pan-Gesellschaft üblich, dass man sich immer das Feinste kauft. Also das heißt, da wurden, wurden schon immer vernünftig schnelle Computer angeschafft. Das war dann so die kai-xmp, kai-ymp, diese ganzen legendären Anlagen, nicht dann später große IBM-Systeme, so Multiprozessorsysteme, wurde auch mal auf, auf Vektorkomputer waren auch mal innen, nicht sind dann aber wieder beiseite geschoben worden. Also es wurde auch im Hinblick auf Computerphysik und auf Hochleistungsrechnung wurde an sich, auch mal sich an die Spitze gesetzt. Und damit konnte man das Problem immer weiter verfeinern. Das heißt, man hatte mehr Rechenpower und man konnte genauer hinschauen. Und am Endeffekt, das war so Ende der 90er etwa, da hatte man das Wendelstein 7X Feld dann eigentlich ziemlich gut bestimmt. Wo man sagen konnte, jetzt ist es so weit, dass wir das Ding bauen können.
Und ist denn seit dem Abschluss, also man sagt, wenn jetzt so Planung geht, sagt da jemand, das ist das Feld, so müssen unsere Spulen aussehen, muss man dann da noch auf so Fortschritt zum Beispiel in der Materialforschung oder so zocken, dass man weiß, 2015 können wir so ein Ding anbuten? Oder war man zu dem Zeitpunkt schon so, dass man so, okay, mit der Technologie der 90er Jahre kann man mal anfangen, in die Realisierung zu gehen? Also wie funktioniert so was bei so einem ultra langfristigen Experiment?
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Nämlich, das ist auch ganz heikel. Also eigentlich hatte man nur relativ grobe Vorstellungen, wie man das bauen könnte. Wenn ich mir da so die alten Bücher dazu angucke, also die technischen Spezifikationen, da gibt es bei Großanlagen immer so ein Schema. Da hat man quasi eine Vorstudie, die wird dann in die internationale Begutachtung geschickt und aus der Vorstudie wird dann eine detailstudie gemacht. Wenn ich mir diese Vorstudie und selbst die detailstudie angucke, da kann man wirklich nur milde lächeln. Das war sehr, sehr naiv. Denn es gab letztlich gar kein richtiges Konzept, wie man also diesen, so nennt sich das, dann optimierten Stellarator mit diesen geformten Spulen, wie man das in einer super leitenden Ausführung machen will.
Also sind da so die Probleme, so Beispielprobleme?
Einige Dinge sind ja, ich fange erst mal mit dem an, was kein Problem ist. Also der Stahlbau, das ist nicht so wahnsinnig anspruchsvoll. Das ist halt nicht so Fügen, Fügen und Schweißen oder sowas. Nicht, das ist erst mal grundsätzlich machbar.
Du hattest vorhin erzählt, dass ihr da schon irgendwie auch so bis an die Grenzen von denen, was geht. Dazu komme ich gleich.
Also erst mal grundsätzlich Stahlbau nicht. Das sieht erstmal alles gut machbar aus. Das ist alles Stahlbau, mein Gott. Nicht Kessel und Verstrebungen und sowas nicht, dass es nicht nur ein Anlagenbau macht wie Schiffbau.
Aber es klingt so ein bisschen nach Jugendlich im Leichtsinn so, ach, das machen wir jetzt mal. Was kann da schon passieren? Und dann kollidiert man mit der Realität.
Wissenschaftler sind euphorik, ja nicht so.
Sonst wird das ja auch nichts. Das hängt man ja nicht an.
Nee, wenn man die ganze Zeit immer Angst hat, dass man das nicht hinkriegt, dann in der Tat fängt man da nicht an. Superleitung ist eigentlich auch nicht so heikel. Superleitung gibt es schon seit 100 Jahren und den Superleiter, den wir benutzen, Neop Titan, das ist einer der altmodischsten und sichersten Superleiter, die es gibt. Den ist auch schon seit 1920 bekannt und ist in jeder medizinischen Anlage drin. Insofern gab es da gute Gründe, dass dann hier die Vorväter dieses Projektes, die das alles angeschoben haben, dass die dann auch den Geldgebern und auch den Kollegen sagen konnten, ach, das ist alles hinzubekommen, das wird nicht so schwer. Im Endeffekt muss man schon eine harte Lernkurve durchleben, die vor allem dadurch charakterisiert ist, dass die Genauigkeitsanforderungen sehr hoch sind. Erstens die Genauigkeitsanforderungen an den Stahlbau, auch an den Bau dieser Spulen. Denn der Stahlbau, der bestimmt, wo die Spulen sitzen, wie die Spulen relativ zu dem Gefäß sitzen, wo das Magnetfeld drin sitzt. Das heißt also große Toleranzen konnte man sich dann nicht leisten, erstens schon mal das Gründen des Magnetfeldes.
Aber das abzusehen und man hat das ignoriert oder hat man das gar nicht gesehen und das viel erst auf zusammengebaut.
Diese groben Studien, diese Vorstudien, die geben das nicht her. Da sieht man das einfach nicht. Also das ist ja auch noch nicht komplett durch überlegt. Erst mal wirklich reingeht, wenn man erst mal wirklich reingeht in die details, da muss man eben schon viele tausend Ingenieurstunden reinstecken für diese detailuntersuchung. Das heißt, erst mal los gesegelt ist, dann weiß man eigentlich, worauf man sich eingelassen hat. Der zweite große Block, der unterschätzt wurde, der vielleicht ein bisschen naseweiß angegangen war, ist, was es bedeutet, eine kryogene Maschine zu bauen. Aber es ist eine kryogene Maschine. Eine kryogene Maschine ist, wo der Löwenanteil der ganzen Maschinen, wir reden hier von 430 Tonnen von 750 Tonnen, auf den absoluten Nullpunkt runtergekühlt werden müssen. Also 430 Tonnen werden hier auf 3,4 Kelvin, auf 270 Grad runtergekühlt mit flüssigem Helium. Da kann man auch sagen, naja, das ist einfach nur runterkühlen, nicht so flüssiges Helium. Aber das ist plötzlich eine andere Welt. Denn alles, was kalt ist, also alles, was runtergekühlt ist, an das kommt man während des Betriebes nicht mehr ran. Das heißt, die Zuverlässigkeit muss in etwa die Zuverlässigkeit eines Raumschiffes sein, was so wegfliegt und wo man auch nicht mehr rankommt. Damit explodieren sofort die Genauigkeitsanforderungen, damit explodiert die Qualitätsanforderung insbesondere. Und dann muss man sich mit solchen schönen Dingen beschäftigen, die es in der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft dann oft nicht gibt. Qualitätssicherung und systematisches, das ist ja so ein Concurrent Engineering. Das heißt also, wo man das Design der Maschine dann immer wieder den Ansprüchen immer wieder so nachzieht und mit allen Randbedingungen gleichzeitig arbeiten muss. Dann wird es nämlich plötzlich sehr, sehr heikel. Eine kalte Maschine mit den hohen Präzisionsanforderungen zu bauen, da wurd's dann hart.
Das heißt, ihr habt de facto einen 430 Tonnen Satelliten gebaut, der auf 0 Kelvin runtergekühlt oder in 3 Kelvin runtergekühlt wird? Ja, sozusagen.
Also flüssiges Helium, da fragt sich jetzt vielleicht der eine oder andere Hörer, kühlen macht man doch mit Stickstoff. Stickstoff wird nicht so kühl, deswegen Helium. Also, ihr müsst ja schon in Bereichen, die so normales Engineering nicht erreichen.
Aber hätte man jetzt nochmal sozusagen zurückzugehen, das heißt also, dass so grundlegende Entscheidungen wie, welchen Supraleiter nehme ich, daraus folgt ja, welches Kühlsystem brauche ich, daraus folgt ja dann wiederum, was sind meine Engineering-Anforderungen an die ganzen Teile. Das heißt also, eine grundlegende Entscheidung wie, wir nehmen einen relativ konventionellen Supraleiter, der aber wiederum hohe Kühlanforderungen hat, treibt dann sozusagen das Gesamtprojekt in dem Sinne.
Aber es gab wenig Alternativen.
Wäre das rückblickend besser gewesen, wenn man sagen würde, wir nehmen lieber diesen Supraleiter, dann ist das Kühlen nicht so aufwendig. So hätte man da irgendwas reißen können rückblickend? Oder war das schon okay so?
Leider nicht, leider nicht. Weil die hohen Felder, die wir brauchen, das wird zurzeit immer noch, wenn man es in eine Spulenform bringen will, nur von diesen ganz konventionellen metallischen Supraleitern geliefert, die leider nur bei diesen 3 bis 3,5 Kelvin vernünftig arbeiten.
Die Spulen waren ein Stück, was halt relativ früh schon fertig sein muss. Das ist jetzt nichts, was man sagen kann. Das machen wir jetzt noch im letzten Drücker, wenn die Materialien dann zur Verfügung stehen.
Warten wir kurz, bis jemand einen Supraleiter findet.
Außer dann nicht mal jetzt Supraleitern.
Das heißt also, da wäre halt auf Materialfortschritt zocken, hätte einfach nicht geholfen.
Nee, das heißt, da war es schon vernünftig konservativ zu sein, aber es hatte natürlich einen Rattenschwanz von Folgen. Und ich sage ja, eine cryogene Maschine zu bauen, das ist überhaupt kein Spaß. Das ist eine harte Nummer.
Das hat auch mit so einem Ausdrehungskoeffizienten und so einem Zeug zu tun?
Ja, alle Materialien muss man testen unter minus 270 Grad Bedingungen. Also wir hatten ein riesen Entwicklungsprogramm, wo wir ein Reibelement entwickeln mussten, also eine reibende Verbindung, die so zwischen Spulengehäusen angebracht ist. Wo Spulengehäuse sich berühren und dann anfangen starke Kräfte, bis zu 100 Tonnen Scherkräfte, 100 Tonnen aufeinander auszuüben. Und dann sind wir zum Schluss gekommen, das können wir nicht einfach sich selbst überlassen, dass wir einfach so ein Stahlgehäuse so auf sich rumrubbeln lassen. Nicht, weil es dann zu, ja nicht zu unkontrollierten Bewegungen daran gekommen wäre. Nur haben wir gesagt, da müssen wir ein Reibelement da rein packen. Also was heißt so eine Reibscheibe. Hört sich total trivial an, eine Reibscheibe. Aber dann müssen sie wieder durchdenken. Aha, eine Reibscheibe für 100 Tonnen. Gut, ok. Bisschen höhere Anforderungen. So war 100 Tonnen Scherkraft, das heißt also so eine quergerichtete Kraft. Aha, dann gleitet die da, nicht so, nicht? Dann beginnt die da so umzurutschen da drauf.
Das ist bei minus 270 Grad.
Das ist auch in Ordnung. Und minus 270 Grad muss es auch noch funktionieren. Ja und man kommt auch nie wieder ran. Nicht, weil das ist da ganz tief in den Spuren. Man wird also nie wieder rankommen. Das heißt, die muss 20 Jahre halten und muss mindestens 5000 Lastzyklen, also 5000 mal Magnetfeld hoch und wieder runterfahren aushalten. Oh, ja, da wurde es die Luft ein bisschen dünner und am Ende ist es dann so eine Lösung geworden. Da haben wir dann eine Aluminiumbranze gefunden, die musste dann auf ein Mikrometer genau geschliffen werden, also wie so eine Linsen und hat auch in der Tat so eine ganz leichte Linsenform, so eine ganz leichte Krümmung, damit die nicht rutscht, sondern so abrollt. Und damit die nicht reibt, läuft sie auf einer hochglanzpolierten Fläche, das heißt, diese Gehäuse wurden dann wie so ein Spiegel poliert, also mit einem irrelangen Polierschritt, sodass dann auch eine ganz plane Fläche ist, auf der diese Linse dann so drauf rumrollt. Und damit es noch weniger reibt, ist denn dieser Aluminiumbronze-Pad, ist dann dort mit Molybden-Dieselfid, also mit Karamba, das kennen wir aus dem Auto, nicht beschichtet worden, aber mit einer festen Schicht. Und das geht nur mit einem Plasma-Sputter-Anlage. Da mussten also zwei und solche Pads dann selber sputtern, nachdem wir die dann hergestellt haben. Und das Ganze damit nachweist, dass sie funktionieren, haben wir in Österreich extra einen Teststand aufgebaut, der so aus zwei großen hydraulischen Stempeln besteht, die dann so in flüssiges Stickstoff eintauchen und dort dann 5.000 Mal nicht mit Querkräften und dort drauf und dann wieder Querkraften in diese Pads durchgeschaukelt haben und dabei permanent den Reibungskoeffizienten gemessen. Das ist nur eine winzige technische Lösung von Hunderten. Also das bedeutet, dass man so eine Maschine hat, wo große Kräfte, hohe Präzision, tiefe Temperaturen, das fressen alles aufeinander.
Ihr seid, was so das Engineering angeht, schon so echt an der vordersten Kante von dem, was gerade so geht.
Ja, wir haben eigentlich während des Baus dieser Maschine erforscht, wie man so eine Maschine baut. Das war am Anfang nicht bekannt. Und wir haben auch Schwein gehabt. Am mehreren Stellen haben wir Schwein gehabt. Weil viele Technologien, die wir gebraucht haben, sind eigentlich erst verfügbar geworden, während wir gebaut haben.
Also denn doch, an gewisser Stelle habt ihr zwar nicht drauf gezockt, dass die Forschung weitergeht, aber...
Probleme haben sich dann ergeben und...
Problemen haben sich gegeben, wir sind panisch durch die Gegend gelaufen, haben nach Lösungen gesucht und haben dann hier und da mal so Leute gefunden, also Hersteller gefunden, haben gesagt, ja, gerade ganz frisch aus der Entwicklung haben wir das hier und dann, es könnte knapp reichen.
Okay.
Also vielleicht, um das Ganze noch mal kurz zu visualisieren, wir haben also insgesamt drei toroidale Systeme ineinander. Also im Inneren ist halt das Plasmagefäß. Außenrum hat man halt dieses irre System aus Spulen, die irgendwie krumm und schief sind und die an so einem Zentralring befestigt sind.
Ja, das Innere ist auch schon krumm und schief.
Das Innere ist auch schon krumm und schief, genau. Und dann kommt das Einzige, was ein bisschen regelmäßig aussieht, nämlich die Außenhülle, die toroidal ist, aber dann noch mal 300 Löcher hat, durch die alle möglichen... 500? 500 Löcher hat, durch die alle möglichen Einschübe dann zum Inneren Plasmagefäß dann kommen. Und diese drei Systeme sind also ineinander geschachtelt und dürfen sich halt auch nicht berühren. Das heißt, sie stehen auf ihren eigenen Füßen. Also das mittlere System ist das Kryosystem. Also das, was auf minus 270 Grad gekühlt wird.
Das steht auf kalten Füßen.
Das steht auf kalten Füßen, die übrigens auch gar nicht mit dem Boden fest verbunden sind. Also die sind nicht verankert, sondern stehen auf Gleitflächen letztendlich drauf. Und beim Runterkühlen...
Falls sich die Größe verändert während des Kühlen.
Genau. Also beim Runterkühlen zieht sich also diese gesamte Ring um mehrere Zentimeter zusammen und verschiebt sich halt gegen alle anderen Teile, die da auch eingebaut sind und die halt warm bleiben, wie zum Beispiel das Plasmagefäß, was auch wärmer wird durch das Plasma im Inneren. Und das Außengefäß, was halt im Vergleich zu den Spulen 300 Grad heiß ist. Das heißt, das ist schon ein irre komplexes System, was sich beim Kühlen und dann auch noch im Betrieb gegen sich selbst verschiebt.
Und so ergeben sich dann auch die Toleranzen, die man dann braucht.
Genau.
Weil man noch die Verschiebung kompensieren muss. Wie kriegt man denn so ein Plasma überhaupt auf mehrere Millionen Grad? Oder wie kriegt man überhaupt ein Plasma? Stell ich mir da so einen Typ vor mit einer Pingsette, der da so einen Gramm irgendwie ins Vakuum reinmacht? Oder wie funktioniert das?
Das machen wir letztendlich einfach mit Mikrowellen. Also das ist nicht groß anders als so eine Haushaltsmikrowelle. Nur, dass unsere Mikrowelle sehr viel Leistung kann, was, wenn ich jetzt richtig verstanden hab, zum Anfang der Entwicklung auch noch nicht so ganz klar war, ob das in dem Maßstab gehen würde. Also unsere Mikrowellen haben Megawatt-Nennleistung, an die sie auch fast rankommen inzwischen. Das sind Gyrotrons, das heißt, so wird ein Elektronenstrahl beschleunigt, der durch wieder einen superleitenden Magneten durchgeht. Und beim Eintreten in dieses superleitende, also durch den superleitenden Magneten erzeugte Feld, fangen die Elektronen an zu gyrieren und geben dabei mit der Frequenzregulation dann Mikrowellenstrahlen ab. Die stehen in einer anderen Halle, die von uns aus gesehen da drüben ist, also ein paar hundert Meter vom Plasmagefäß entfernt. Die werden dann alle erstmal aus der Mikrowelle ausgekoppelt, was auch gar nicht so leicht ist, weil das ja immerhin Megawatt ist. Unser Langzeitziel ist, eine halbe Stunde lang Plasma zu fahren. Das bedeutet, Megawatt eine halbe Stunde lang durch so ein kleines Fenster irgendwo durchzukriegen. Das ist technisch eine ziemlich große Herausforderung und hat letztendlich dazu geführt, dass bei uns leider Diamantscheiben sein müssen. Das heißt, normales Glas oder auch nur Quarzglas funktioniert halt nicht, sondern da müssen halt tatsächlich so... Wie groß sind die in der Zeitung?
So knapp zehn Zentimeter.
Genau, also richtig fette Diamanten.
Das heißt, ihr habt einen fetten Hohleiter von den Mikrowellenanzäugen?
Nein, tatsächlich die Mikrowellen selber werden einfach durch Luft transportiert. Die werden nur aus dem eigentlichen Jurotron, in dem ein Vakuum ist, dann ausgekoppelt einfach in Luft. Und dann gibt es ein irre kompliziertes Spiegelsystem.
Ein Spiegelsystem, okay.
Das sieht ein bisschen so Todesstern-mäßig aus. Das sind echt sehr abgefahrene Teile, die...
Das klingt doch wie Todesstern, wenn man da dann versinkt in den Strahl reinreißt.
Das ist ein Todesstern. Ein Hystischzugang ist auch nicht erlaubt.
Das ist so ein Untergrundtunnel. Die werden dann runtergespiegelt in den Keller, wo diese insgesamt acht Strahlen dann gebündelt werden in zwei große Strahlen. Diese Strahlen gehen dann den Strahlentunnel lang, werden mehrmals umgelenkt überspiegelt und refokussiert und letztendlich dann über einen Turm, der neben dem Plasmagefäß steht, dann über einen sogenannten Launcher, der auch noch mal aus solchen Kupferspiegeln besteht, die verfahrbar sind und mit dem man genau steuern kann, auf welchen Punkt genau die Mikrowellenleistung gesteuert wird, genau dann ins Plasmagefäß rein gepackt. Krass! Und es gibt dann einen Punkt, so ein Magnetfeld, bei dem die Mikrowelle resonant ist, das heißt, wo die Frequenz der Mikrowelle, gerade die Korrektionsfrequenz der Elektronen entspricht im Plasma. Und bei diesem Resonanzfeld sind dann die Mikrowellen mit den Elektronen in Resonanz, was also bedeutet, dass die Elektronen im Kreis beschleunigt werden und dadurch dann geheizt werden. Das passiert halt sehr lokal und das kann man dann letztendlich mit Hilfe dieser Spiegel dann ausrichten und entweder direkt auf der Achse heizen, was man meistens tut, oder wenn man ein bisschen rum experimentieren möchte, auch mal neben die Achse schießen kann, um das Plasma halt an einer Stelle dann zu heizen.
Also zu veranschaulichen, was klein bedeutet tatsächlich, die Wellenlänge dieser Mikrowellen, das ist zwei Millimeter. Und dieser Resonanzpunkt, den Adrian da beschrieben hat, also dieses Volumen, in dem tatsächlich diese Resonanz passiert, die ist auf der gleichen Größeordnung der Wellenlänge. Das heißt also im Prinzip, diese zweieinhalb Megawatt, nicht pro vereinigten Strahl von Mikrowellen werden so auf eine Daumengröße zusammenfokussiert an dem Punkt. Da passiert dann die Energieübertragung von den Mikrowellen auf die Elektronen. Die Elektronen werden ordentlich tüchtig auf Tempo gebracht und geben das dann wieder weiter an die Ionen. Und dann wird dann am Ende das Plasma heiß. So einfach ist das.
Bleibt das dann heiß von sich aus oder muss ich immer nachheizen? Das klingt ja so, als wenn ich die ganze Zeit die Mikrowelle betreiben muss.
Genau, muss man auch.
Wenn die ausgeht, was passiert dann? Macht es puff und das Plasma ist weg?
Nicht ganz puff, aber doch puff.
Also puff, aber nicht puff.
Es macht eher so...
Also man spricht da von zum Beispiel von Energieeinschlusszeit. Die möchte man möglichst groß haben. Das ist also die Zeit, die das Plasma braucht, um seine Energie zu verlieren an die Wände. Und je besser der Einschluss durch das Magnetfeld ist, desto höher ist halt diese Energieeinschlusszeit. Die will man natürlich so groß wie möglich haben. Das heißt, dass die Wärmeverluste des Plasmas an die Wand möglichst klein sind.
Also einige Zehntelsekunden, so eine knappe halbe Sekunde. Das heißt, man kann sich zugucken auf ein Bildschirm, wenn wir die Mikrowelle abschalten, das ist wirklich so ein, nicht verklemmt das so, nicht so ganz hübsch.
Also ich versuche immer so ein bisschen das zu betrachten, wie im Vergleich zu irgendwelchen Spaltungskraftwerken, und frage mich jetzt, kann man irgendwie zu viel Mikrowelle zuführen und dann geht irgendwas kaputt oder ist das total stabil alles? Das ist... Passiert irgendwas, wenn ich da mehr Energie zuführe?
Es wird erstmal heißer.
Und dann? So passiert aber nichts.
Dann passiert erstmal nichts. Also man kriegt dann, wenn man jetzt einen Fusionsreaktor hat, dann kriegt man unter Umständen mehr Fusionsreaktionen. Ja, aber das war's dann. Also es kann einem nicht quasi weglaufen plötzlich.
Ja, und es kommt noch dazu, also diese Temperatur, die wir da anstreben, das sind die berühmten 100 Millionen Grad oder eben in einer vernünftigeren Einheit 10 Kilo Elektronenvolt, 10 bis 20 Kilo Elektronenvolt. Das ist gerade beim Maximum, das heißt also, da hat man die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit für Fusionsstöße. Wenn man es ja so viel heißer machen würde, dann würde man da wieder runterlaufen. Das heißt, dann würde man wieder weniger Fusion bekommen. Das ist also der berühmte Sweet Point.
Vielleicht sollten wir den Punkt jetzt mal nutzen und nochmal ein bisschen genauer in diese Kernfusion reingehen. Also warum macht ihr das eigentlich?
Ja, wo wir gar keine Kernphysiker sind. Die Kernphysik ist eigentlich das Uninteressante daran.
Das sagt wahrscheinlich auch nur ihr, wenn man jetzt Kernphysiker ist.
Nee, das ist schon alles gut bekannt. Da ist nichts Neues rauszufinden. Da forscht auch keiner dran an Kernfusion.
Das ist tatsächlich ein relativ langweiliger Prozess. Also was man da machen muss.
Dann lassen wir uns trotzdem mal kurz durchgehen, damit die Hörer wissen, weil das Ziel am Ende, auch wenn es langweilig ist, muss ja doch zumindest klar sein.
Also was man letztendlich einfach machen muss, ist, man muss sich zwei Teilchen nehmen, die am besten leicht sind. Also Wasserstoff bietet sich da an, und man muss sie mit genug Energie aufeinanderknallen. Also da gibt es ein Optimum an Energie. Und dann hat man auch schon die Konfusion.
Also eigentlich ist das wirklich kein Hexenwerk.
Sagen wir heute.
Es geht ja darum, diese positiv geladenen Wasserstoffkerne, nicht ob jetzt den ganz normalen Wasserstoff oder den schweren oder den superschweren Wasserstoff, das sind die Isotope, nicht die drei Wasserstoffisotope von Interesse hier.
Also Tritium und Deuterium.
Ja, genau. Nicht schwerer und superschwerer nicht. Also Tritium ist schwerer Wasserstoff, superschwerer Wasserstoff ist... Ah, ein Quatsch. Schwere Wasserstoff ist Deuterium und superschwerer Wasserstoff ist Tritium. Jetzt haben wir es. Also auf jeden Fall reden wir hier von Wasserstoffkernen. Die sind einfach positiv geladen und positiv geladene Teilchen stoßen sich ab. Das ist die sogenannte Coulomb-Abstoßung, Coulombkraft. Und das heißt, wenn man die jetzt zum kollidieren bringen will, und irgendwas hat für sie unheimlich was mit kollidieren zu tun, nicht dann erst mal diese abstoßende Kraft. Und damit man die überwinden kann, brauchen sie erst mal Tempo. Und dann kennt man ja das Coulomb-Gesetz nicht, die Kraft wird immer stärker, je mehr man sich annährt. Also eigentlich hört sich das ja so an, als könnte man das gar nicht erreichen. Die kriegen wir niemals irgendwie auf einen Punkt. Aber da kommt die einzige relevante Kernphysik dann rein. Da gibt es sozusagen so einen Umkehrpunkt, wo dann plötzlich die starke Wechselwirkung übernimmt. Und das ist eine Kernkraft. Also die wirkliche Kernkraft, die die Kerne zusammenhält. Die dafür sorgt, dass Kerne zusammenpappen. Und die übernimmt ab einem bestimmten Punkt. Das ist so im Bereich von 50 Picometer oder so was. Also ziemlich nah beieinander schon. Und damit man diese große Annäherung erreicht, muss man die auf Tempo bringen. Und dann braucht man noch mal Quantenphysik dabei, nämlich den Tunnel-Effekt. Letztlich ist diese Coulomb-Abstoßung ein Potenzial, also ist es ein Wall, den man überwinden muss. Also wie so ein Hügel, über den man rüber muss. Aber in der Quantenphysik läuft das ja ein bisschen anders. Da muss man über Hügel nicht rüber. Man muss ihn wo es hinreichend, also hinreichend hoch klettern, dass man nah genug dran ist, sodass man durchtunneln kann, dass man durchwutschen kann. Und das heißt, durch den Tunnel-Effekt nicht schafft man das, dass man nicht ganz über den Hügel rüber muss, sondern man kann einfach durch nicht so weit genug herangekommen ist. So und das ist eigentlich der Elementarprozess, der dafür notwendig ist und der ist auch wirklich gut verstanden, der ist auch gut vermessen. Das heißt, da kennen wir alle Reaktionswirkungsquerschnitt, alle Reaktionsraten und so was. Das steht alles in dicken Büchern drin, das mit plus minus, plus minus paar Prozent oder sowas, ist das alles völlig in Ordnung.
Wir lagen bei der Reichweite der starken Wechselwirkung komplett falsch, das sind zweieinhalb Femtometer.
Ach, Femtometer, nicht Pico, sondern Femto, verflext, ja.
Jedenfalls müssen sie sehr nahe in den Nachraten.
Jaja, irgendwie war mir auch schon so, dass Pico zu viel ist. Pico ist ja gar nicht so viel. Also, das ist ja ziemlich viel für die Atome, ja. Na gut, das heißt, das ist der eigentliche Elementarprozess. Und wenn denn die starke Wechselung übernommen hat, dann verschmelzen die ja und dann wird darin umsortiert und dann kommt es zu dem Massedefekt, also zu der Differenz in der Masse bei den Endprodukten. Was dabei rauskommt, ist dann ein Heliumkern, nicht mit zwei Neutronen, zwei Protonen. Das bildet ein Heliumkern von dem ganz stinknormalen Heliumgas, dem Edelgas und ein freies Neutron. Wo kommt da jetzt die Energie bei raus? Wenn man also das Gewicht, das Gesamtgewicht von dem Neutron und dem Helium vergleicht mit dem Gesamtgewicht von dem Deuterium und dem Tritium, hat man da einen Massauterschied. Und dieser Massauterschied nach der prämtesten Formel der Physik, nach E gleich mc², der gibt dann eben das E die Energie. Und diese Energie ist dann Bewegungsenergie, kinetische Energie, die sich dann verteilt auf den Heliumkern und auf das Neutron. Und um das wieder in ein Verhältnis miteinander zu setzen, gegenüber der Eingangsgeschwindigkeit von Deuterium und Tritium, ist die kinetische Energie nach dem Fusionsstoß der beiden neuen Teilchen so grob, also als Größenordnung Faktor 1000 höher. Das heißt, wir erfahren eine Faktor 1000 Beschleunigung.
Und um da hinzukommen, müsst ihr euer liebstes Plasma erzeugen?
Naja, das Plasma braucht man da noch nicht. Also im Prinzip könnte man das machen, dass man einfach immer ein Deuterium, ein Trizium nimmt, beschleunigt die, patcht aufeinander, machen Fusionen, fliegen auseinander. Kein Problem. Kann man auch sofort aufbauen. Könnte ich hier auf den Tisch aufbauen, wird wahrscheinlich zwei Stunden dauern oder sowas. Wäre nur ein elektrostatischer Beschleuniger. Und da würden schon ein paar Neutronen da schon mal rauskommen.
Man kann tatsächlich Fusionsreaktoren, also auch einen funktionierenden, kaufen. Die gibt es auch für Schulen tatsächlich. Das Ganze nennt sich der Farnsworth-Fuser. Übrigens, nachdem auch der Professor Farnsworth für Drama benannt ist. Ist das ein Asche, so ein Ding? Leider nicht. Kostet dann immerhin ein paar 10.000 Euro. Das ist so ein Teil, mit Vakuumgefäß kann man auch angucken. Dann kann man einen Neutronenzähler daneben stellen. Der macht Fusion. Das ist jetzt nicht so das Problem tatsächlich.
Also, dass wir Fusion machen, ist wirklich nicht schwierig. Das kann man so in Schulen. Was ist jetzt das Schwierige? Das Schwierige ist, oft Fusion zu machen. Nämlich einerseits sagen wir immer, das ist ja ein toller Prozess. Diese Kernfusion erzeugt ganz viel Energie. Aber wenn man sich jeden einzelnen Prozess anguckt, ist das natürlich lächerlich wenig. Da hilft es auch gar nichts, irgendwie pro Sekunde eine Milliarde Fusionsprozesse zu machen. Sondern in Wirklichkeit muss man für ein Kraftwerk, dass man die Zahlen reingeht, braucht man pro Sekunde 10 hoch 18 Fusionsreaktionen pro Sekunde. Also das verflixt viele. Und da hilft es nichts, wenn man eins nach dem anderen, diese Pillen da aufeinander schießt. Da ist man immer in zehn Größenordnungen oder sowas entfernt. Und auch wenn es dann mal ab und zu rauscht, mal sowas durch die Presse, dann kommt mal dieses Labor, da man das Labor sagt, wir haben in einer Sekunde eine Milliarde Neutronen erzeugt. Das ist immer noch zehn Größenordnungen entfernt von dem, wo man hin will. So, und da kommt jetzt das Plasma rein. Nicht der Plasmazustand ist gut dafür, weil man diese Plasmen, die wir hier erzeugen, die haben so etwa 10 hoch 20 Teilchen pro Kubikmeter. Und dann reden wir beim Kraftwerk von 1000 Kubikmeter. Hier der Wendelstein hat nur 30 Kubikmeter. Weil wir, wie gesagt, hier Fusionsprozesse nicht studieren wollen, deshalb ist das irrelevant. Aber dann hat man eben genügend Kubikmeter und damit insgesamt genügend Teilchen, die dann mit einer hinreichenden hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit miteinander stoßen und man hat viele Teilchen. Das heißt, man hat Wahrscheinlichkeit und Anzahl. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht so einigermaßen hoch und bei der richtigen Geschwindigkeit, also richtigen Temperaturen, in anderen Worten, nicht ist, man sitzt auf Maximum der Wahrscheinlichkeit und dann einfach schiere Anzahl. Die schiere Anzahl, das ist das, was die Plasmaphysiker liefern. Wir liefern einfach die Menge. Da denkt man sich an sich ganz einfach, man nimmt einfach nur ganz viele, nimmt so eine Suppe, aber da kommt eben die Plasmaphysik rein, also eine solche Suppe aus geladenen Teilchen hat ihren eigenen Schädel. Das heißt, die bildet Ströme, die bildet Turbulenzen, die bildet Instabilitäten, die macht Diffusionseffekte und so was. Und das ist unser Kerngeschäft, also unser Geschäft, nicht die Kernphysik, sondern das Kerngeschäft, das alles zu bändigen, also dieses sogenannte kollektive Verhalten des Plasmas zu bändigen.
Vielleicht noch kurz zur Einsortierung. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir brauchen viele Atome, dann reden wir nicht vom Liter, sondern Größenordnung ist so ein paar Gramm, oder?
Ja, so ein künftiges Kraftwerk wäre so was wie ein Gramm auf 1000 m³ verteilt. In Wendelsteinen sind es so was wie 10 Milligramm auf 30 m³ verteilt. Also wenig Zeug.
So wie viel Energie kommt denn daraus, wenn es komplett fusionieren würde? So ein Plasma?
Ich würde es jetzt lieber in Leistung ausdrücken. Also ein solches künftiges, ja noch nicht verfügbares Kraftwerk mit seinen 1000 m³, da kann man die ganzen Zahlen einfach mal so zusammenfegen. Da würde man eine thermische Leistung von drei Gigawatt erzeugen, was dann mit den entsprechenden Inversionsfaktoren auf so einen Gigawatt elektrisch rauslaufen würde. Und da hat man eben immer so ständig ein Gramm Gas drin. Und das reicht für so ein paar Minuten.
Wie macht man das eigentlich, dass das Gas, also wenn ich jetzt eine Fusion habe in so einem Plasma, dann habe ich da plötzlich Helium in meinem Wasserstoff. Das kann ja auch nicht gut sein.
Das Helium ist erst mal Dreck da drin. Das tut nichts, also ich meine, das macht erst mal nichts. Das Helium reagiert mit nichts. Das sitzt da so drin. Trotzdem will man das da natürlich nicht akkumulieren, aber das Helium geht dem Weg alles Irrtischen, das diffundiert einfach auch raus. Das wandert wie alle anderen Teilchen, wandert es auch systematisch raus und wird dann draußen abgepumpt.
Das heißt, ich bin immer am Nachspritzen von...
Du bist immer am Nachspritzen von Deuterium-Tritium-Gemisch und man ist mal am Abpumpen von Helium und anderem Krimskramstädter.
Also man muss sich jetzt nicht aktiv darum kümmern, im Sinne von das Plasmafiltern oder so?
Es gibt da viele Überlegungen zu, wie man das besser machen kann und ob es ein Problem ist, dass vielleicht das Helium im Zentrum akkumuliert.
Das sind dann schon Luxusprobleme in der Zukunft.
Man muss sicherstellen, dass das nicht durch skurrile Plasmaphysik, ich sage ja, Plasmen haben ihren eigenen Schädel, durch skurrile Plasmaphysik plötzlich sich staut da drin, weil dann ausgerechnet das Helium beschließt, nicht rausdiffundieren zu wollen. Das hat man ganz oft in der Plasmaphysik, dass mehr das Gegenteil von dem passiert, was man möchte. Man möchte natürlich den zufusionierenden Brennstoff drin behalten, der soll also nicht rausdiffundieren und der Dreck soll raus. Da kann es dann schon passieren, dass es genau umgekehrt ist. Dann muss man sich damit rumplagen, muss dann wiederum Mittel und Wege finden, um das dann besser hinzubekommen.
Das heißt also, was ihr ja eigentlich tut, ist noch sehr viel Grundlagenforschung. Also sozusagen rauskriegen, wie könnte man sowas in Zukunft eigentlich machen?
Ja, das ist, ich muss immer wieder drum reiten. Also die Plasmaphysik ist halt sehr garstig. Also der Plasmazustand ist der Zustand der Wahl, um tatsächlich Fusionen als Energiequelle nutzbar zu machen. Die Sonne ist auch im Plasmazustand, die hat sich eh nicht entschieden. Aber dann muss man sich mit Plasmaphysik auseinandersetzen. Und das ist ein ziemlich schwieriges Geschäft. Das gehört zu den schwierigen Ecken der Physik. Und zwar nicht, weil das jetzt so was ganz durchgeknalltes ist, wie Super-String-Theorie oder eben auch schon Quantenmechanik, finde ich auch schon verrückt. Aber dieses kollektive Verhalten, das macht einem das Leben sehr schwer. Also die Plasmaphysik gehört so in die Physikklassifizierung der komplexen Systeme. Und dazu gehören die normalen Fluide, dazu gehören die biologischen Systeme. Das ist im Ende fast wie so eine Aufgabe, wie den Menschen physikalisch zu erklären, wo auch alles mit allem irgendwie verwickelt und verwurstet ist. Damit schlägt man sich den ISGAM rum. Und deshalb hat das in der Tat noch durchaus viele Grundlagenfragen, denen man weiter nachgehen muss. Ich glaube, wir haben eine Menge Fortschritt gemacht. Und ich kann immer nur betonen, die Fusion selber gehört nicht dazu, die Grundlagenfragen, sondern das ist die Plasmaphysik. Da haben wir viele Fortschritte gemacht. Noch nicht so, dass wir fertig sind. Also einen berühmten 20 Jahre, also eine Generation müssen wir noch reinstecken.
Wieso haben wir denn hier überhaupt einen Stellarator gebaut, wenn in den 70ern schon der Tukammer funktioniert hat? Das ist irgendwie eine Frage, die sich vielleicht der eine oder andere stellen würde.
Ja, das ist eine sehr berechtigte Frage. Aber ich hatte ja schon vorhin gesagt, also viele haben ja auch gesagt, Stellarator ist halt Mist. Nicht das lassen wir. Und es hat dann einige wenige, man kann es störrisch oder neugierig nennen, also störrisch oder neugierige oder ein Gemisch aus beiden gegeben. Die also in diesem Gemisch sich gefragt haben, woran liegt das? Woran liegt das, dass das eigentlich nicht funktioniert? Also es ist einfach so und dieses Gefühl von unbefriedigt sein als Wissenschaftler nicht, dass man sagt so, hä, dass wir mir doch ganz anders laufen müssen. Warum funktioniert das eigentlich nicht? Die muss man doch nachgehen. Das hätte ja gut passieren können, dass man irgendwann rausfindet, ach, deswegen funktioniert das, das kriegt man auch nie hin. Nicht aber auf dem Weg dieser Frage nachzugehen, habe ich festgestellt. Ach, deshalb funktioniert das nicht und das kriegt man ja hin. Indem man eben halt diese nichtplanaren Spulen macht und indem man das im Computer durchrechnet und so. Und damit hat man jetzt so gesagt, naja, das ist dann ja, das geht dann auch. Und dann kommt noch ein zweiter Punkt dazu. Jetzt kommen wir nämlich zu den Stellarator-Vorteilen. Ansonsten, wenn das nur genauso gut wäre, dann könnte man sich ja wirklich fragen, warum soll man noch was machen. Denn was ich noch gar nicht erwähnt habe, ist die Tatsache, dass der Tokamak das alleinselig machen, der jetzt auch nicht ist. Eine ganz fundamental hässliche Eigenschaft des Tokamak ist, dass er einen sehr starken Strom im Plasma tragen muss. Warum? Dieser starke Strom im Plasma, der wird dann mit Absicht erzeugt, um das Verdrillen des Magnetfeldes zu erzeugen. Nämlich man erzeugt mit den äußeren Spulen ein rein toroidales Magnetfeld, also ein rein ringformiges Magnetfeld. Wenn man jetzt einen starken Strom in das Plasma reinbringt, dann erzeugt dieser starke Strom wiederum für sich ein Magnetfeld, wenn man die beiden überlagert, dann wird es verdrillt. So, das ist der Trick beim Tokamak.
Also das Plasma ist ein unglaublich guter Leiter. Das ist also vergleichbar mit Kupfer. Viel besser.
Tausendmal bessere Leistfähigkeit als Gold.
Also man hat ein sehr gut leitfähiges Medium, man hat eine Spule im Inneren, die halt sehr oft gewickelt ist und durch die man dann letztendlich einen Primärstrom treibt. Das große Problem dabei ist, man kann den Strom im Plasma nur so lange aufrechterhalten, wie man den Strom in der Primärspule halt ändert. Also genau wie bei einem Haushalts-Trafo. Und das führt halt zu der grundsätzlichen Eigenschaft des Tokamaks, dass er halt nur gepulstbetreibbar ist, weil irgendwann kommt man dann die Leistungsgänze seiner Stromversorgung, mit der man halt den Strom ändert.
Außerdem einfach ein Trafo braucht Wechselstrom. Ja. Sonst funktioniert das Induktionsgesetz nicht. Das ist ja ein DI nach DT. Also eine Änderung des Stromes, nach der Zeit mit induziert wird. Und das kann man nicht austrexten. Das ist ein grundsätzliches Physikproblem. Das heißt also beim Tokamak, da wird der Betrieb immer so sein. Nicht, dass man hoch fährt, runter fährt, hoch fährt, runter fährt. Und wenn wir jetzt wiederum über ein Tokamak-Kraftwerk reden, ist dieses Hochfahren, Runterfahren nicht in zehn Sekunden oder einer Sekunde, sondern da wird jetzt so in den Konzepten von sechs, acht Stunden geredet. Also sechs, acht Stunden wird er so hochgefahren und dann kurz eine halbe Stunde wieder runtergefahren, die Spule wieder entladen. Und dann wird er wieder hochgefahren und dann wird die zentrale Spule, diese zentrale Induktionsspule wieder entladen. Aber das ist nicht gut. Also vor allem so ein großes Wärmekraftwerk, wir reden da ja so von Gigawatt-Kraftwerken, die man so in acht Stundenzyklus immer hoch und runterfährt, der Ingenieur gruselt sich davor. Also das ist einfach jedes Mal ein thermischer Zyklus und ein Lastzyklus. Das heißt, man kriegt doch große Probleme mit den Materialien, weil das einfach auf die Ermüdung geht. Das heißt, man kriegt einfach eine zyklische Ermüdung. Das ist ein großer Malus, den wir hatten. Und es kommt noch ein zweiter dazu. Ein starker Strom in einem Plasma macht das Plasma nicht gerade angenehmer. Also das findet das Plasma eigentlich auch gar nicht lustig und reagiert darauf mit einer ganzen Klasse von Instabilitäten, die sich darin ausbreiten, die dann zu Fluktuationen dazu führen, die dazu führen, dass das Plasma heftig dem Plasmakefig entkommt, also wirklich da so richtig dramatisch ausbüxt. Und das kann im dramatischsten Falle dazu führen, dass es zu einer sogenannten Stromdisruption kommt. Denn man muss eins bedenken, prinzipbedingt ist das Plasma in einem Tokamak ein selbst organisiertes Gleichgewicht. Man beginnt ja mit einfach mit einem Nichts, mit Gas, also mit einem Magnetfeld und Gas. Und da muss man so ein bisschen Plasma erzeugen, mit Mikrowellen zum Beispiel, was in der Lage ist, überhaupt ein bisschen Strom zu führen. Das ist ja erst mal ein ganz mieses Plasma, eine ganz schlechte Leitfähigkeit, überhaupt ein bisschen Strom zu führen. Und das baut dann ein bisschen Magnetfeld auf und dann muss man noch mehr nachblasen und noch mehr Strom rein.
Um die Verdrillung zu erzeugen.
Dann hangelt sich das so hoch.
Das ist so ein Bootstrap-Problem.
Das ist ein Bootstrap-Problem, also wie Münchhausen, sich in die eigenen Schuhe aus dem Sumpf ziehen. Und damit hat man so ein bisschen ein leicht wackeliges Gleichgewicht, was sich so gerade eben selber hält. Und wenn das Leiseste schief geht, zum Beispiel sich so eine stromgetriebene Instabilität ausbildet, die sind eben besonders brutal, dann kann es leicht passieren, dass sich das Plasma dann abkühlt, damit die Leitfähigkeit erhöht. Der Strom dann eben behindert wird dadurch, die Leistfähigkeit schlechter wird, dann der Strom dadurch behindert wird. Und dann sackt einem das durch und dann geht es plötzlich so in eine Millisekunde rum, es fällt einem das ganze Plasma zusammen. Und das gibt auch ordentlich magnetische Kräfte. Also der größte Tuckermarkt der Welt in Kalem, wenn der eine Disruption hat. Also das ist auch so eine paar hundert Tonnen Maschine und die hobst dann doch schon einen halben Zentimeter hoch.
Das sieht wahrscheinlich ähnlich aus wie eure Maschine hier, mit irgendwie was so die Kabel und Schottdutzen und Planche.
Also schüttelt die Kiste schon ordentlich durch.
Also das ist noch dafür ausgelegt, bei den größeren Maschinen, die für die Zukunft geplant sind, die sind so schwer und so riesig und tragen auch so viel Strom, dass man sagt, das möchte man eigentlich gar nicht mehr haben.
Das ist nicht erlaubt, dann wäre es kaputt. Das heißt, Disruption muss man vermeiden. Das führt wiederum dazu, dass man da meilenweit von diesen Stabilitätsgrenzen weg bleibt, alle möglichen Maßnahmen, Regelungen, Schleifen einbaut, um diese Instabilitäten zu unterdrücken. Das heißt, man muss schon furchtbar kämpfen. Es gibt da einen passenden Ausspruch von einem Kollegen von mir, der viel mit Tokamaks gearbeitet hat. Er hat gesagt, Tokamaks are a terrible beast to control.
Das klingt hier schon ein bisschen wie Biologie. So ein Typ, der so einen Monster in den Käfig so piekt und guckt, wann es böse wird.
So ähnlich ist das. So und jetzt kommen wir zum Unterschied beim Stellarator. Wenn man jetzt einmal gemerkt hat, starker Strom im Plasma muss hoch und runter gerammt werden, erzeugt in Stabilitäten Stromabrisse und so. Ich rede jetzt sehr schlecht über den Tokamak, davor habe ich ja sehr gut über den Tokamak geredet. Also das gleicht das aus. Das ist eine toll funktionierte Maschine, die nach wie vor die besten Parameter liefert. Aber man muss sich mit diesem starken Strom im Plasma sehr arg rumschlagen. Das ist Fakt. Wie sieht es jetzt beim Stellarator aus? Der Stellarator hat keinen Strom im Plasma. Das braucht er nicht. Nicht die ganze Verdrillung des Magnetfeldes wird durch die bekloppten Spulen gemacht. So, damit ist man das Problem des Stroms los. Und wo kein Strom drin ist, gibt es auch keinen Stromabriss. Wo kein Strom drin ist, treibt dieser Strom auch keine Instabilitäten. Und man braucht auch keinen Strom induzieren. Das heißt, der ist automatisch dauerstrichfähig. Also der Stellarator ist in der Tat diese ringförmige Flasche, wo man das Plasma reinfüllt. Und dann bleibt es da, bis man es wieder rausnimmt.
Deswegen konntet ihr sozusagen auch schon quasi beim ersten Einschalten die Rekorde für Stabilität schlagen. Von allen anderen.
Naja, also viele Rekorde haben wir damit nicht geschlagen.
Wir sind froh, dass das funktioniert.
Weil wir erstmal nichts kaputt machen wollten. Also das heißt, wir haben erstmal als erstes per Verordnung, per interne Verordnung, haben wir die einzukoppelnde Heizenergie sehr beschränkt. Nämlich, das ist ja so, wir haben den Wendelstein jetzt in einen Zustand gebracht, wo wir damit so mal erste Testplasmen erzeugen können. Und vor allem die erste Wand, das heißt die Wand, die direkt mit dem Plasmen im Kontakt ist, im Inneren des Gefäßes, das ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie eine Stahlwand ist oder so was, sondern das ist eine Hightech-Wand, die ist noch nicht fertig ausgebaut, die ist also noch relativ empfindlich. Da haben wir jetzt so Strukturen, Kühlstrukturen, auf die wir jetzt noch in diesem weiteren Ausbauschritt, den wir jetzt gerade anfangen, noch 2000 Grafit-Kacheln, sehr genau gearbeitete Grafit-Kacheln, ranschrauben müssen. Erst diese Grafit-Kacheln sind widerstandsfähig genug, dass wir da mehr Energie in die Maschine einstecken können.
Aber beim Test hattet ihr doch jetzt schon tatsächlich Fusion erreicht?
Nein, wir werden nie Fusion erreichen. Also wir arbeiten ja auch ausschließlich mit Wasserstoffen, Deuterium. Tritium machen wir nie hier. Da haben wir gar keine Genehmigung für, das ist auch nicht Sinn dieser Maschine, das wäre auch sinnlos, das mit dieser Maschine zu machen. Also die ist zu klein, um wirklich daraus was zu lernen. Die müsste man größer machen, um wirklich mit Tritium zu arbeiten, sonst hat man da nichts draus. Da können wir auch nochmal drüber reden. Also das heißt, Fusion wollen wir hier nicht machen, sondern wir machen hier die Plasmaphysik für die Fusion. Unser Ziel ist es, Plasmen zu erzeugen, die relevant sind für Fusionsbedingungen. Also das heißt, den schwierigen Teil von der Fusion, nicht den leichten.
Also letztendlich die Temperatur zu erreichen, die wir dafür brauchen und die Temperatur aufrechtzuerhalten.
Was wir zu unserer eigenen Überraschung in der Tat schon erreicht haben, ist mit sehr wenig injizierter Energie haben wir schon sehr hohe Elektronentemperaturwerte bekommen. Also unsere Elektronen, also die leichte Spezies, die haben also locker die 100 Millionen Grad erreicht. Aber wo gemerkt, das sind die leichten. Das ist auch noch das etwas leichtere, insbesondere Heizung mit diesen Mikrowellen, direkte Elektronen. Also die Mikrowellen koppeln unmittelbar in die Elektronen ran. Das heißt, die kriegen die volle Hitzeklatsche gleich ab. Aber trotzdem haben wir da Berechnungen vorgehabt und die hatten allerlei konservative Annahmen. Die waren davon ausgegangen, naja, also hier hat man noch da und da und da und da Verluste, da kühlt es noch wieder ein bisschen ab. Die haben eher mit der Hälfte gerechnet. Das heißt, wir sind viel besser geworden, als wir gedacht haben. Und das hat uns zur Folge auch gehabt, wenn die Elektronen erstmal heiß sind, dann ziehen sie die, also durch Bomberdemont, durch Wärmeweitergabe, dann ziehen sie die Ionen mit. Da sind wir bei den Ionen auch recht hochgekommen. Da sind wir auf mindestens 10 Millionen, eher 20 Millionen Grad gekommen. Und das bei ganz popelig wenig Heizung. Also wir haben gerade nur 4 Megawatt reingesteckt. Das ist ja noch lächerlich.
Habt ihr das vorher gewusst oder war das eine Überraschung?
Das war eine Überraschung.
Das ist ein bisschen wie so...
Wisst ihr warum?
Nö, die Maschine funktioniert besser als gedacht. Aber ich sage ja, diese Computerberechnungen, das sind ja alles Quotes. Ein Computercode spiegelt ja niemals die ganze Wahrheit wieder, sondern das ist ja eben halt ein Satz von Grundgleichungen, die ganz gewiss wahr sind. Aber das ist in der Physik gerne mal so, dass die Lösung der Gleichungen vielmehr von den Randbedingungen abhängt. Das heißt also, das, was man noch zusätzlich annimmt, was so, ja, nicht weiß, an Rändern passiert, oder was als Anfangsbedingungen passiert und so weiter nicht. Das heißt also, wie man an die Gleichungen überhaupt rangeht, die zu lösen, was die Lösung bestimmt. Und das meine ich mit konservativ, nicht? Also, da sind sehr vorsichtige Annahmen gemacht worden, im Endeffekt in Quotes. So, damit man jetzt nicht zu viel verspricht.
Okay, das heißt also, dass es jetzt besser funktioniert hat, als offiziell erwartet. Ist aber auch tatsächlich eine Auswesst davon, dass also das Engineering besser war als erwartet, oder?
Ja, nee, das Engineering ist so gut wie gefordert, so gut wie spezifiziert. Die Spezifikation war natürlich sehr scharf. Generell ist es die Kombination daraus, wenn also, wenn man ein sauberes Engineering macht, kombiniert mit den konservativen Erwartungen, also mit den Erwartungen, die auf konservativ programmierten oder konservativ umgesetzt sind, kurzbasieren. Beides kombiniert sich dann dazu, dass solche Maschinen in der Regel besser funktionieren. Wir haben auch in der Geschichte der Fusion Maschinen gehabt, die viel schlechter funktioniert haben, als erwartet. Da war entweder was faul in der Berechnung, also richtig ein Fehler in der Berechnung. Viel häufiger war es aber schlampiges Engineering, das einfach misstig gearbeitet wurde.
Beim Rumlaufen hatte ich ohnehin den Eindruck, dass es erinnerte mich sehr an so mittelständischen Gerätebau, von allem, was so steht. Die Anlagentechnik und so sieht alles aus, wie man es im Highend-Mittelstand oder wissenschaftlichen Gerätebau kennt.
Aber die Geschichten, die wir dann hören, sind doch eher Raumschiff-Enterprise-mäßig. So Geschichten, wie das einfach eine Schweißnaht nicht gezogen werden kann, wie man das normalerweise macht. Erzähl doch mal hier ein paar von den Engineering-Geschichten, weil die fanden sehr faszinierend. Also Sachen, die man vorher nicht kommen sah, oder wo man die man vielleicht schon kommen sah, aber nicht klar war, wie man das dann kompensieren kann. Da gab es ja hier einige solche Geschichten.
Ja, dann könnte ich abendfüllend erzählen. Die Maschine ist voll mit solchen Horror-Stories. Ja, also wenn man mal mit der Schweißerei beginnt, also Schweißen ist ja sowieso so eine Kunst. Und das ist so eine schwarze Kunst, so eine Archämie. Weil man so ganz genau auch nie weiß, was passiert. Schweißen bedeutet ja, dass man sich mit flüssigem Metall in Verbindung mit festem Metall unter sehr komplexen Randbedingungen auseinandersetzen muss. Das heißt, man hat irgendeine Struktur unter rum. Und eben über den Schweißbogen macht man einen Teil dieses Schweißgut, macht unser Schweißgut flüssig und bringt das in Verbindung mit festem Metall. Und dann gibt es da so einen ganz komischen Übergang zwischen flüssig und fest. Und dann erstarrt das Ganze wieder und dann zieht sich das Ganze wieder zusammen, kühlt sich ab und dann passiert irgendwas.
Dann ist das ganz oft auch nicht reversibel. Das heißt, je Schweißer es erstmal gesetzt hat, dann ist sie da halt...
Ja, dann ist das auch hin. So, wenn sich da alles verzieht, das ist ein irrer Aufwand, das alles wieder zu korrigieren, wieder auseinanderzufräsen und wieder gerade zu biegen und so. Also jeder, der selber mal geschweißt hat, weiß, dass das so eine Tücke ist. Und diese ganze Tücke, die kulminiert in etwas, was man denn als Schweißverzug oder Schweißschrumpf bezeichnet. Das heißt, das ist so dieses Verziehen des Gesamtsystems. Also nicht der Schweißnaht alleine, nicht sondern alles dessen, womit sie umgeben ist. So und das führt hin dazu, dass wenn man etwa Metalle miteinander verschweißt, nicht also irgendwie einen großen Klotz auf ein Blech oder zwei Bleche aneinander, dass man höllisch aufpassen muss, was insgesamt mit dem gesamten zu schweißenden System passiert. Wenn man also eine solche Schweißnaht gesetzt hat, dann kann es passieren, dass danach alles rundherum, also schon um mehrere Millimeter oder gar um Zentimeter, anders ausgerichtet ist, als vorher sich verzogen hat. Jetzt ist es so, dass ja, also aus einem Gemisch an Gründen, wir sehr oft sehr hohe Ansprüche an den Schweißverzug stellen mussten. Man kann diese Gründe in zwei Kategorien unterteilen. Das eine ist der Heilige Gral, das sind die Magnete. Also die Magnete müssen präzise ausgerichtet sein zueinander, sonst ist das Magnetfeld Mist. Wenn das Magnetfeld Mist ist, dann ist die Leistung der Maschine schlecht. Also das, was wir gerade eben hatten. Also jetzt haben wir so tolle Werte vom Plasma, da hätten wir einfach schlechte Werte vom Plasma bekommen, weil die Magnete nicht gegeneinander korrekt ausgerichtet sind. Und das hätte passieren können, wenn die einfach schlunzig oder konventionell geschweißt worden wären. Und wo müsste denn da geschweißt werden bei den Magneten? Ja, wenn man sich das vorstellt, sind die Magnete, die schweben ja nicht einfach so im Raum, sondern die müssen miteinander verschraubt und verbunden werden. Und zwar einerseits um ihr eigenes Gewicht zu tragen, aber viel entscheidender, um die magnetischen Kräfte abzufahren. Eigentlich die magnetischen Kräfte, die erwähnte ich ja schon vorhin, das ist gerne mal ein 100-Tonnen-Bereich. Das heißt, da muss man schon große Strukturen dort einbauen, um die Magnete gegeneinander abzustützen. Das sind so 20 x 20 cm massive Stahlklötze, die dann zwischen die Stahlgehäuse der Spulen geschweißt werden müssen. Mit dicken, fetten Schweißnähten. Also mindestens 16 mm Schweißnähte. Dann muss man da einmal ganz rumbraten. Auf der Rückseite und auf der Vorderseite. Und richtig viel Schweißgut. So makroskopische Mengen Schweißgut werden dann eingebracht, um diese Verbindung herzustellen.
Vielleicht kurz eine 5 Sekunden Pause machen, damit sich jeder mal eine 16 mm Schweißnaht vorstellen kann. Das ist ein dicker Fingerbreit.
Das ist ein ordentlicher Klopper. Und da wird ordentlich Material reingebracht. Also entsprechend nach Adam Riese hat man bei einer 16 mm Schweißnaht, hat man da 10 cm Schweißverzug. 2 mm war absolute Schmerzgrenze. Und da haben wir also ein riesen Entwicklungsprogramm gestartet mit unseren Schweißern, um diesen Schweißverzug unter Kontrolle zu bringen. Und am Ende lief das darauf hinaus, dass immer kurze Strecken geschweißt werden. Das Ganze befindet sich dann permanent wie auf so einem OP-Tisch in der Vermessung. Das heißt also überall Lasertracker so rangebracht, die also die genaue Position der Spulen zueinander gemessen haben, also online gemessen haben. Da hat der Schweißer immer mal hier geschweißt, da geschweißt, mal geguckt, was passiert. Und um den Schweißverzug, um den Abkühlprozess unter Kontrolle zu halten, also um den nicht sich selbst zu überlassen, sondern kontrolliert zu halten, haben wir mit solchen Pistolen, mit Trockeneis das abgekühlt. Also mit Hochdruck-Trockeneis. Damit wurde es dann so schockgekühlt. Und das war ganz heikel, weil dann passiert es ganz schnell, dass das zu schnell abkühlt und sich Risse bilden. Dann ist die Schweißenart Schrott, wenn da Riss dran ist. Das heißt, man musste die feine Kunst finden, das sehr schnell abzukühlen, damit sich nicht irgendwelche Wärmewellen in den Gehäusen abkühlt, sondern dass es ganz rasch und wohl definiert abgekühlt wird, ohne dass es Risse bildet. Das war die ganze Sache mit den Lateralabstützungen zwischen den Spulen.
Und dann gab es ja noch diesen Trick, mal von links und mal von rechts zu schweißen.
Das ist nämlich die zweite Kategorie von Brummplagerei mit Schweißverzug. Das hat ja nichts mit den Magneten zu tun, das war einfach die Platzprobleme. Denn in diesem äußeren Gefäß, diesen Krüos-Daten, da ist nicht viel platztern, also der ist voll ausgefüllt.
Leitungen, Kabel, Spulen.
Die Spulen selber, Leitungen, Kabel, Stützstrukturen, alles total vollgestopft und nichts darf die Wand berühren. Die Wand ist ja viel wärmer als...
Und warum habt ihr nicht einfach 10 Zentimeter größer gebaut?
Das ist die Gretchenfrage. Heute würde ich es so tun, ja.
Also wäre jetzt eine der Lehren aus dem Projekt gewesen?
Das ist eine Lehre aus dem Projekt. Ich hätte den Krüos-Daten 40 Zentimeter mehr Durchmesser gegeben.
Weil dann könnte man zumindest an dieser Stelle mit dem Nier-Spreis-Schweiß-Watz auch gehen.
Dann hätte man da ein bisschen weniger aufpassen müssen. Das ist richtig. Es gilt aber generell die goldene Regel des Anlagenbaus von krüogenen Anlagen, dass man mit Volumen des Krüos-Daten geizt. Denn Krüos-Daten-Volumen ist teuer. Das ist einfach teuer. Warum ist es teuer? Der gesamte Krüos-Daten muss thermisch isoliert werden. Denn innen drin wohnen große Strukturen, also in unserem Falle hier diese 430 Tonnen Material, die auf minus 270 Grad auf 3,4 Kelvin abgekühlt werden und wenig davon entfernt. Teilweise nur so zwei, vier, fünf Zentimeter entfernt ist die warme Welt, unsere Welt, die Raumtemperaturwelt.
Der für die Spuren 300 Grad heiß ist.
Der für die Spuren 300 Grad heiß ist. Das heißt, man muss dazwischen eine thermische Isolation und eine Jacke anziehen. Diese Jacke, das ist natürlich auch wieder so eine Hightech-Jacke. Das sind 20 Lagen, aluminiumbeschichtete, geknitterte Kaptonfolie.
Hat das Knitternes Absicht?
Ja, das Knitternes Absicht.
Die lernt dazu.
Nein, die ist geknittert, weil dadurch das Infrarotlicht dann eben halt so gestreut wird. Das wird dann einfach so diffuser weggestreuten. Das bringt einen Faktor 1,2 oder so was. Also geknitterte Kaptonfolie und dann wird darauf noch ein thermisches Schild. Das ist in dem einen, also beim Außengefäß, ist das Messing und das wird dann aktiv gekühlt mit gasförmigem Helium bei 70 Kelvin. Und das muss alles daran geschnallt werden. Das ist einfach teuer. Nicht in die größere Fläche, nicht desto teurer wird das. Das heißt, da hat man gegalzt, ein bisschen an der falschen Stelle gegalzt. Am Ende haben wir teuer bezahlen müssen dafür. Das war ein kleiner Fehler.
Aber gut, ich meine, das sind ja die Dinge, warum man sich das mal ausprobiert.
Und eben halt dieses Außengefäß, jetzt wieder zum Schweißen zurückzukommen. Also wir haben wahnsinnig wenig Platz in kures Daten. Das heißt, diese Einzelteile des Außengefäßes, dieses Außengefäß besteht also aus einer Unterschale, einer Oberschale. Das bildet dann eben halt so dieses eine Modul. Wir reden da von fünf Modulen. Der Wendelstein-Siemix ist eher so ein Pentagon, was aus fünf Modulen besteht. Und dieses Modul, das hat dann so eine Kesselform, einfach so eine zylindrische Kesselform. Und dieser Kessel, der ist an der Horizont, also am Equator ist der aufgeschnitten. Der besteht also aus zwei Hälften.
Also wie ein Bälgel, den man dann mit der Durchsteigerkasse unter an fünf Segmente teilt.
Ja, unter an fünf Segmente. Also wie, ja genau. Und das ist so aufgeschnitten. Und diese obere Deckel und der untere Deckel, die werden so aufeinandergesetzt, wenn der Magnet dann eingesetzt ist. Das Magnetsystem mit den 14 Magneten wird da eingesetzt. Das wiegt dann für sich schon 135 Tonnen. Wird das so Millimeter genau eingesetzt. Und da ist dann nur noch ganz wenig Platz drin. Dann wird dieser Deckel da oben aufgesetzt und dann müssen diese großen Schweißnähte da gesetzt werden. Also die großen Equatorial-Schweißnähte. Die Schweißnähte einmal um den eigentlichen Ring.
Moment, das heißt, die Anlage ist zugeschweißt?
Ja.
Das heißt also, sie kommt nur noch mit der Flex an eure Magneten?
Ja, das ist aber kein Problem.
Also deswegen sind die Magnete uns auch so unglaublich wichtig, weil die da rauszuholen, das ist echt eine Aufgabe.
Also in dem Sinne ist es ja wohl ein Problem. Ein Magnet darf nie ausfallen. Warum stecken wir in ganz großen Problemen?
Macht man das nicht mit Schraubverbindungen, Flanschen, irgendwas?
Ja, man hätte das auch schrauben können, aber das ist auch wieder wahnsinnig teuer. Also wirklich sehr sehr teuer, solche großen verschraubten Flanschen.
Und die müssen dann ultrapräzise sein mit dem Vakuum?
Ja, das ist einfach so ein Riesending. Das muss sehr präzise sein, die Dichtflächen müssen ganz präzise darauf sein, ich werde ein hiesen Gewicht. Und im Ende hat nichts davon, man will es ja gar nicht auseinanderschrauben.
Also man muss einfach sich darauf verlassen können, dass die Magnete nicht ausfallen.
Die Magnete muss man einfach so bauen, dass die nicht ausfallen. Punkt.
Noch ordentliche Qualitätssicherung.
Genau, wie macht ihr das eigentlich? Weil ich meine, das ist ja schon weit jenseits von allem, was man so aus der Industrie kennt, also außerhalb des Raumfahrtbaus.
Ja, mein Gott, also das ist eben, eigentlich ist das Qualitätssicherung. Das sind Prozeduren, also sehr viele, sehr genaue Prozeduren, viel Papierkram, also eine ziemliche Papiermühle hier am Laufen, der dafür sorgt, dass alles, was eben vorher konstruiert ist, auch wirklich so umgesetzt wird. Und natürlich muss man eine saubere Konstruktion haben. Das ist auch wieder so ein Sektor, wo wir sagen können, ein Schwein gehabt. Also ohne, wieder mal kommt der Computer rein, also ohne dieses massive computer aided design, das massive Cut, was wirklich auch schon mit relativ schnellen Maschinen, das sind, na gut, das sind so Doppelprozessor-Linux-Maschinen oder sowas, auch nichts ganz besonderes mehr. Aber trotzdem, vor 15 Jahren oder so was hätte man die nicht gehabt. Und nur dadurch konnte man wirklich dieses dreidimensionale Konstruktionswesen denn davon machen. Wir haben also von dieser ganzen Maschine haben wir ein komplettes Modell. Also nichts, was man da sieht, ist nicht im Modell enthalten. Also kein einziges Rohr, kein einziges Kabel, was da dran ist, ist nicht im Modell enthalten. Umgekehrt, es wurde nicht ein einziges Kabel gelegt, ohne dass es vorher in das Modell eingepflegt wurde. Da ahnt man schon, was das für ein monströses Modell ist. Ich habe sie ja auch von mehreren Millionen Teilen.
Und dann irgendwelche Modifikationen dran zu machen.
Na gut und...
Da gibt es dann auch keinen Homer Simpson, der da mal eben noch was reinzieht irgendwo.
Also mal eben ist man gar nicht, wenn man mal was ändern will, dann muss man eine Change Note auslösen. Und das ist dann ein zehnseitiges Dokument, wo man sich dann erklären muss, was man denn dort tut.
Und wo Note sehr euphemistisch ist.
Ja und wo sehr viele Unterschriften und Stempel und Kontrollen durchgeführt werden. Und es geht nicht anders. Weil ansonsten würde genau das passieren, dass irgendwie kleine Fuscher reingemacht werden und dann funktioniert das Ganze nicht. Und natürlich alles, was getan wird, wird dann mindestens noch einmal angeguckt. Also vier Augen im Prinzip bis zum Umfallen.
Und wo habt ihr die, also ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nicht so der traditionelle, sage ich mal wissenschaftliche Gerätebau. Der ist ja doch eher so ein bisschen mehr ad hoc. Wo habt ihr diese Kompetenz herbekommen?
Naja, also ein Teil ist einfach gute Ingenieurkunst, nicht wie man sie im Ingenieurwesen lernt. Also das heißt gerade so Qualitätssicherungsingenieure.
Ist ja mehr so Luftfahrtechnik oder so.
Die Ingenieure, die kann man schon auch so einfach einkaufen. Also das heißt, um erst mal so eine Basiskompetenz herzustellen. Das heißt, wir haben ja ein sehr, sehr großes Ingenieurteam. Also in den Peak-Zeiten hatten wir jetzt über 200 Ingenieure. Jetzt sind wir noch so bei 120 oder so was. Die haben sich einfach auf der Basis ihrer Ausbildung viel von diesen Sachen einfach erarbeitet. Wo holt man das her? Wir haben viel von Airbus gelernt, muss ich sagen.
Also Luftfahrt.
Wir haben oft mit Airbus zusammengesessen, haben unser ganzes Änderungsmanagement, das Change-Management, das haben wir uns immer wieder bei Airbus so reflektiert. Die waren freundlich genug, uns dabei zu helfen. Dann haben wir mit dem Desi in Hamburg oft mal zusammengekluckt. Die haben ja schon einiges hinter sich mit ihrem Beschleunigerbau. Da haben wir eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge rausgezogen. Ein paar Sachen vom Zern, von dem Beschleuniger. Also die Beschleuniger-Physiker, die sind so ein bisschen auf unserer Seite. Also am ersten lernen wir was aus der Luftfahrt und von den Beschleunigern. Raumfahrt ist irgendwie anders. Also die haben auch irre Qualitätsansprüche. Aber da geht es eher so um Vibrationsfestigkeit und um thermische Zyklen und um Langzeitzuverlässigkeit.
Und um Akkus.
Ja, ne, wir haben, ja, ne, hoch- und herunterfahren gibt es ja auch. Also ohne thermische Zyklen kommt man hier auch nicht hin. Die haben ganz komische thermische Zyklen.
Immer wenn die Sonne auf die eine Seite und das Weltall auf der anderen Seite.
Also das ist auch sehr, sehr anspruchsvoll, nicht? Also wenn wir da nach Göttingen geht zum MPS, zum Max-Pank-Institut für Systemforschung, da fummeln da auch an diesen schicken Satelliten darum, bauen dafür Instrumente, das ist auch schon sehr, also würde ich sagen, die gleiche Schwierigkeitsklasse lockert nicht, die wir denn so haben. Und die Zuverlässigkeitsansprüche sind vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen höher. Nicht, das wird ja einfach gestartet und es ist weg.
Da kommt man nie wieder ran, genau. Wir können wenigstens noch die Flex nehmen.
Wir können wenigstens noch aufschweißen und wieder reinlagen. Und wir haben auch ein paar Deckel drauf, nicht diese großen Deckel, die wir dir da gesehen haben. Die dienen auch dazu, um mit den größeren Daten dazu zumindest reinzukommen. Man kann leider nicht einkriechen, dafür ist zu wenig Platz. Aber man kommt dann, entscheidende neuralgische Stellen kommt man dann auch an.
Verstehe, also nächstes Mal auch größer bauen, um reingehen zu können.
Na ja, das wäre ein bisschen großzügig, dass man da so ein bisschen ein Roboter reinzuschicken. Dass man da so ein bisschen marschieren kann. Also vielleicht eine Ratte oder sowas. Eine Schweißratte.
Ich habe gesehen, unten in diesem einen Mock-Up, der vor der Halle steht, übt er das mit diesen Grafitplatten gerade. Also diese Grafitplatten. Da steht eine Roboter-Arm drin. Was tut ihr da?
Der sieht so nach Roboter aus, als ob er eine Vermessungsarm.
Ach so.
Also ich meine, Vermessung gehört natürlich zum großen Bereich der Metrologie. Da sind wir wieder bei einem Bereich, wo wir Schwein gehabt haben. Nämlich ebenfalls mit den Technologien der 90er Jahre, da hätten wir es nicht gepackt. Da hätten wir das Ding nicht zusammenbauen können.
Also die Messpräzision wäre nicht ausreichend gewesen?
Ja, einfach die Instrumente wären nicht da gewesen.
Also das Problem ist ja tatsächlich die Dreidimensionalität, dass man nicht einfach von einem Punkt aus ohne weiteres zum nächsten Montierpunkt gelangt, sondern dass tatsächlich alles dreidimensional absolut im Raum gefunden werden muss.
Also das heißt, wir haben insgesamt unsere Koordinatensysteme eingemessen in der ganzen Halle, ein absolutes Koordinatensystem. Und daran kalibrieren sich auch die Lasertrecke und daran wird alles kalibriert, nicht? Das heißt, wir haben die ganze Halle, wo die Maschine drin steht und wo die Maschine selber drin steht, das ist eben halt auf einen Sub-Millimeter-Bereich genau ausgemessen.
Das heißt, ihr habt einen Koordinaten-Ursprung in der Halle und von da aus ist jedes Teil positioniert?
Genau, das heißt, wir wissen von jedem Teil mit einer Genauigkeit besser als ein Millimeter, wo es sich in der Halle befindet.
Und wie im Raum.
Jede Schraube, ja, und wie sie im Raum gekippt ist. Das geht nur, indem man die ganze Montage mit einem konsequenten Vermessungsprogramm dann eben sieht. Das geht eben mit verschiedenen Methoden. Lasertracker haben wir schon immer wieder darüber gesprochen. Das Lasertracker funktioniert ja so, dass man ja so einen kleinen Reflektorspiegel irgendwo aufbringt und der Laser schnappt sich den und dann verfolgt er einfach die Position dieses Spiegels. Hört sich sehr einfach an, sind weil sehr tolle, aufwendige, teure Geräte. Und dann gibt es weitere Methoden. Das sind so Laserscanner. Die scannen so Oberflächen ab und bilden die auch in ihrer ganzen Krümmung ab, sodass man dann in ein Computermodell wiederum auch alle gekrümten, alle gerundeten, gekrümten Fläche, Rohren und so was alles bekommt. Dann gibt es Fotogrammetrie. Da fotografiert man aus verschiedenen Perspektiven die Maschine und dann wird das mit Software zusammengesetzt und dann aus diesem zusammengesetzten Bild wird diese dreidimensionale Struktur wieder rekonstruiert. Und was für die praktische Montage sehr wichtig sind, das ist genau der Roboterarm, den du da gesehen hast. Das sind solche Vermessungsarme und das ist im Prinzip so ein spitzer Stift, also wie so eine Fingerspitze und den führt man an eine Position. Und da hängt dieser Arm dran und dieser Arm ist ausgestattet mit Sensoren, mit solchen Dreh- und Positionssensoren. Der Arm wird vorher auch eingemessen, wiederum in dieses Absolutsystem und da wo diese Spitze hin zeigt, ist eine absolute Position. Das heißt also ein Schweißer bei uns, der einen Bolzen irgendwo anschweißen muss, der nimmt diesen Vermessungsarm, führt diesen Bolzen mit diesem Vermessungsarm eine Position und dann reißt er das an und da schweißt er an. Wo soll er sonst wissen, wo er einen Bolzen hinsetzen soll?
Dass er irgendwo auf einer gekrumpten Oberfläche irgendwo im Raum ist?
Mit einem Zollstock geht das nicht oder mit einem Meter weiß.
Montage Roboter gibt es doch auch noch mal.
Ja, es gibt nichts, desto trotz, weil das auch so mühsam ist, das alles mit der Hand zu machen. Gerade dieses ganze Bolzen setzen. Das haben wir vorher ausprobiert. Ein Schweißer nimmt sich einen Bolzen mit dem Messarm dann hinterher und dann muss er das dann anreißen und dann wieder ablegen und dann verliert er den Bolzen und da haben wir gesagt, das ist zu ineffizient, da verlieren wir zu viel Zeit. Und da haben wir dann eine Firma, also das war EADS, also der Maschinenbauzweig von EADS, der ist ein Rostock, Rostock Systemtechnik. Die haben für uns viele Werkzeuge gebaut und da haben wir die beauftragt, einen solchen Hilfsroboter für uns zu entwickeln. Und das ist quasi das Gleiche, auch wieder so ein Arm, aber der schnappt sich den Bolzen, hat ihn so in der Hand, das ist eine Roboterhand, und dann gibt man die Koordinate ein und dann hält er den da hinten fest. Und dann muss der Schweißalber uns hin und muss es dann bloß einmal festschweißen.
Moment, das heißt, das, was ihr jetzt tut, das heißt, ihr habt die Bolzen noch nicht, bevor ihr das Ding zum ersten Mal zusammengebaut habt, da reingeschweißt?
Also die ganzen Bolzen, an denen die ganzen Gefäßeinbauten jetzt befestigt sind, das waren so pro Modul, glaube ich 500 Stück oder so was, die alle an die Wand geschweißt werden mussten, um irgendwie Haltepunkte dafür zu haben. Das mussten wir irgendwo an festschrauben. Nicht so wie wenn man Nagel in die Wand haut und ein Bild anzuhängen. Diese Bolzen, die haben wir erst ganz am Ende eingebaut. Die waren vorher nicht da. Das heißt, da sind unsere Monteure, unsere Schweißer sind allerdings in die Maschine reingekrochen. Da haben wir also fünf Teams, vier, fünf Leute da drin gehabt. Also das heißt, bis zu 25 Leute haben wir. Warum? Man könnte sich ja denken, dass es praktischer ist, das vorher zu machen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn man die Bleche in der Hand hat, bevor man sie zusammenbaut, ist das doch viel einfacher.
Naja, gut, aber dagegen sprechen wieder Dinge. Nämlich diese Bolzen, das sind ja auch nicht so dicke Dinge. Das sind solche relativ flimsigen Teile, damit man auch nicht so viel Masse wieder da drin hat. Gibt auch wieder gute Gründe dafür. Wenn man diesen ganzen Igel davor eingebaut hätte und hätte dann diese ganzen Montagearbeiten innen und außen gemacht, hätten wir die alle krumm und schiefgetreten.
Ach so, wegen?
Das hat schon dagegen gesprochen, das zu machen. Zweitens, das ist wieder der etwas lächerlichere Grund, die Gefäßeinbauten selber haben wir wieder parallel zu den anderen Arbeiten entwickelt. Das heißt, wir wussten auch noch gar nicht, wo die Bolzen noch hin sollen. Die waren alle noch in der Fertigung. Wir hatten gar keine Aufpunkte.
Okay, just in time engineering.
Ja, das ist ja alles immer gerade rechtzeitig auf dem letzten Drücker fertig geworden. Und dann so, wie soll es sein, dass das fünfmal geändert worden ist? Also auch die ursprüngliche Zeichnung hat mit der ersten Version gar nichts mehr zu tun, weil dann dauernd das Konzept geändert werden muss, weil man in der Hand dann doch nicht angekommen ist, nicht um das zu machen oder weil das miteinander gestoßen hat und alles nicht gepasst hat. Das heißt, das Zeug hatten wir auch erst, als die Maschine dann schon quasi fertig war. Wenn wir weitgehend fertig waren, hatten wir die Gefäße einbauten zur Verfügung.
Und die Grafitplatten baut ihr jetzt aber erst ein?
Die bauen wir jetzt erst ein. Die haben wir einfach weggelassen, weil wir keine Zeit mehr dazu hatten.
Also der erste Betrieb war quasi mit einem Limiter heißt das. Das ist also einfach ein Ring oder mehrere Ringe, die an bestimmten Stellen im Plasmagefäß sitzen und quasi einfach den Radius des Plasmas letztendlich begrenzen.
Begrenzen, dass die Wand nicht berührt, okay.
Genau, das haut dann einfach da auf Grafit, also das sind auch Grafit-Kacheln, aber halt ringformig angeordnet. Da spart man halt sehr viel Material, die sind auch sehr viel einfacher einzubauen. Und dann sagt man einfach, da ist Schluss. Also hinter diesem Ring ist oder weiter außen als dieser Ring ist halt kein Plasma mehr. Das ist auf vielen Gründen nicht so schön, aber funktioniert halt erst mal.
Um mal die Gesamtanlage zu testen.
Genau, und da hängt ja auch ganz viel anderes dran, wie Kalibrierung von Instrumenten. Wir haben jetzt auch eine unglaubliche Menge an Daten, durch die wir erst mal durchgehen müssen und Diagnostiken, die noch weiter entwickelt werden müssen, weil sich herausgestellt hat, dass das irgendwie gar nicht so richtig funktioniert. Diese erste Betriebsweise war nicht nur psychologisch wichtig, um die Maschinen am Laufen zu haben und zu zeigen, dass wir es geschafft haben, sondern auch wirklich um die Daten zu generieren.
Ja, das war schon ein wichtiges Prinzip, auf das wir uns alle eingeschworen haben, was wir gesagt haben, so früh wie möglich Sportplasma machen und damit Erfahrungen sammeln. Man kann immer mehr mit so einer Maschine machen und immer weiter ausbauen, dies und das, das ist ja auch noch ganz schön, aber halt irgendwo erst mal anfangen. Und so einfach wie möglich. Das ist gut für die Maschine, das ist auch gut für die Leute.
Aber ich habe mal eine ganz triviale Frage zu den Kacheln. Wie baut die letzte ein?
Wieso die letzte?
Na ja, weil ich meine, man kann ja immer hinter langen.
Die Schraube ist von vorne.
Ach so, die ist von vorne.
Die ist auch eingezogen.
Die ist von vorne, die ist ganz tief versenkt.
Okay, also dann kommt von vorne.
Und damit die Schraube nicht wieder eine üble Wechselwirkung mit dem Plasma hat, so als Metall, Metall und Plasma, was man schlecht nicht ist, wird die dann auch noch diamantbeschichtet.
Was?
Okay, eine DLC-Schicht wird darauf gelegt. Diamond-like-Carbon heißt das ja.
Wobei man dazusagen muss, dass die Feldlinien in einem sehr schrägen Winkel auf dieser Karren treffen. Das heißt, weil das Feld ja größtenteils so oedal ist, trifft das in so einem schrägen Winkel drauf, dass der Kontakt mit den Schrauben wahrscheinlich sehr sehr gering ist, aber man weiß ja nicht.
Kein Risiko.
Nichts anbrennen lassen, machen wir nochmal Diamant-Schliff. Okay.
Was sagt ihr denn den Leuten, die vorher gesagt haben, das kann man gar nicht bauen? Hätten fast recht gehabt.
Ja, muss man sagen. Denen zeige ich, das war knapp. Ich meine, wir sind so gerade durchgekommen. Also es gab ein paar Mal schon Momente beim Bau dieser Maschine, wo man sich so dachte, könnte schief gehen.
Das war so ein Moment.
Also wir hatten eine große Krise mit den Spulen. Grundsätzlich Spulen bauen ist nicht so fürchtlich. Also auch superleitende Spulen bauen ist nicht so fürchterlich schwierig. Also das ist auch Standard. Also hier die Kernspinnentomographen, die haben auch superleitende Spulen und so was. Das sind jetzt ja MNR. Und auch die in dieser Form zu bauen, ist nicht so ein Hexenwerk. Aber wir mussten da auch durchaus Risiko auf uns nehmen, weil wir keine Ersatzspulen gefertigt haben. Dafür war kein Geld. Also alle Spulen müssen funktionieren, weil wir uns gesagt haben, dass alle Spulen müssen auch hier funktionieren und lange funktionieren. Haben wir alle Spulen getestet. Und für diesen Test ist also jede Spule, nachdem die Wickelpakete entweder in Augsburg oder in Genoa hergestellt wurden, das war so ein Firmenkonsortium, ein deutsch-italienisches Firmenkonsortium, sind die nach Leipzig gegangen, um dann in die Stahlgehäuse eingebettet zu werden und verschweißt und instrumentiert. Und von Leipzig, also Zeits bei Leipzig, sind die dann nach Paris gefahren worden und in Paris dann zwei Monate lang einem intensiven Testprogramm unterzogen worden, wo sie dann das erste Mal abgekühlt wurden, in super leiten Zustand gebracht wurden, wo alle Flussraten für Helium geprüft wurden, wo die Vakuumeigenschaften geprüft wurden und wo auch die Hochspannungsfestigkeit geprüft worden. Denn die Spulen sind spezifiziert, dass sie 10.000 Volt hochspannungsfest sein müssen. Das hört sich jetzt ganz irre an. Warum sollte man das machen? 10.000 Volt Hochspannungsfestigkeit gegen Erde. Beim Supraleiter, also eigentlich logisch zusammenstöpselt, denkt man, beim Supraleiter dürfte auch gar keine Spannung auftreten. Also minimalsten. Aber wir haben es ja leider mit einer Spule zu tun. Eine Spule hat eine Induktivität. Wenn man den Strom sehr schnell rausnimmt, was passieren kann, wenn man eine Schnellabschaltung machen muss, dann kommt es zu einer hohen induzierten Spannung. Die kann bis zu zweieinhalb Kilovolt betragen. Dann geht man immer auf Nummer sicher und multipliziert es mit vier. Also waren die vier 10.000 Volt spezifiziert. Da sind die Reihenweise durchgefallen. Dann mussten diese Spuren wieder zurück zum Hersteller und mühsam wieder aufgefräst werden. Mit Zahnarztbohren wurden die dann aufoperiert. Da wurde extra ein Schweizer für eingestellt, ein ganz sorgfältiger Schweizer.
War der Zahnarzt?
Nee, der ist Supraleitungsexperte. Der ist eine Ein-Mann-Firma in der Schweiz betragt. Und der hat dann dort für zwei Jahre lang campiert und hat 30 Spulen wieder aufgefräst mit seinen Zahnarztbohren, um diese Isolationsfehler zu finden. Und da stand es manchmal schon auf der Kippe, nämlich dann war es auch wirklich nicht klar, ob wir diese Isolationsfehler, ob wir den wirklich beseitigen können. Und dann hätten wir eine Spule verloren. Wenn wir eine Spule verloren hätten, dann hätten wir einen tiefen Problem gesteckt.
Und nochmal 30 Spulen neu fertigen, wäre einfach nicht gegangen.
Das hätte einfach Jahre gedauert.
Weil es so eine Sonderfertigungstechnologie ist?
Naja, das ist halt so ein langer Rattenschwanz. Also das dauert einfach seine Zeit. Wie baut man überhaupt eine Superleitende Spule? Es fängt damit an, dass man den Superleiter herstellen muss. Den kann man nicht einfach von der Kabeltrommel kaufen. Der wird so hergestellt, der wird so gezogen. Und den hatten wir damals von zwei Firmen machen lassen. Also eine italienische und eine deutsche Firma. Die sind jetzt alle von den Finnen übernommen worden. Also jetzt müsste man das von den Finnen machen lassen. Also die notwendigen Längen Superleiter herzustellen, das hätte wahrscheinlich ein Jahr gedauert. Dann müssten daraus Kabel gemacht werden. Das heißt, die werden dann so verdrillt, dann werden so Kabelbündel daraus gemacht. Die werden dann coextrudiert. So heißt das, also in so ein Rohr hineingezogen, in ein Aluminiumrohr reingezogen, sodass in diesem Aluminiumrohr das flüssige Helium fließen kann, sodass es dann schön dieses Kabel umspült. Und dann aus diesen Rohren werden dann die eigentlichen Windungen der Spule gemacht. Da braucht man dafür eine große Windungsmaschine, die eben diese Windungspakete in die richtige Form bringt. Dann wird das Ganze mit Harz vergossen. Das Ganze wird dann in ein Stahlgehäuse eingebettet. Also das ist schon eine ganz schöne Produktionskette, die man da anschmeißen muss. Wenn man das mal so durchrechnet, das sind etwa zwei Jahre.
Das klingt jetzt aber nicht so, als wenn da ein einsamer Schweizer mit seinem Zahnarztbohrer irgendwas finden könnte. Wie hat man sich denn das vorzustellen?
Naja, der einsame Schweizer, der wusste halt die richtige Stelle, wo diese Isolationsfehler auftreten. Zumindest hat er die Stelle spekuliert. Und auf der Basis von Daten, denn wir haben ein paar Beobachtungsdaten dann da abgeliefert, man findet solche Isolationsfehler mit einem ganz einfachen Trick. Das ist auch wieder ein plasmophysikalischer Trick, das ist die sogenannte Paschenentladung. Da liegt man also so eine Spule unter Spannung, da lässt man etwas Gas einströmen und dann kommt es dort zu einer kleinen Entladung. Das heißt, es blitzt dort auf, nicht an der Stelle, nicht wo quasi ein Kabel offen liegt oder sowas, nicht wo ein elektrischer Kontakt offen liegt. Dann guckt man mit der Kamera rauf und dann sieht man da so ein bisschen flackerndes Licht. Diese Kameradaten haben die Schweizer gesagt, da ist was faul und da ist er dann mit seinen Zahnarztbohren rangegangen, hat sich dann das Haar zu lange vorgebohrt und hat das alles wieder so freigelegt, bis er dort diese Risse oder diese Hohlräume gefunden hat, die übel Täter waren, wo Gaseinschluss war und damit dann zu Isolationsschwächen gekommen ist. Da kann man sich noch fragen, da hätte die Trottel doch einfach verzichten können auf die Hochspannungsfestigkeit, aber dann muss ich sagen, könnte ich eigentlich nicht mehr ruhig schlafen, weil nicht bei so einer Schnellentladung, die man ja macht, wenn man eh ein anderes Problem hat. Genau, nicht Schnellentladungen passieren, wenn ein anderes Problem ist. Zum Beispiel ein Problem, dass in diesen Krüasdaten, in diesem Volumen, wo die Magnete drin wohnen, dass es dazu im Gaseinbruch kommt. Und dann ist das ganz automatisch verbunden mit einer schneller Abladung. Da hat man genau diese Kombination, Gas strömt rein, es kommt eine Schnellabladung, die Spannung geht hoch und man zündet einen Schweißbogen. Und dieser Magnet, der speichert 600 Megajoule magnetische Energie.
Das ist schon dicker Schweiß.
Das haben wir mal so abgeschätzt, also ein 1 Meter Loch ist da locker schnell gemacht und da wäre die ganze Anlage short. Mit einer Schnellentladung wäre die short. Da hat man mal so eben eine Milliarde versenkt. Das kann man nicht riskieren. Deshalb haben wir gesagt, diese Magnete müssen funktionieren.
Und wenn man jetzt die Komplexität von euren Magneten mit z.B. so vom Zorn vergleicht?
Ach, das ist ganz anders. Die Zernmagnete sind ja so Dipole und Quattupole. Also das sind so entweder Vierleiter, Quattupole, nicht so, durch die Strom durchfließt oder Dipole, Zweileiter. Das sind gar nicht solche geschlossenen Spulen.
So solche Stabmagnete.
Und die arbeiten mit wesentlich weniger Strom, nebenbei gesagt. Also der Nennwert beim Zern, das sind 8000 Ampere. Das ist ganz lächerlich bei uns. Wir haben 18.500 nicht und mehr Strom ist auch mal gleich heiklerer Geschichte. Und was der entscheidende Unterschied auch ist, nicht die also diese Dipole und Quadrupole sind alle gleich. Das heißt, wir haben fünf verschiedene Typen, die aber so miteinander eben halt so ein bisschen komisch verschachtelt sind. Das heißt, die gesamte Aufbau Komplexität, die ist schon ein bisschen höher. Und die Zahnleute haben uns ja auch hier oft besucht. Und gerade mit den Magnetleuten haben wir viel zu tun gehabt. Die haben uns auch beraten an verschiedenen Fragen. Die haben immer gesagt, naja, das Ding ist ja verdammt klein. Aber mein Gott, ist das komplizierend. Bei denen ist das alles sehr groß, aber sehr repetitiv. Die haben ihre Module und dann werden die einfach in Serie gemacht und aneinander gepappt. Und dann macht man das halt im Umfang von wie viel? Im Umfang ist das 50 Kilometer oder was nicht so.
Noch mal kurz zur Erklärung für die, die es nicht wissen, so ein Supralitner Magnet. Wie funktioniert der eigentlich?
Also wie Supraleitern funktionieren?
Supraleitern können wir voraussetzen, aber wie baut man damit ein Magnet und warum macht man das so?
Man nimmt sich einen Supraleiter, also quasi einen Supraleitenden Strang und wickelt den letztendlich in eine Spulenform und schließt dann letztendlich zwei Netzteile an das Ding an. Was auch nicht ganz trivial ist, weil man muss ja den komischen Übergang schaffen von Normalleitern zu Supraleitern, was bei uns auch ein ganz komplexes Bauteil ist, aber ja.
Um den Strom wieder wegzunehmen, weil der sowieso im Kreis fließt oder?
Nee, unsere Supraleiter sind ständig an die Netzteile zum Nachregeln angeschlossen. Das heißt, die regeln die ganze Zeit den Strom auf genau diese 18:500 Ampere, die wir dann halt brauchen. Das heißt, die werden nicht geschlossen.
Aber nur ganz klein bisschen, wenn so ein Prozent oder sowas führend über sie nach. Also im detail für das, also als Bauanleitung, mal wenn sich jemand das mal selber bauen will, so ein Stellaratur, läuft das im Prinzip so, dass so eine Spule, kann man ja sagen, macht einfach ganz viele Wicklungen oder sowas. Nicht so würde man das zu Hause machen, einfach mit Kupferdraht ganz viele Wicklungen machen an eine Spule. Aber ganz so macht man es bei einer vernünftigen Superleitenspule nicht, sondern man macht sogenannte Pancakes. Das sind also Lagen. Das sind eigentlich Schnecken. Das heißt, man macht eine Schnecke aus Superleiter. Dieser Superleiter, das ist ja so ein relativ steifes Kabel, weil der eigentliche Leiter in so ein Alu-Rohr drin ist.
Wobei das Alu-Rohr hier der Isolator ist.
Nö, der leitet schon.
Ja, aber im Vergleich zu Superleitern.
Wenn der Superleiter in Ordnung ist, dann ist das eben egal. Aber wenn der Superleiter nicht mehr Superleitend ist, dann ist das schon wichtig, dass der Strom daran fließen kann. Deshalb müssen die wiederum noch von einer Isoliert werden, die beiden. Also auf jeden Fall ist das so eine Schnecke, die so aus diesem Alu-Rohr gemacht wird. Und in dem Alu-Rohr ist das dicke Bündel Superleitendes Kabel drin. Dann macht man also eine so eine Schnecke, so 10 cm breite etwa. Und das nennt sich dann Pancake. Nicht, weil es ein bisschen aussieht, wie so ein Pfannkuchen halten. Und da werden fünf solche Schnecken übereinander gestapelt. Und die bilden dann insgesamt das Wickelpaket. Und diese einzelnen Pancakes, die sind dann jede für sich ja eine Spule, die werden dann alle miteinander verschaltet. Dieses Verschalten geschieht dann in einem Bereich, da nennt sich den Spulen-Kopf. Nicht, wo denn all diese Superleitenden Kabel so zusammenführen. Und da muss man dann diese Superleitenden Kabel miteinander verbinden. Nur das ist eben halt auch keine Lüsterklemme, sondern das ist schon auch ein verflixst kompliziertes Ding, so Superleitende miteinander zu verschalten, dass die über 18:500 Ampere da keinen Unsinn machen.
Das war auch ein irre langer Prozess. Also das ist quasi im Labor neben dem, wo ich arbeite, passiert.
Wie macht man das? Also ich meine so 18:500 Ampere ist ja nun doch schon eher so ein bisschen...
Willst du das wissen, wie man die verbindet?
Ja, klar.
Okay, dann kann ich erzählen. Jetzt geht es ans Eingemachte. Jetzt geht es richtig an die Superleitungs-Elektrotechnik. Ja, also wie ist der Superleiter eigentlich gemacht? Also das sind Niob-Titan-Drähte, die sind eingebettet in eine Kupfermatrix. Und das funktioniert so, also man hat einen dicken Kupferblock, da stofft man dicke Stäbe mit Niob-Titan rein. So, nicht in so einem bestimmten Muster. Und dann hat man einfach so einen Kupferblock und Niob-Titan-Stäbe da drin. Und dann wird extrodiert, dann wird gezogen. Dann wird das lang gezogen, immer länger gezogen, immer länger gezogen, bis so ein haarfeiner Draht entstanden ist. Nicht wirklich ganz, ganz super fein ist der denn. Also, ein bisschen dicker als ein Haarfeiner.
Also, das ist quasi ein Kupferdraht, in dem dann mehrere dünne Niob-Titanen dreht.
Das ist ein Kupferdraht, in dem sind mehrere dünne Niob-Titanen dreht. So, und dann hat man, nimmt man etwa 250 von diesen, und die werden zu so einem Zopf gedreht. Die werden so miteinander so verdrillt. Und das ist dann der eigentliche Supraleiter. Nicht diese Kombination aus Kupfer.
Wie dick ist der denn so?
Der ist dann so ein, naja, so ein 20-cm Durchmesser, ja.
Also ich weiß nicht, ist wahrscheinlich abwegig, aber ich hab manchmal immer so, wenn ich so weit abkühle, wie es hier passiert, wird dann nicht irgendein Material spröde und fängt an zu platzen oder so?
Das hängt von den Materialien ab. Also es gibt eben Materialien, die verspräulden unter kalten Temperaturen, es gibt gleich die bleiben duktil.
Naja, aber wenn ich jetzt Niob-Titanen höre, was so gezogen wird, dann ist doch da schon enorm Stress auf dem Material. Kann es nicht sein, dass da irgendwelche Unreinheiten gibt, die dann kaputt gehen?
Durch Ziehen entstehen eigentlich keine inneren Spannungen. Es wird ja einfach so in die Länge gezogen. Man hat ja momentan die Spannung da drauf und auf die reagiert ja das Material, in dem es duktil wird, mit seiner Duktilität. Also das heißt, das hat dann ja schon eine plastische Verformung erfahren.
Ja, aber kann es nicht schon reißen an der Stelle?
Spannung hat man ja nur bei elastischen Verformungen. Reißen kommt ja immer jenseits der elastischen Verformung. Also das ist ja immer diese Materialeigenschaften, es kommt immer ganz lange elastische Verformung und dann kommt irgendwann der Riss.
Das ist aber eine verstandene Technologie, die ist halt so Kabelziehen.
Achso, du weißt halt genau, wie viel du ziehen kannst.
Genau, das heißt, das macht man vor der Risskante. Natürlich irgendwann würde man beim Exzodieren den Draht durchreißen, da muss man halt vorher aufhören.
Aber das weiß man ja vorher, man weiß genau, wie diese Materialkurven sind und zieht das dann in diesen Bereichen.
Also das ist gute Standardtechnik, das macht alles Otto Kumpu. Heutzutage ist Otto Kumpu vor, war es eben Euro-Metallier.
Okay, gut, das heißt, wir haben jetzt diesen Neoptitan.
Ich muss also ausholen, damit man das erklären kann, wie man die verbindet. Das heißt, dann hat man also diesen Zopf und da ist eben dieses Kupfer und in das Kupfer eingebettet sind diese Neoptitandrähte. So und jetzt hat man zwei solche Zöpfe und die will man jetzt miteinander elektrisch verbinden. Und dann hat man also diese gedrehten Zöpfe. Das Bild habe ich immer noch gut vor den Augen. Dann sitzen da unsere Techniker, fieseln die alle wieder auf, diese 250 Drähte. Nicht so mit so einer großen Lubenbrille. Dann haben sie da so einen Strauß, also so eine ganze Strippe. Dann wollen die alle in alle Richtungen gucken. Und dann werden die mit Silberlot vorsichtig verzint. Jeder einzelne von diesen Drähten. Und da ist ja auch das Kupfer besteht, dafür brauchen wir auch das Kupfer. Ist dann eben gut verzinnbar. Also dann sind die alle mit in der verzint. So und dann hat man eben zwei solche Bündel mit 250 Drähten. Und dann werden die nach einem ganz bestimmten Schema miteinander verflochten. So zu einem flachen Zopf werden die dann verflochten. Also wirklich so ein planarer Zopf, der dann so ganz lang ist. So dieser miteinander verflochene Zopf, der wird dann zwischen zwei Platten zusammengequetscht. Und diese beiden Platten bilden dann aber noch genügend Raum, dass das flüssige Helium, was also aus dem einen Rohr, also so neben einem Zopf fließt, dass das den Weg noch wieder finden kann zu dem anderen Zopf, ohne großen Widerstand.
Also quasi doch eine Lüsterklemme.
Im Ende ist es dann doch wieder eine Lüsterklemme, aber eine Lüsterklemme, in der auch noch flüssiges Helium fließt. Und wo jeder Einzeldraht nicht miteinander verfilmselt wird.
Und das macht irre viel Arbeit auch, weil das ja an jedem Pancake von jeder Spule passieren muss.
Und noch in der Verschaltung der Spulen untereinander. Die sind ja alle noch in Serie miteinander gescheitert.
Was teilweise auch im Überkopf passieren musste, weil die Spulen dann ja schon verbaut waren, wenn sie miteinander verbunden haben. Dann mussten teilweise Leute unter dem Modul dann stehen und den ganzen Tag über den Kopf diese blöden Dinge zusammen flechten. Das sah schon echt nicht beneintenswert aus.
Das haben alles die Polen gemacht. Heftig auf Polnisch geflucht, ja.
Wir hatten ein super polnisches Ingenieursteam, die uns in keinen gespendet haben.
Die hat uns die polnische Regierung einfach geschickt, das Gehälter bezahlt und die haben vorher am CERN gearbeitet. Und dann war der Beschleuniger am CERN dann fertig. Und da hatten die dann so ein bisschen die Gedanken, was machen wir denn jetzt mit denen?
Wenn man schon so ein Team hat, dann wie man es herabgibt.
Die haben jetzt ganz viel Erfahrung. Die rennen alle auseinander, wenn wir die einfach loslassen. Wir brauchen die noch für den nächsten Beschleuniger, also für Hamburg, nicht für den XFEL in Hamburg. Aber dazwischen war so eine paar Jahreslücke und dann haben sie sie quasi bei uns zwischengeparkt.
Das ist doch gut, ich meine. Es gibt offenbar überall so eine hoch spezialisierten Teams. Ich kenne zum Beispiel aus dem Raffinerieanlagenbau, da gibt es auch so Teams, die machen halt nur so Gaskompressoren und so ein Zeug. Die sind dann so Roving Engineers.
Ja, das ist so Spezialwissen, was man mit sich herumträgt. Das ist alles in den Köpfen der Menschen.
Also ich habe hier so den Eindruck gewonnen beim Umgeführt werden, dass ihr an Probleme gedacht wurde, weil die so drei Indirektionsschichten jenseits dessen sind, wo ich an der Stelle gedacht hätte, so das ist jetzt hier auf der Liste der Sachen, an die man da denken muss. Und wir hatten vorhin so ein Ding, das wir Ihnen noch kurz erzählen, als wir unten standen. Aber nicht so gibt es hier irgendein Bauteil, was einfach normal ist. Eine Stange oder so. Und dann ja, hier ist eine Stange. Ja, aber die ist auch aus Aluminium. So erklärt doch mal, warum die Stange aus Aluminium war. Das fand ich nämlich auch eine lustige Erklärung.
Ja, also letztendlich ist das Problem, dass alle magnetisierbaren Materialien nicht zu nah am Magnetfeld stehen dürfen. Letztendlich haben wir ein Inventar an allen Materialien, die da eingehen. Das betrifft auch die Schaltschränke. Wenn man also Computer für seinen Schaltschrank bestellt, dann muss man auch angeben, wie viel Gewicht davon letztendlich magnetisierbar ist. Also zum Beispiel Stahl ist oder Eisen einfach. Das wird dann alles in eine große Datenbank eingetragen. Und dann wird letztendlich geguckt, wie sich das Magnetfeld verformt durch die ganzen Einzelmaterialien, die sich überall in der Halle befinden. Das ist zum Glück bei uns im Moment überhaupt nicht schlimm. Aber hat halt dazu geführt, dass wir ganz oft auf komische Materialien ausweichen, wie zum Beispiel diese ganzen Gerüste, die da rumstehen, die halt auch aus Alu sein müssen. Das bezieht sich auf Schrauben, das bezieht sich auf letztendlich jedes einzelne Bauteil, was ein zertifiziertes Material sein muss.
Jede Unterlegscheibe, ja.
Und das nicht deswegen, weil sie, wie beim Kernspintamotografen, das Magnetfeld sozusagen die Teile beeinträchtigen würde, sondern weil die Teile euer Magnetfeld beeinträchtigt werden.
Genau, das Magnetfeld ist der heilige grail, nicht? Also das heißt, das darf nicht verformt werden. Das darf nicht unkontrolliert verformt werden, weil dann einfach die Leistungsparameter des Plasmas schlecht werden. Also das steht und fällt mit der Güte des Magnetfeldes.
Nachdem wir uns so viel Mühe gegeben haben, das im Produktionsprozess der Spulen richtig hinzubekommen, wäre das ziemlich ein Respekt, dass dann durch ein paar Eisenkomponenten...
Durch einen Geröst... Oh, da haben wir gar nicht dran gedacht, an das Geröst. So blöd sind wir da nicht. Die ganzen Stahlgerüste, die haben wir alle rausgerissen, haben dann einen Hersteller gefunden, der dann für uns Alugerüste geschweißt hat und gefertigt hat, die wir jetzt eingebaut haben.
Das heißt, so ein ganz großer Teil des Wissens, was hier aufhäuft, ist aber eigentlich auch so ein, wer kann denn eigentlich welche Teile in dieser Präzision oder in diesen esoterischen Materialien oder was auch immer liefern?
Insgesamt ist es so, dass eine unheimlich starke Industriekomponente daran haben. Das ist unsere Philosophie und es ist nur notwendige Philosophie, dass man fast nichts selber macht. Also der Eigenfertigungsanteil, der ist wahrscheinlich unter 10 Prozent. Normalerweise würde man denken, naja ein Forschungsinstitut, das ist halt eine Werkstatt, die basteln sich da ihre Anlagen so zurecht. Überhaupt nicht. Sondern das ist alles in Industrieverträge platziert, vorher spezifiziert, dann muss ein ganz systematisches Verfahren durchgeführt werden, mit Design Reviews, mit Projekt Teams, mit Projektteam Meetings, mit Follow-Ups, mit Wochenberichten, Tagesberichten, mit Abnahmeprüfungen, mit On-Site-Abnahme und so weiter. Mit den ganzen Summs, die man so haben muss, wenn man so ein verteiltes System hat. Wir haben so in den Hochzeiten des Aufbaus, haben wir da bestimmt 20, 30 Firmen so parallel auf Trab halten müssen, damit die alle in Time auch wieder liefern. Und eben eine einzige Komponente, die zu spät kommt, die hat dann in der Montage, dieses ganze Montagesystem, rasseln zum Anhalten gebracht. Und was heißt das praktisch? Das bedeutet, dass auf zwei Schichten verteilt 100 Leute rumstehen.
Weil du kannst sie auch nicht nach Hause schicken.
Dann sitzen sie da und stehen rum und kosten jede Stunde 35 Euro, jeder einzelne.
Was ist denn mit den Sachen, die ihr jetzt hier rausgefunden habt? Gibt es da Sachen, wo man schon jetzt sagen kann, dass sie in irgendwelchen anderen Fächern Vorteile gebracht haben oder Erkenntnisse? Oder sind das alles so Spezialsachen, die eigentlich nur euch betriffen?
Nee, diese Industrie-Komponente, die ich gerade eben erwähnte, die hatten einen ganz interessanten, indirekten Effekt. Nämlich unsere Industriepartner, unsere Auftragnehmer, die haben sich erstmal um den Auftrag beworben, um Geld damit zu verdienen. Die haben es nicht aus Altruismus gemacht, sondern die haben gesagt, oh, das ist ein schöner, fetter Auftrag, den schnappen wir uns mal. Das ist immer europaweit ausgeschrieben, sehr kompetitiv, deshalb die Firmen, mit denen wir da gearbeitet haben, über ganz Europa verstreut sind. Spanien, Italien, Frankreich, Schweiz, alles mögliche. Also ganz Europa ist da mit drin im Pool. Die sind da also reingesegelt in diese Aufträge, haben sich erstmal gesagt, oh, das ist ja schön, haben wir einen dicken Auftrag mit einer guten Marge. Ist ja auch ein Forschungsinstitut, da kann man ein bisschen mehr quetschen. Und dann sind die halt so reingesegelt. Und dann am Anfang ist dann natürlich mal so eine Spezifikation. Und dann haben sich über ein paar Sachen vielleicht auch schon gewundert, wollten aber den Auftrag auf jeden Fall haben. Und dann ging es erstmal richtig ran. Wenn erstmal verstanden wurde, was das bedeutet, dann war eben sehr oft war dann Holland in Not, weil dann die Firma dann auch festgestellt hat, das geht über unsere Grenzen eigentlich hinweg. Das können wir gar nicht. Wir können diese Spezifikation gar nicht erfüllen, diese Anforderungen gar nicht erfüllen. Und dann gab es typischerweise eine Krise. Wir haben gesagt, hier ist Vertrag, es ist Vertrag. Wir haben unterschrieben, wir können das jetzt nicht im Regen stehen lassen. Und was ist dann passiert? Also erstens haben die dann angefangen, ihre besten Leute denn da hinzuschaufeln. Wir mussten dann typischerweise anfangen, unsere besten Leute da hinzuschaufeln. Und dann hat man da zusammengesessen und diese Probleme gelöst. Das heißt, sich das Schritt für Schritt angeguckt, was muss man machen, um das hinzubekommen. Da haben wir Tests durchgeführt, dann haben wir manche Apparaten, dann haben wir gemeinsam getüftelt, haben wir Berechnungen durchgeführt. Dann sind wir durch die ganze Welt gereist, haben uns da verschiedene Lösungen denn da so angeguckt und haben am Ende zusammen mit der Firma das irgendwie über die Ziellinie geschleppt. Und das war manchmal einfacher, manchmal schwerer. Wir hatten also sehr gute Firmen, die da sehr solide reingegangen sind. Manche sind auch einfach ganz naiv da so reingerannt und da war Holland in Not. Was aber immer der Fall war, war, dass diese Firmen, diese Auftragnehmer, dass die viel klüger rausgegangen sind, als sie reingegangen sind. Das heißt, wir haben auch hier nie wieder. Entweder so die Art von Klugheit gab es auch, aber auch technologisch oftmals klüger. Das heißt, sie haben dann einfach ihre eigenen Sachen, also das, was sie bis dahin konnten, mussten sie zwangsweise, um diesen Auftrag in Ordnung zu bringen, mussten sie sehr verfeinern, dass sie einfach unheimlich viel dazu gewonnen haben. Und das haben wir eben von den Firmen auch sehr oft bestätigt bekommen. Das haben wir auch in so einer Broschüre mal dokumentiert. Wir haben alles mal aufgeschrieben, ist auf unserer Webseite, kann man die so runterladen sogar, dass dadurch einfach eine Weiterqualifizierung von Industrieunternehmen erfolgt ist, die die wiederum im Markt vorangebracht hat, werbs- Ein gutes Beispiel ist MAN in Deggendorf, mit denen haben wir über zehn Jahre zusammengearbeitet. Das war immer eine extrem erfreuliche Zusammenarbeit, wo man wirklich richtig zusammengearbeitet hat als Ingenieur und technisches Team und immer wieder die verschiedenen Probleme dieser Schweißtechnologien, dieses Gefäßformen, der thermischen Isolation, alles das zusammen gelöst hat. Und das ist sowieso eine Firma, die auf höchstem Niveau so arbeitet, aber die ist auch manchmal in Bedrängnis gekommen und dann haben wir immer gemeinsam Lösungen gefunden. Und die haben gesagt, sie haben aus diesen Aufträgen, die sie bei uns abgearbeitet haben, haben sie die ganze Dreidimensionalität für sich erschlossen. Dreidimensionales Wasserschneiden, dreidimensionales Gefäßformen, dreidimensionale Metrologie, sehr präzises Dreidimensionales Schweißen. Das alles hat in den Deggendorfen einen ganz festen Platz zu bekommen. Ist dann auch wieder indirekt in ihre Serienproduktion, in ihre chemischen Reaktoren eingegangen, wo die glaube ich 60 Prozent Marktanteil sind.
Ja, da sind die Marktführer.
Letztlich hat es auch wieder mit den Leuten zu tun. Das heißt, da haben sie wieder sehr gute Ingenieure angesetzt, die eine Weile da mitgearbeitet haben. Das ist wie so ein Fitnessraum oder so was. Das heißt, da kommt man dann schon ordentlich gestählt raus, wenn man das alles noch gemacht hat. Und dann sind die Serienprodukte dann wieder, die Probleme, die da auftreten, die sind dann wieder klein.
Aber ihr macht ja auch sozusagen Sachen für andere Projekte. Was ist denn dein Experiment da unten? Erzähl doch mal, dieser Teilchenbeschleuniger.
Ich beschleunige kein Teilchen, aber was ich mir angucke, ist ein...
Also das, was Experimenten nebendran strecht, kannst du mal beide erzählen vielleicht.
Ja, okay, klar. Ich selber mache ein Experiment zu magnetischer Rekonektion. Das ist ein Prozess, der jetzt so aus der Grundlagenforschung der Plasmaphysik kommt. Und das ist, ich glaube, fürs Institut relativ wichtig, auch eine Anlage zu haben, die auch die ganze Zeit läuft. Also das ist ein kleines Laborexperiment, in dem immer was gemacht wird. Das heißt, fast jeden Tag kann man da hinkommen und da werden gerade Experimente gemacht. Und genau, das ist halt auch, ich glaube, für uns ein wichtiger Zweig, weil wir da wirklich so ganz in die Grundlagen gucken und mit ganz einfachen Mitteln quasi uns die Grundlagenprozesse angucken, die vielleicht auch ganz woanders eine Rolle spielen.
Und sollte sagen, wenn sie sagen, kleines Experiment, dann meinen sie sowas wie ein VW-Bus von der Größe?
So ungefähr, ja.
Also ist jetzt nicht was, was irgendwie auf dem Tisch steht.
Also was wiegt es, 5 Tonnen oder so?
Ja, gut, die Spulen 7 Tonnen, aber...
Also 10 zusammenflächen.
Ja, also ein kleines Zeichen.
Für Plasmaphysik Verhältnisse klein.
Also für Plasmaphysik ist es schon so mittelgroß, sag ich mal. Da gibt es sehr viel kleinere Experimente, gerade in der Niedertemperatur Plasmaphysik. Aber was wir uns in unserem Labor, in der gleichen Gruppe auch angucken, ist in Kollaboration mit CERN. Die wollen auf Dauer wieder zurück zu Linea-Beschleunigern, zu Laptone-Beschleunigern. Das heißt, die wollen zum Beispiel Elektronen sehr stark beschleunigen und können sich das auf Dauer nicht mehr leisten, das in den riesigen Ringbeschleunigern zu machen, weil die nämlich immer größer und immer teurer werden müssen. Das heißt, Linea-Beschleuniger wäre da schön. Und was es da gibt als schönes Konzept, ist der sogenannte Plasma Wakefield Accelerator. Da erzeugt man sich ein sehr dichtes Plasma in, dass man ein Teilchenbunch reinschickt. Das erzeugt letztendlich hinter diesem Bunch, was da mit relativ ischertischer Geschwindigkeit durchfliegt, so eine Art Bugwelle. Und in dieser Bugwelle, die also ein sehr starkes elektrisches Feld ist, kann man dann ein zweites Teilchen reinschicken, also ein einzelnes Elektron. Und das wird dann unglaublich stark beschleunigt, also sehr viel stärker als es in einem ringbeschleunigen der Fall ist. Und dadurch kann man sich halt sehr viel Strecke letztendlich einsparen. Das ist ein Konzept, was es in Theorie gibt, aber noch nicht so richtig gebaut wurde, zumindest noch nicht so richtig erfolgreich. Und das wurde dann letztendlich ausgeschrieben, mehr oder weniger. Und in Kollaboration mit CERN wurde dann dieser erste Prototyp bei uns gebaut. Da gibt es auch ein paar konkurrierende Experimente. Und ja, unseres wird jetzt bald transferiert zu CERN und die 1-Meter-Prototyp-Version wird dann erst mal zu 10 Metern erweitert und dann hoffentlich irgendwann dann auch so 100 Metern, das heißt zu einem richtigen Beschleuniger dann. Genau, das sind halt auch Zusammenarbeiten, die jetzt so gar nichts mit Fusion so richtig zu tun haben, sondern so in ganz andere Schiene gehen und die, ich sag mal im Vergleich zu Wendelstein, die dann relativ günstig sind bzw. auch externe Gelder dann rannehmen. Und ich sag mal für den Ausbildungsbetrieb auch total wichtig sind, weil wir daran halt Doktoranden uns im Haus selber dann ranzüchten können. Die lernen dann halt damit, Experimenten zu arbeiten, mit Plasmaphysik einfach umzugehen und auch die Anlagen selber komplett zu betreuen. Also alles von Wasser anschließen bis Vakuumtechnik und so weiter.
Genau, wofür braucht man das Wasser? Ich sag am Ausgangsschild bei eurem Bereich irgendwie, das irgendwie Wasseraus Fragezeichen Schild.
Das ist mir mächtig, ich vergesse nämlich immer das Wasser auszuschalten.
Wofür braucht man das Wasser?
Meistens immer zur Kühlung. Wir haben Spulen, die werden einfach warm, da hab ich auch neulich eine zerbraten, deswegen ist auch das Schild da, weil ich es nämlich erstmal vergessen habe einzuschalten, die noch wieder auszuschalten. Und dafür sind halt solche kleinen Laboralideale. Man kann halt alles kaputt machen und man kann es dann aber auch selber wieder reparieren und man hat nicht gleich Millionen Schaden.
Also nicht dieses Raumschiff, was man...
Ja klar.
Das ist mehr so der Fall.
So einen Lehrbetrieb brauchen wir natürlich auch.
Wir haben ja auch einen Bildungsauftrag.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten hier so?
So was wie 450.
450 Leute, okay.
Also einmal hier in Greiswald, dann haben wir ja noch die andere Zweigstelle in Garching bei München. Das ist beides, das gleiche Institut. Da arbeiten noch mal genauso viele ungefähr, oder?
700.
700?
Da müssen wir hier noch ein bisschen Nachwuchs entschicken.
Und ich nehme an, die Leute, die Mikrowellen bauen, die werden ja wahrscheinlich auf einem ähnlichen Niveau spielen. Also das kann man sicherlich auch nicht von der Stange kaufen.
Also hier unsere Mikrowellenheizung für den Wendelstein. Das ist total die Prototypenentwicklung. Adrian erwähnt das ja vorhin schon, dass diese Mikrowellenröhren funktionieren. Das war, als dieses Projekt gestartet wurde, alles andere als klar. Zwar, dass grundsätzlich man eben mit diesen sogenannten Gyrotrons Mikrowellen machen kann, das ist gut etabliert. Die sind überall in der Welt auch im Einsatz. Alles ganz wunderbar. Es gibt auch mehrere Hersteller. So in Japan, in Russland, in den USA, in Europa. Aber diesen Anspruch, den wir formuliert haben, dass wir Mikrowellenröhren hier bekommen, die 1 Megawatt Mikrowellenleistung, 140 Gigahertz für eine halbe Stunde liefern, das war dann noch nicht klar. Das ist aber erforderlich, weil wir hier demonstrieren wollen, dass dieser Stellarator dieses Plasmas dauerhaft aufbauen kann. Eine halbe Stunde ist für einen Plasmaphysiker dauerhaft. Also wenn man eine halbe Stunde kann, dann geht alles andere auch. Dann geht auch ein halber Tag, dann geht auch ein halbes Jahr, dann geht auch ein halbes Jahrhundert. Aber was jetzt so der Weltstandard ist, das sind einige zehn Sekunden. Und das ist noch nicht, wo man hin will. Nämlich der Übergang zwischen einigen zehn Sekunden auf eine halbe Stunde, da passiert noch eine ganze Menge.
Also vor allem mit Aufwärmen von Komponenten zu tun.
Ja, das Ganze muss in so ein Gleichgewicht kommen. Das passiert alles in der Zeit so zwischen den ersten zehn Sekunden und dann zehn Minuten oder so was. Also das heißt, man muss zur halben Stunde hin. Solche Röhren gab es noch gar nicht zu der Zeit, wo man diesen Anspruch formuliert hat und wo das Projekt mit diesem Anspruch gestartet wurde. Dann wurde dort ein Entwicklungsprogramm losgetreten, wo also sehr viel russisches Wissen eingegangen ist, was so über die Jahre zusammengesammelt wurde. Da waren die Russen immer sehr gut in Sibirien, am Sibirischen Institut. Und das wurde dann transferiert zur europäischen Industrie, nämlich zu einem französischen Konzern, Thales, ein Mischkonzern, der alles mögliche Zeug macht. Und die haben eine Firma Aktivität, die sich mit Elektronenröhren beschäftigt. Und die haben eben diesen Auftrag dann angenommen und haben das zu sich transferiert und haben dann zusammen mit dem früheren Forschungszentrum Karlsruhe, jetzt dem Karlsruhe Institut für Technologie, haben die diese Entwicklung vorangetrieben, sich so vorangerobbt, da eben diesen Hochleistungsröhren für sehr lange Puls dauern. Und das ging dann tatsächlich, das haben die dann, die Karlsruhe dann zusammen mit Thalys dann hinbekommen. Und das ist unsere enge Zusammenarbeit mit Karlsruhe, mit dem KIT. Und das ist ein separates Projekt, also es ist ein Projekt im Projekt, nicht dieses Projekt Mikrowellen.
Wo dann auch nochmal zehn Leute ihre Doktorarbeit drüber schreiben.
Ja locker locker, nicht? Also was so für sich einige zig Millionen gekostet hat, die ganze Entwicklung, Beschaffung, nicht? Jede Röhre an sich ist schon etwas mehr als eine Million, mit den ganzen Krimskrams runter rum oder sowas ist man da locker mehrstelligen Millionenbereich. Ja und das ist auch alles an den äußersten Grenzen, nicht? Und eben halt dazu eben auch so wirklich kühne Konzepte, wie darauf zu verzichten, das durch Hoheleiter zu schicken, sondern über Spiegel. Das gibt es nur hier. Das gibt es nur hier.
Ich glaube, wir haben das nirgendwo anders gehört. Das ist ja wieso.
Nee, das machen die anderen nicht, obwohl das viel besser ist. Also selbst Ithal macht das nicht. Sie sind ja alle sehr konservativ.
Ist vielleicht jetzt erst klar, wo ihr das gemacht habt, dass das viel besser ist?
Ja, also am Ende das Überzeugen, dass etwas wirklich besser ist, das geschieht nur, indem man es tut. Und indem man es auch wirklich demonstriert, dass es besser ist. Das kann man nur tun, indem man es tut, sonst redet man nur rum. Und sonst halten sich eben konservative Konzepte immer, weil man es schon immer so gemacht hat. Und Mikrowellen gehören in den Hoheleiter-Punkt. Das ist so ein Glaubenssatz. Wir sind überzeugt, dass es viel besser ist, das mit den Spiegeln zu machen.
Weil man dann noch die Freiheit hat, irgendwie einen Fall zurückzukriegen.
Ja, die Spiegel sind alle natürlich motorisch gesteuert und vom Computer dann irgendwie so justiert und so was nicht. Die können immer nachgeführt werden, sind alle wassergekühlt. Es muss natürlich wassergekühlt sein, weil da bleibt ein Prozent hängen. Das ist so bei Megawatt ist das schon immer viel. Und ja, nicht alles. Aber es bietet einem mehr Flexibilität und man muss am Ende nicht so genau arbeiten. Nämlich das Türkische bei Hoheleitern ist, wenn man da leicht gekippt ist. Ich denke, die Mikro werde da durch und erzeugt dort einen Hotspot. Dann landet die ganze Leistung an der Ecke und dann beginnt es dort auszugasen. Dann geht einem das Vakuum verloren, was da eigentlich drin sein soll. Und dann passieren merkwürdigste Dinge. Dann werden nämlich so Bögen drin gezündet. Dann beginnt das dann zu funken und dann ist die Hölle los.
Bei ITER ist das eine irre lange Strecke, oder? Ein paar Dutzend Meter, die sie über einen Hoheleiter führen müssen.
Das wird sehr anstrengend, das zu bauen.
Ich war vor ein paar Wochen schon mal hier. Da gab es hier noch so eine andere Geschichte, dass in dem Plasma-Behälter auch einzelne Atome ausgasen und das Plasma kaputt machen können.
Genau.
Das noch kurz erzählen. Ich finde es immer faszinierend, was einem das Schicksal für Steine entgegenwirft, mit dem man vielleicht nicht gerechnet hätte. Oder ihr habt doch mitgerechnet. Doch, doch. Das wusstet ihr schon.
Genau, das gehört zum normalen anfänglichen Betrieb von einer größeren Plasma-Anlage, egal ob jetzt Hoka Mako oder Schilderator, dass die Wände am Anfang noch dreckig sind. Dreckig heißt nicht, dass da irgendwie Schlamm draufklebt oder so, sondern dass einfach in die Wände, also in den Stahl über die Jahre, die es letztendlich im Aufbau war, alles mögliche Zeug eingezogen ist, vor allem Wasser ist das, aber auch irgendwelche anderen Verunreinigungen. Und jetzt Fingerabdrücke, also ziemlich viel Fett und Zeug, was einfach an den Wänden klebt. Und da pumpt man die ganze Luft raus. Das heißt, da fiel das Gas schon von alleine aus, aber man hat halt noch viele Wände drin, was halt erst durch Zufuhr von Energie letztendlich rauskommt. Das probiert man auch noch zu imgeben, indem man die ganze Maschine backt. Das wurde dann auch wie lange? Mehrere Wochen gemacht?
Einfach nur Mikrowelle reinballern?
Nee, tatsächlich. Man packt die ganze Maschine ein und dann heizt man sie einfach auf.
Aber wenn jetzt die Griff...
Nein, nicht ganz. Das ist eine Kombination. Einerseits ein paar Heizmatten. Aber das Wesentliche beim Aushalzen ist, dass das eigentliche Gefäß, in dem das Plasma drin ist, dass es komplett umgeben mit so Rohren, mit Wasserrohren, die da alle aufgeschweißt sind. Und eigentlich dient das dazu, dieses Gefäß eben auch ein bisschen zu kühlen, so auf Temperatur zu halten. Und dann schickt man eben halt 150 Grad heißes Wasser durch. Und damit heizt man das ganze Gefäß dann auf 150 Grad aus.
Aber wenn ihr jetzt die Grafit-Kacheln wieder einbaut, dann...
Dann müssen wir auch wieder ordentlich wieder ausheizen.
Versuche ich nochmal.
Und das führt dann letztendlich dazu, dass man also sein Plasma anmacht. Das Plasma strahlt ihre viel Leistung ab und macht halt die Wände warm. Und es kommt dann ziemlich schnell die Schmante runter. Genau, der Schmand kommt dann halt ins Plasma rein. Dann alle möglichen Komponenten, die man nicht drin haben will. Wozu das letztendlich führt, ist, dass man schwere Atome in Plasma drin hat, die erstmal ihre ganzen Elektronen verlieren müssen. Das heißt, das ist ein Energieverlustkanal. Und außerdem fängt das Plasma an zu leuchten, was das eigentlich nicht tun soll. Und dieses Leuchten ist halt Abgabe von einer nigenen Form von sichtbarem Licht oder allen möglichen Strahlungsformen. Und das ist dann der sogenannte Strahlungstod des Plasmas. Das heißt, das verreckt einfach. Das macht also zu viel Energie verliert.
Und das lässt sich nicht durch Nachheizen kompensieren?
Bis zum gewissen Grad schon, aber dann irgendwann einfach nicht mehr. Aber es geht auch ziemlich schnell. Also innerhalb von Millisekunden bricht das dann einfach weg. Und dann ist es halt aus. Und dann gibt es also überall so genannte Sniffer-Probes, die feststellen, dass die Mikrowellenleistung jetzt durchscheint durch das Plasmal. Das heißt, dass sie auf die entgegenselte Wand dann anfängt zu treffen. Und dann werden sofort die Mikrowellen abgeschaltet. Und dann ist halt Schluss. Und dann muss man wieder neu anfangen. Und wie man das umgeht, ist, dass man halt dann jeden Abend eine sogenannte Glimment-Ladung laufen lässt. Da wird dann letztendlich so ein kleiner Draht einfach geheizt, so wie eine Glühlampe mitten im Gefäß. Und die führt dann letztendlich dazu, dass das gesamte Gefäß dann ausgeheizt wird bzw. bombardiert wird mit Ionen. Ist das so, oder mit Elektronen?
Ich meine, diese Glimment-Ladung ist letztlich wie so eine Läufstoffröhre. Die Läufstoffröhre über uns ist eine Glimment-Ladung. Da legt man hohe Spannung an und dann hat man eine Elektrode und die Gegenelektrode ist das restliche Gefäß. Dann wird da einfach alles schön mit Plasma ausgefüllt, mit so einem schönen kalten Plasma. Aber das kalte Plasma ist immer noch warm genug, dass es den Schmutz von der Wand kratzt.
Genau, das lässt man halt mehrere Stunden laufen, dann einfach am Abend. Und zum nächsten Morgen macht man es auch noch ein paar. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das mal gemacht wurde. Halbe Stunde ungefähr. Und der erste Schuss des Tages, das merkt man auch gleich, der läuft dann sehr viel länger als die restlichen Schüsse des Tages, gerade wenn die Maschine noch neu ist und noch wenig benutzt wurde. Und über den Tag merkt man dann, wie es so immer schlechter wird.
Weil mehr Dreck reinkommt.
Genau, weil mehr Dreck reinkommt. Und zum nächsten Tag nach wieder neuen Glimmerndladungen bricht man wieder einen Rekord für längstes Plasma.
Und wie löst man das dann in Zukunft? Also ich meine, das ist ja durchaus ein relevantes Problem, wenn man so ein Plasma eine halbe Stunde lang hat.
Bessere Wand. Also es kommt unheimlich viel auf gute Wandmaterialien an.
Okay.
Und Grafit ist da schon mal erstmal eine gute Wahl. Grafit ist ja so ein relativ poröses Material. Das ist ja anders als so Metall oder so was nicht. Das ist ja wie so ein bisschen, wie gesagt, so eine schwammartige Struktur so auf molekulare Ebene. Nicht so mit diesen ganzen vielen verschiedenen Kohlenstoffschichten. Das heißt also, was da drin sitzt, das geht schnell rein, geht auch schnell wieder raus. Das heißt also, wenn der Grafit warm wird, nicht wenn er heiß gemacht wird, nicht, dann geht auch das ganze Wasser, damit auch der ganze Sauerstoff und das ganze Zeug und auch was da sonst so drauf rumgeistert nicht, das kriegt man relativ schnell rausgezaubert. Und deshalb schafft man es mit einer Grafitwand relativ schnell, also noch ein bisschen Plasma-Betrieb und heftigen Heizen und Glimmen und sowas, schafft man es relativ schnell, einfach eine gute Wand herzustellen. Dazu kommt, das Grafit besteht aus Kohlenstoff und Kohlenstoff hat Kernladungszahl 12 und die Intensität der Plasma-Strahlung geht sehr stark mit der Kernladungszahl. Das heißt also Metalle, nicht die für viel höhere Kernladungszahl haben, nicht die strahlen viel stärker. Jetzt haben wir da Metallwände drin, das heißt also diese Verunreinigung, die wir jetzt produzieren, die sind besonders virulent. Mit Kohlenstoff ist da viel friedlicher an der Stelle. Das ist immer so ein bisschen so ein Handel, den man da macht. Also die Wand wird immer da sein, das Plasma wird immer eine Wechselwirkung mit der Wand machen. Jetzt kann man einerseits eben an dem Plasma rumzüchten, dass diese Wechselwirkung so harmlos wie möglich ist. Das ist dann so die plasmaphysikalische Kunst, so Plasmaverteilungen zu generieren und Magnetfeldkonfiguration zu finden, sodass sie möglichst wenig von der Wand abkratzen, damit wenig Verunreinigungen erzeugen. Das ist so die eine Seite, denn arbeitet man an der Wand, dass man dort gute Materialien dafür findet, gute Materialien dafür auswählt und die eben halt auch gut vorbehandelt und so was.
Das klingt doch so, als wäre Diamantbeschichtung des Innenraums eigentlich das Optimum.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht.
Also zumindest kommt da nichts runter.
Das ist auf den Diamantrecht, aber wir kommen jetzt über.
Na ja, wenn ich schon über Schrauben mit Diamant verkleidet hätte.
Ja, also Diamant ist gar nicht so schlecht. Das ist natürlich schon ein Kostenfaktor. Das muss natürlich auch irgendwie wirtschaftlich sein. Außerdem letztlich, ob Diamant oder nicht, dieses starke Baumbardement mit dem doch relativ schnellen Teilchen, das kratzt auch von Diamanten was ab. Wir reden ja nicht von makroskopischen Mengen. Also auch so eine Grafikkarre, die kann man da ein Jahr drin haben, man holt die raus nicht und die ist voll unverändert. Das sind einfach minimale Mengen, da reichen einfach so ein paar Zehn Atome oder so was. Wir haben ja auch gar nicht so viel Zeit in dem Volumen. Also das Plasma selber, das ist ja einfach auch nicht viel Material. Wenn wir da von ein Prozent oder fünf Prozent für Unreinigungen reden, dann ist das ja schon irrsinnig viel. Aber das sind einfach nicht viele Teilchen, das kommt ratzfatz zusammen.
Das heißt also, wenn man so was so langfristig für Dauerstrichbetrieb plant, dann braucht man einen Plasmareiniger oder so?
Na das Plasma selber ist ja schon mal ein Reiniger. Also das reinigt erstmal die Wand. Und der Dreck, der in das Plasma hineinkommt, der bleibt der ja nicht. Der muss ja nicht zwingend drin sich aufhäufen, sondern der macht ja auch wieder seinen Weg raus. Am Endeffekt muss ein Gleichgewicht entstehen, ein gutes Gleichgewicht aus einer verdaubaren Menge Dreck für das Plasma, der dann halt den Weg reinfindet, der dann aber auch wieder ausgeschieden wird.
Okay, was vielleicht ein größeres Problem wird. Also, ich meine, wahrscheinlich stellt sich das mit einem Gleichgewicht erst ab einer bestimmten Größe ein.
Jaja, das ist richtig. Also, wenn die Maschine größer wird, wird es besser. Weil einfach das Verhältnis zwischen Volumen und uralträchtig größer wird. Das heißt also, wenn man es jetzt mit einer 30 Kubikmeter Maschine ganz gut in den Griff kriegt, dann sollte das eigentlich bei einer 1000 Kubikmeter Maschine nicht mehr so das Thema sein.
Was ist denn, wenn morgen hier ein anonymer Benefaktor auftaucht, euch 100 Milliarden gibt und sagt, er will ein Fusionskraftwerk haben?
Dann hauen wir ab, dann kommt er nie wieder.
Was würdet ihr sagen, 20 Jahre? Willst du Bill Gates kaufen?
Keine Ahnung. Würdet ihr grundsätzlich sagen, ja, das könnten wir machen, dauert halt ein bisschen? Oder ist da noch zu viel Unbekanntes drin?
Letztlich der Schritt zu einem Demonstrationskraftwerk, also so einem Prototypenkraftwerk, das ist jetzt alles nur so eine Risikofrage. Und zwar keine Betriebsrisikofrage, sondern eine Wirtschaftlichkeitsrisikofrage. Also wenn man bereit ist, viel Geld zu investieren und bereit ist, das gegebenenfalls abzuschreiben, nicht weil man dann irgendwo auf die Nase fliegt, dann könnte man sofort anfangen.
Das heißt also, die wissenschaftlichen Risiken sind soweit abschätzbar?
Man könnte es, wenn man kühn ist, könnte man es einfach mal wagen. Und unsere kühnen chinesischen Freunde, die drängen da ja auch. Denen geht der ITER zu langsam. Und die Chinesen haben eigentlich vor, einen Parallel-Iter zu machen.
Aber das ist doch ein Tokamarkt, oder?
Jaja, die machen alle eine Tokamarkt. Das ist ein bisschen gewohnt da. Das ist ja so ein Newcomer, den wir hier machen.
Aber bewegt es dann andere Leute, die mehr Geld haben oder zumindest besseren Zugriff auf Ressourcen haben, dazu ihre Projekte zu überdenken? Also denken die Chinesen drüber nach, zu sagen, wir lassen uns mal lieber einen Stellarator bauen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Also Wendel, habt ihr jetzt plötzlich ganz viele chinesische Gaststudenten hier?
Ich hatte mal eine ganz interessante Diskussion mit dem Chef der chinesischen Fusionsforschung, den ich sehr gut kenne. Der ist ein prima Kerl. Der hat hier in England studiert. Der ist auch sehr Europa erfahren und sehr gut vernetzt hier. Und der hat uns hier auch mal besucht. Und er hat dann immer sehr deutlich unterstrichen, was sie alles können. Was sie alles besser können. Nicht so. Und dann war es immer so seine Standardkommentare. This we can do. Ich weiß nicht, wie das gezeigt hat. So this we can do. Oder die über diesen Disc geredet. So nicht this we can do. And we can make much quicker decisions. Wir können viel schneller entscheiden in China. Und ihr diskutiert ja immer im Kreis, wo geht das alles so langsam und sowas nicht. Und da, diese ITER ist ja ganz typisch europäisch westlich aufgesetzt. Und China geht alles viel schneller und muss alles viel mehr mit Nachdruck vorangetrieben werden. Wir haben ein bisschen diskutiert und sind hier so weiter marschiert, bis eben dort zu unserer Halle und wo beide vor dem Wendelstein standen. Da hat er sich das angekündigt. This we cannot do. Und dann hat er gesagt, naja, werdet mal fertig und legt mal los. Also wir in China bauen Tokamaks nicht, weil wir unser Geschäft da so jetzt gerade relativ neu eingestiegen sind. So in den letzten 20 Jahren. Und da setzen wir erstmal auf was bewährt ist nicht und wollen jetzt nicht noch völlig neue Komponenten reinbringen. Und da hat er gesagt, wenn der Wendelstein dann gut funktioniert, na dann kaufen wir ihn halt bei den Deutschen.
Okay, das ist doch mal ein Ritterschlag.
Es gibt ja immer mal wieder so irgendwie News-Items. So was war gerade das letzte Locket Martin. Die meinten, sie hätten irgendwie so einen Taschen-Kanfusionsreaktor. Irgendwie jetzt so zwei oder drei Jahre vor der Fertigstellung.
Vom Jahr her hat es gepasst.
Wenn ich dir jetzt mal so gegen, was ich jetzt hier so sehe und was ihr so erzählt haltet, dann scheint das ja doch eine etwas sehr optimistische Annahme zu sein, die die da treffen oder?
Ja, das kommt tatsächlich immer wieder vor. Und das ist tatsächlich auch leider mit großer Regelmäßigkeit. Das kleine Firmen, da gab es jetzt auch gerade ein, also das war im Time-Magazin sogar Titel-Stories oder Fusion-Start-ups, was die jetzt so können und auf welchem Stand die sind. Und tatsächlich gibt es einfach immer wieder Leute, die denken, das kann auch nicht so schwer sein. Und diese großen festgefahrenen Strukturen der Großforschung, die kommen einfach nicht voran. Und so kleine Prototypenentwicklungen, da kommen viel schneller zum Ziel. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass wir das ja auch schon durchlaufen haben. Das heißt, die Großforschung ist ja nicht daraus entstanden, dass wir von Anfang an Großforschung machen wollten, sondern dass es tatsächlich ein komplexes Problem ist. Und dann gibt es immer mal wieder neue Konzepte, die vielleicht auch interessant sind, aber die dann oft vielleicht um Geld daran zu holen oder einfach um News zu generieren, sich dann doch sehr stark aufbauten.
Und das Problem ist, dass oftmals wieder nicht Zahlen auf den Tisch gelegt. Die Chance für ein Plasma, wirklich Fusionsenergie zu liefern, lässt sich an drei, vier Kennzahlen schon mal ganz gut einschätzen. Und diese Kennzahlen, die werden dann oft nicht genannt. Die werden dann gesagt, nee, das ist Firmengeheimnis oder...
Naja, das bei Lock geht nicht. Also tatsächlich...
In dem Falle wurde es dann auch getan. Da wurden diese Zahlen dann auch genannt. Da konnte dann auch schon ein Blinder mit dem Rückstock sehen, dass man damit nichts wird.
Also dass man tatsächlich neun Größenordnungen weg von so Target-Größen ist.
Neun Größenordnungen.
Also es gibt halt, für die Kernfusion gibt es so das eine. Also wenn man nur eine Zahl haben möchte, dann nimmt man das Trippelprodukt. Das ist das Produkt von Dichte, Temperatur und Einschlusszeit. Das hatten wir alles so ein bisschen von dem, was wir erzählt haben. Und das muss einfach immer eine bestimmte Zahl kommen, dass man in einen Bereich kommt, wo die Kernfusion einfach einen positiven Energieoutput hat. Und da muss man entweder eins von unglaublich groß haben oder halt einfach alle drei groß halten. Und da sind sie einfach unglaublich in Meilen von entfernt. Und sie haben jetzt eine kleine Anlage gebaut, die interessant ist, vielleicht auch schöne Ergebnisse liefern wird, aber bei Weitem nicht irgendwie das große Halsversprechen sind. Und ob sie da mit ihrem Rapid Prototyping, wo sie jedes halbe Jahr eine neue Maschine bauen wollen, große Fortschritte machen, es ist ein Konzept. Aber ob sie damit irgendwie neue Größenordnungen schaffen, das ist, ja, eher nur das, was ich meine.
Aber ich meine, nichtsdestotrotz, also wir hier in der Plasmaforscher-Gemeinde, wir freuen uns ja, dass es da diese Start-ups gibt, dass es da Industrie, Unternehmen, klein oder groß gibt, die so sagen, na ja, das ist doch eine interessante Sache. Da gucken wir mal rein, da machen wir auch mal was. Also soll das auch nicht, also deshalb bin ich da immer sehr vorsichtig, das irgendwie mardig zu machen.
Ich bin gut, ich meine, im Zweifel ist es halt nur, dass tatsächlich für Leute, die Plasmaforschung studieren wollen, halt mehr Arbeitsplatzchancen gibt, was ja auch nicht schlecht ist.
Ja, na gut, also in Arbeitsplätzen würde ich das erstmal nicht ausdrücken. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall Wissenschaft als solches und das Generieren von Wissen, das ist ja auch kein so ein ganz gradliniger Vorgang. Also der lebt ja auch von Vielfalt und lebt auch manchmal von Querdenkern. Nur gibt es eben keine Garantie, dass die Querdenker immer diejenigen sind, die den Erfolg davontragen, sondern das geschieht ja eher ganz, ganz selten. Nichtsdestotrotz sind sie wichtig, um auch zu stimulieren, auch ein bisschen zu provozieren, nicht einfach auch mal ein paar Aufreger dann so zu produzieren in der ganzen Gemeinde. Nicht, damit man sich auch mal wieder mal selber in Frage stellt, ist man auf einem richtigen Pfad? Ist das alles in Ordnung? Ist das alles abgesichert? Das gehört mit zu diesen ganzen, ja, dieser Dialektik, diesen Dialog, den man den da so pflegt, so dieses Ring um wahr und falsch.
Also ihr seht es eigentlich eher positiv, aber denkt so, die haben noch einen weiten Weg vor sich.
Also wir haben da noch kein Ding gesehen, wo wir plötzlich gesagt haben, verflixt, das ist es nicht.
Jetzt haben wir es all die Jahre falsch gemacht.
Jetzt hauen wir den Stellaratur weg und bauen das auch. Ich meine, wenn es in der Tat so ein Ding gäbe, wo die Fusionsforschergemeinde dann plötzlich so rauf guckt und sagt, wow, das ist es, da könnt ihr euch aber sicher sein, dass innerhalb von Wochen nicht sofort davon zehn Stück aufgebaut werden. Nicht, dass es so kompetitiv, dieses Feld, da würde sofort jeder drauf hopsen. Nicht so wie da die Geschichte vom Kurchatov-Institut, wo die wirklich dann innerhalb von einer Woche dahin gereist sind, alles nachgemessen haben, denn sofort wieder zurück berichtet haben, es stimmt nicht. Und dann haben die als nächstes die Leute in Princeton ihren Stellaratur auseinandergerissen, einen Tokamarkt draus gemacht.
Also was mich dabei so ein bisschen ärgert, ist einfach, wenn es zu reißerisch wird. Also gerade weil Kernfusion ja so ein Gebiet ist, wo ja der Running Gag ist, das ist immer 20 Jahre weit weg. Und wenn dann ein kleines Startup kommt und sagt, na wir machen das in fünf Jahren und das ist überhaupt kein Problem, dann muss man sich halt immer wieder der Kritik stellen, was dauert ihr euch so lange?
Das war durchaus auch eine der Fragen, bis wir hierher gekommen sind, um festzustellen, worum dauert es eigentlich so lange. Mittlerweile habe ich es verstanden. Das ist halt irgendwie ein dickes Brett. Ja, das ist halt schon ein dickes Brett.
Aber es ist ein großes Fass und ein dickes Brett. Man will ein großes Fass aufmachen und dafür muss man vorher ein dickes Brett bohren.
Was macht denn jemand, der sich das jetzt hier einlädt und denkt, oh, also Plasmaphysik, das klingt cool, da will ich auch hin.
Da kommt zum Beispiel eine Universität Greifswald, um das zu studieren.
Und dann kann er hier auch mit werkeln, wenn er möchte.
Dann kann er hier auch mit werkeln.
Wir haben auch eine Summer School, die ganz lustig ist, wenn man sich das nicht für zu lange antun will, sondern kurz.
Da kann man dann schon mal in einer Woche Plasmaphysik intensiv sich eintrichtern lassen. Die Summer School ist offen für alle, aus allen Ländern. Da kann man sich drum bewerben, kriegt dann auch sogar ein Reisestipendium und freie Unterkunft und ein lustiges Begleitprogramm. Die ist sehr großzügig. Wir kommen an uns. Es gibt noch ein paar universitäre Standorte, wo man gut Plasmaphysik machen kann. Ich hab's in Kiel noch studiert. Stuttgart ist ein wichtiger Unistandort. In München haben wir halt unseren zweiten Standort, den anderen Standort des MPI für Plasmaphysik. Da sind viele von unseren Kollegen, die dort lehren. In Ulm, in Bayreuth, in Bochum nicht zu vergessen. Wir haben auch eine große Universität für Plasmaphysik. Ein bisschen mehr Niedertemperatur, Plasmaphysik machen die ja. Aber letztlich, das hängt auch alles miteinander schon zusammen.
Also, wenn ich euch so zuhöre und dann so eure Anlagen sehe, dann scheint der Plasmaphysik so ein Feld zu sein, was sowohl schwergewichtig in der Simulation ist, aber auch in tatsächlich dem praktischen Ausprobieren. Ist das, weil man noch nicht so viel weiß, dass man so viel ausprobieren muss?
Also, das liegt einfach wieder daran, dass es sich bei einem Plasma an sich um ein komplexes System handelt, der Physikklassifikation. Ein komplexes System ist dadurch definiert, dass man sehr, sehr viele Zusammenhänge gleichzeitig hat, sehr viele Wechselwirkungen gleichzeitig hat. Das definiert ein komplexes System. Es liegt in einer Entschwur der komplexen Systeme, dass durch die Tatsache, dass alles gleichzeitig geschieht, Beobachtungen oftmals sehr schwer zu interpretieren sind. Das heißt, man hat immer sehr unklare Bilder, die Kausalitäten sind niemals sehr klar. Es ist ein Riesenunterschied, wenn man ein einzelnes Rubidiumatom in eine Falle reinpackt und dann dieses Rubidiumatom quält, oder wenn man zehn hoch zwanzig Rubidiumatome hat und die alle miteinander irgendwas machen. Da steht man plötzlich im Wald. Das heißt also, diese Beobachtungen, die wir hier machen mit vielen, vielen Instrumenten, wir gucken jetzt schon mit 20 Instrumenten auf das gleiche Plasma, wir werden mit 50 Instrumenten auf das gleiche Plasma gucken und am Ende ausbauen, nicht alle diese Instrumente glotzen auf das gleiche Ding, wir holen da verschiedene Informationen raus und man kommt da nicht durch, wenn man das nicht sehr klug kombiniert mit Simulationsrechnung, Code-Rechnung. Denn in einem Code weiß man erst mal im Prinzip, was passiert. Also das heißt, da steht zumindest erst mal ein wohl definiertes Gleichensystem zugrunde, ein numerischer Lösungsapparat dafür. Man hat eben viel mehr Möglichkeiten, viel mehr Möglichkeiten, sich einfach Größen anzugucken und Kausalitäten zu überprüfen. Man kann zum Beispiel Effekte einschalten, ausschalten. Zum Beispiel kann man sagen, ist die Krümmung des Magnetfeldes wichtig? Dann schaltet man die Krümmung aus. Und dann guckt man, ist das überhaupt ein Effekt da drauf? Und das können wir im Expo natürlich nicht. Wir können nicht plötzlich den Stellarator gerade biegen. So kann man nicht machen. Und deshalb braucht man eben diese numerischen Instrumente, also diese Simulationsinstrumente, um aus seinen Daten überhaupt Sinn zu machen. Das ist ein ganz mühsames Geschäft. Das ist sogar so mühsam, dass das in der Regel nicht einer alleine machen kann, nicht alle diese Sachen bedienen kann, sondern da muss man wirklich so eine Maschinerie insgesamt aufbauen, dass eine sehr schlagkräftige Theorie- und Simulationsabteilung, die sehr eng wiederum zusammenarbeitet mit den Experimentatoren, die wiederum eine sehr gute Maschine haben. Damit man eine gute Maschine hat, braucht man wieder sehr gute Ingenieure. Das heißt, im Endeffekt reicht das eben von der Mathematik über die Numerik bis zur theoretischen Physik, zur Experimentalphysik, zur Ingenieurkunst.
Würdet ihr sagen, das Primärziel der Anlage war eher ein Ingenieursding, zu zeigen, man kann so etwas bauen oder eher der Erkenntnis gewinnen und zu sagen, ok, wenn wir das hier machen, passiert jenes. Weil das klingt bisher so ein bisschen so, wir haben der Industrie viel geholfen, wir haben diese ganzen Ingenieursprobleme gemacht und Plasmaphysik ist hochinteressant. Aber war das auch ein Ziel, zu sagen, ok, diese Sache haben wir vorher nicht verstanden, jetzt haben wir sie verstanden?
Naja, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen stark Ingenieur geprägt, vielleicht nicht, weil wir in den letzten zehn Jahren sehr stark Ingenieur geprägt waren. Insofern ist das erstmal...
Ihr müsst wieder mal in den Forschungsmotor kommen.
Ja, ja, insofern hat das jetzt erstmal...
Die Auswertung dort wahrscheinlich auch...
.hat das erstmal eine sehr große Luminante gehabt. Und wir haben dann jetzt gerade von unseren großen, von unseren großen, großen Meilensteinen, die wir erreichen müssen, haben wir den ersten von vier Meilensteinen mit dem Bau der Maschine jetzt abgeschlossen. Dieser erste Meilenstein lautet nämlich, man kann so ein Ding überhaupt bauen. In der Tat, das wurde ja in Zweifel gezogen, auch von vielen Kollegen auf der Welt, und gesagt, tolle Idee kann man aber nicht bauen. Gut, das haben wir jetzt gezeigt, das kann man bauen, wenn man sich nach der Decke streckt. Dann gibt es weitere Meilensteine. Der nächste Meilenstein ist ein Stellarator. Ein optimierter Stellarator, wie der Wendelstein 7X, läuft genauso gut wie ein gleichgroßer Tokamak. Das heißt also, dieses Stellarator taugt nichts. Das ist ein lahme Ente-Problem. Über die letzten 50 Jahre ist das beseitigt. Das ist der nächste Meilenstein, den wir bekommen können. Der ist leicht formuliert. Da steckt aber natürlich unheimlich viel Plasmalphysik drin. Weil man da all diese Dinge zusammenbringen muss, um wirklich dieses heiße, stabile, gute Plasma zu erzeugen.
Und meint ihr, das geht?
Das sieht ganz gut aus. Diese ersten drei Monate waren schon mal sehr vielversprechend. Ich bin jetzt schon auf ein paar Vorträgen gewesen hier, zu Instituten eingeladen worden, von verschiedenen Forschungsinstituten und Universitäten. Da werden jetzt schon die Augenbrauen hochgezogen, auch von den Tokamarktleuten. Ich war in der Schweiz, in Lausanne, da wird ein Tokamarkt betrieben, ein relativ kleiner Tokamarkt, aber eine sehr feine Maschine. Und da haben die Kollegen gesagt, das sieht gut aus, das sieht sehr gut aus. Also Respekt, Respekt. Man ist auch gar nicht so neidisch aufeinander, sondern da wurde ich den Hut gezogen. Also es segelt in die richtige Richtung für diesen Meilenstein. Dann ist der nächste Meilenstein, ist die Demonstration, dass dieses Hochtemperaturplasma, dieses heiße Plasma, dass das in einem vernünftigen Kontakt mit der Wand steht. Wir haben schon viel über die Wand geredet. Die Wand ist ein Riesenthema. Und besonders kritisch ist dort an der Wand ein Bereich, der nennt sich Divertor. Da ist Divertor nicht, weil der die Wärme verteilen soll, nicht die großen Wärmeflüsse verteilen soll, nicht so von Divertere oder so was.
Das ist letztendlich, wenn man so will, das eine definierte Kontaktfläche, wo das Plasma wirklich auftreffen soll im Gegensatz zum Rest der Wand, wo das Plasma...
Also das sozusagen wäre in einem Reaktor die Stelle, wo man die Energie entnimmt?
Nee. Nee, das ist eher wie beim Ofen der Aschekasten. Da wird der ganze Dreck rausgepumpt, da wird das Neutragas weggepumpt und so was. Und da landet so allerlei Hitze, also so der Wärmefluss. Die Energie wird ja bei einem Reaktor über die Neutronen entnommen. Die Neutronen gehen ja einfach isotop in alle Richtungen.
Und da wird die gesamte Wand gekühlt?
Ja, und da wird die gesamte Wand rundherum gekühlt. Dies hier ist der Kontakt, wie Adrian sagte, ein wohl definierter Kontakt, ein gewollter Kontakt des Plasmas mit der Wand. Das musste man auch erst lernen über die letzten Jahrzehnte. Das war auch einer der Showstopper, dass man das am Anfang nicht kapiert hat. Dass es besser ist, das Plasma quasi an einer Stelle ganz definiert relativ hart mit der Wand zu verkoppeln. Nicht als zu sagen, naja hoffentlich geht das irgendwie gut. Wir verlassen das Thema selber.
Wie so ein Fuß- und Ankerpunkt, wenn man so will. Das ist quasi der Grundpunkt von dem aus.
Wenn es nicht einfach gehen lässt, dann macht das Plasma wieder was es will. Und es passieren dubioseste Dinge. Mit so einem wohl definierten Punkt, da weiß man wenigstens, was da geschieht, muss aber einen Preis dafür bezahlen. Es landen dann allerlei Wärmeflüsse. Plasma hat durchaus nennenswert Energie. Man steckt 10 Megawatt rein, müssen auch 10 Megawatt wieder raus. Hier so beim Wendelstein etwa. Und diese 10 Megawatt landen eben verteilt auf diesen Divertor-Platten. Und das sind schon ordentliche Wärmeflüsse.
Die man in den Griff bekommen muss.
Da reden wir von 10 Megawatt pro Quadratmeter.
So Größenordnung, Oberfläche der Sonne.
Okay.
Ja, nicht um 10 Megawatt pro Quadratmeter. Das ist so das, was man technisch gerade noch handhaben kann. Das sind so die Wärmeflüsse, die man hat, wenn so ein Space Shuttle in die Atmosphäre eintritt.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist doch irgendwie so. Okay, und wie kühlen wie blöde oder was?
Kühlen wie blöde, ja nicht. Aber da muss man für Wärmeleitung sorgen. Da muss man für Wärmeleitung sorgen. Und die Wärmeleitung zu dem Kühlmittel nicht. Das ist kein einfaches Problem. Da müssten also bei dem Divertor, den wir am Ende einbauen werden, den wassergekühlten Divertor, da mussten wir solche Kunststücke machen, wie Kohlefaser verstärkte Kohlenstoff kacheln von so zwei, drei Zentimeter Dicke auf eine Kupferchromzirkonen Wärmesenke raufzuschweißen. Und jeder, der mal versucht hat, Kohlenstoff auf Metall zu schweißen, der wundert sich, wie das gehen soll. Das geht aber, indem man diesen Kohlefaser verstärkten Kohlenstoff vorher mit einer Kupferdoppelschicht versieht. Und das geschieht wiederum mit Plasma-Sputtering. Das wird da so wie Schneebälle an die Wand, werden da mal so dicke Batzen Kupfer raufgeklatscht, nicht so durch den Sputterprozess. Und dann wird diese dicke Kupferschicht, die wird ans Kupferchromzirkon mit Elektronenstrahlen geschweißt. Schöne Technik hat eine österreichische Firma für uns entwickelt, Plansee, die da auch ganz prima Arbeit geleistet haben. Super teuer. Und diese Divertor, davon haben wir zehn Stück, die wir da einbauen an neuralgischen Stellen, also an wohl definierten Stellen in der Maschine. Und der Betrieb dieses Plasmas im Kontakt mit dem Divertor ist der Meilenstein Nummer drei. Nämlich das ist auch noch ganz, ganz wichtig, diesen wohl definierten Wandkontakt mit den Hochwärmeflüssen dann hinzubekommen und das dauerhaft hinzubekommen.
Sonst ist die Dauerstabilität nicht hinzubekommen.
Ja, sonst hat man ständig Ärger mit dem Dreck, den das Plasma reinkommt, nicht? Weil unter diesem Divertor sind die massiven fetten Pumpen. Das sind so Kryo-Pumpen. Aber uns ist mir nichts normal. Das sind so die stärksten Pumpen der Welt, die man so bekommen kann, nicht? Das sind so Pumpen, die eben durch kalte Platten das Gas absorbieren und dann abtransportieren. Sehr, sehr starke Pumpen drunter. Und damit kriegt man dieses ganze Verunreinigungsproblem in Griff. Also das ist auch noch ganz wichtig, was wir machen müssen. Und Meilenstein Nummer vier ist den ganzen Klump zusammen. Also das Hochleistungsplasma in Kontakt mit der Wand. Meilenstein Nummer vier bedeutet das Ganze noch eine halbe Stunde.
Danach beginnt dann sozusagen die Spielphase. Dann könnte er machen, was er wollte.
Also wenn wir das hinbekommen haben mit der halben Stunde, dann sind wir erstens berühmt und dann kann man sagen, dann geht es an Feinschliff.
Dann ist wahrscheinlich das Material durch, oder?
Nö, das sollte es ja gerade nicht. Das gehört ja mit zu den Meilensteinen, dass das Material damit sehr zufrieden ist. Und wie gesagt, dann geht es uns weiter optimieren. Dann beginnt man links und rechts zu gucken, und dann geht es noch besser.
Okay, und der nächste Schritt wäre ja dann, wenn man sagt, man will Richtung Reaktor, dann müsste man ja in den Matrizium arbeiten, damit man einen Neutronenfluss hinbekommt, mit dem man Wärme rausbekommt.
Der nächste Schritt wäre eine größere Maschine.
Würde man die dann schon als Reaktor auslegen? Das wäre jetzt tatsächlich der nächste Schritt.
Der nächste Schritt wäre schon, wenn wir mal was Reaktor ähnliches mindestens, das diskutieren wir noch. Also, auf jeden Fall ein Schritt, also mindestens ein ITER.
Von der Größe hier? Ui.
Das müsste mindestens ein ITER sein, ja.
Aber die haben da auch so ein BA-Problem, damit fertig werden, oder?
Ein was Problem?
Ein BA, also wie unser Berliner Flughafen. Ach so, ach so.
In der großen Kategorie Fukushima, Chernobyl, BR.
Oh Gott, das ist ein BA gemeint. Ja, ach, für ITER muss ich ja immer eine Lanze brechen. Die haben es auch echt nicht leicht.
Na gut, ich meine, mit dieser internationalen Kooperation.
Das ist ein hochpolitisch aufgebautes Projekt. Und das hat ja auch seinen Reiz. Man hat das irgendwie dazu geschafft, die halbe Weltbevölkerung dazu zu bringen, an einem friedlichen Projekt rumzubasteln. Aber es bedeutet auch, dass da sieben Arbeitskulturen mindestens aufeinandertreffen. Und von diesen sieben Arbeitskulturen ist eine die Europäische Union, deren Einigkeit auch täglich demonstriert bekommen. Und das wird dann einfach mal so als eine Nation dort genommen. Also in Wirklichkeit hat man es eher so mit 30 Nationen dort zu tun. Und die arbeiten da jetzt an einem technisch durchaus komplexen, anspruchsvollen Projekt. Das ist ja schon schwierig für sich. Aber gut, da gibt es auch andere Beispiele. CERN ist ein super Beispiel, nicht, wo die halbe Welt an Hochenergiephysik arbeitet. Aber dann hat es der Politik auch gefallen, das so aufzusetzen, dass nicht etwa, wie es beim CERN der Fall ist, dass es einen zentralen Topf gibt, wo alle ihre Geld reintun und es gibt ein vernünftiges Management und das macht es. Sondern alle diese sieben ITER-Partner behalten ihr Geld und bauen den ITER, indem sie die Bauteile dafür bauen.
Und zum Teil gleiche Bauteile in unterschiedlichen Ländern.
Also zum Beispiel das Stahlgefäß, das besteht aus acht Oktanten, die dann diesen Ring formen. Das ist ein sehr großes Gefäß. Sieben von denen werden in Europa gebaut, und eine in Korea.
Und wenn es da nicht passt, hat man da einen Pich oder wie?
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich mehr so ein Tonbau zum Babel-Projekt?
So ein bisschen, ja. Und die Hälfte der Magnete werden in Europa gebaut, die andere Hälfte in Japan. Und das ist alles so zurecht verhandelt worden. Liegt daran, dass eben jeder wollte eben alle Technik haben, hatte keine Lust drauf. Indien macht die Wasserkühlung, nicht so blöde Aufgabe so, nicht? Und die Europäer machen die Magnete, ah, schöne Aufgabe. Da hat man sich nicht darauf einigen können, sondern jeder macht quasi alles. Und das hat dann auch zur Folge in dieser Governance-Struktur, also in der ganzen Steuerungsstruktur, dass eben jeder der ITA-Partner da ständig drum rumrührt. Es gibt also einen gigantischen ITA-Council, in dem sitzen 40 Diplomaten, die dann das Ganze steuern.
Gibt es da auch Nachverhandlungen, weil irgendein Land findet, wir haben aber hier, wir brauchen mehr verdient als wir haben?
Reichlich, reichlich wird sich da gestritten. Und dann wird auch immer gedroht, nein, dann steigen wir aus, jetzt haben wir keine Lust mehr, und wir haben einen Anrecht da drauf. Und das alles erzeugt natürlich unheimlich viel Overhead. Also in dieser Umgebung, da das so konsequent so anzutreiben, das ist schon eine große Kunst.
Und aber vom Projekt Ziel sind die ja eigentlich sozusagen eins näher am Reaktor dran, ne?
Kann man so sagen, ja. Das liegt einfach daran, dass beim bestelleratelange Stillstand herrschte. Und insofern war es ja auch nur vernünftig, für ITER einen Tokamarkt zu nehmen, weil das einfach das am weitesten entwickelte und wirklich leistungsfähige Konzept ist. Es ist ja auch nach wie vor so, dass der Tokamarkt besser funktioniert. Ich habe ja schon den Meilenstein formuliert, nicht?
Den müssen wir erst mal erreichen.
Und dann kann man drüber reden, was dann kommt.
Das Ziel von ITER ist also bei 50 Megawatt Eingangsleistung, 500 Megawatt Fusionsleistung letztendlich rauszukriegen. Das heißt, das erste Ding, was man tatsächlich auch Reaktor nennen kann.
Das heißt also, die müssen halt dieses Absorptionsproblem auch lösen. Wie sie halt irgendwie aus dem Neutronenfluss Wärme kriegen.
Naja, das ist noch so halb gelöst. Also das wird ja...
Also ITER wird kein stromerzeugender Reaktor. Das heißt, die führen das...
Na gut, aber die thermische Leistung muss ja irgendwie... Die muss trotzdem irgendwo hin.
Also dieses Absorbieren, das Absorptionsproblem wird gelöst, aber nicht die zweite Aufgabe des Blankets, das Trizium erzeugen, also genügend Trizium zu erzeugen, dass es denn auch für den Reaktor selber wieder reicht. Nichts, sondern es wird dort Testmodule dann geben, die das ausprobieren. Nicht diese Brutfunktion, da diese Trizium-Erzeugungsfunktion ausprobieren. Aber das sind nur einzelne kleine Module, die man da einsetzt. Und der ganze Rest ist einfach so eine dicke Wand, so eine dicke Bremswand.
Und das Trizium wird dann einfach artificiell zugeführt?
Ja, das Trizium muss einfach reingefüllt werden. Also das kann man in Kernreaktoren herstellen, nicht von der kanadischen Kandu-Klasse, die fällt das als Nebenprodukt beab, das kann man in Kurven.
Der Schritt dann, also wenn man jetzt sagen würde, ihr seid jetzt fertig und habt irgendwie eure halbe Stunde erreicht, und man würde sich jetzt im nächsten Schritt entscheiden, sagen wir, wir bauen als nächstes mal eine Stellaratermaschine, dann würdet ihr sozusagen wiederum die Erkenntnisse aus dem Vita-Projekt nehmen, die die bis dahin angehäuft haben und die in so einer Maschine verbauen.
Und umgekehrt, also etwa unsere Gyrotron-Entwicklung, also das Gyrotron, was wir hier haben, also die Entwicklung, die wir vorangetrieben haben, das ist das ITER-Gyrotron. Das braucht ITER auch.
Verstehe.
Denn ITER möchte seine Entladung für zehn Minuten oder so etwas aufrechterhalten. Und die Gyrotrons, die es bis dahin gab, die hätte ITER nicht gebrauchen können. Das heißt, da hat sich ITER auch ganz doll gefreut. Hurra, die Wendelstein-Gyrotrons, die funktionieren ja. Ein Problem weniger.
Also, man kennt sich und man hat sich auch überall gern in der Plasmaphysik und deswegen wünscht man sich.
Wir kennen uns, wir streiten uns, aber wir haben uns doch irgendwie gern.
Gerade bei den Nexon-Teilen Großanlagen, weil man da immer mit den gleichen Problemen irgendwie sehr rumschlägt.
Ja, man hat bildet so eine Art Leidensgemeinschaft.
Selbsthilfegruppe. Ich würde gerne noch so ein paar wirtschaftliche Sachen ansprechen. Also eine Sache, die mir zum Beispiel ganz wichtig ist, vielleicht denkt sich der eine oder andere Hurra jetzt tolle Sache. Gut, dass ich das über meine Strompreise immer finanziere. Ja, da wird ja viel zu viel immer genommen. Und wie viel Prozent wird denn hier von den Stromgesellschaften gemacht und bezahlt von dem Projektbundget?
Die Stromgesellschaften bezahlen gar nichts. Das ist reine staatliche Forschung.
Alles Steuer?
Alles Steuer.
Also zahlt auch ihr, liebe Hurra, aber über Steuer, nicht über eure Stromkosten.
Ja, die Stromkosten, das geht in die Subvention der Erneuerbaren.
Okay. Die nächste Frage war, die wir uns notiert hatten, finde ich super, welche Partei muss ich denn wählen, damit das hier geschordert wird? Dürfte der überhaupt eine Aussage machen?
Es gibt Parteien, die man vielleicht nicht wählen sollte.
Dann machen wir das so, das ist auch gut.
Nee, ach, ich weiß ja nicht. Die Parteienlandschaft, die ist ja auch sehr komplex.
Also wie wird das überhaupt finanziert?
Also unser Haushalt wird im Wesentlichen von Bundesmitteln getragen. Dem sind eine Bundeseinrichtung. Also 90 Prozent unseres Haushaltes ist Bundesanteil, zehn Prozent ist dann Landesanteil. Und dann kommt noch obendrauf noch eine Extrafinanzierung, die wir aber sozusagen fest in unserem Haushalt vorsehen, die von der Europäischen Kommission kommt. Das ist so etwa so ein 15-Prozent-Anteil.
Und gibt es da irgendjemanden, der euch immer wegkürzen will? Und irgendjemand anderen, der immer mehr?
Alle wollen euch immer wegkürzen. Wer hält euch denn an dem? Also es ist eine teure Forschung. Jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen ausholen. Es ist also eine teure Forschung. Also ich finde immer noch angemessen, aber es ist viel Geld. Da muss man sich einfach mal klar darüber sein. Also die deutsche Fusionsforschung erhält pro Jahr 120 Millionen. Bundes- und Landesmittel eben, wie eben genannt aufgeteilt. Das ist also erstmal durchaus nennenswert. Also wirklich viel Geld. Hier könnte man auch völlig andere Dinge mitmachen. Das ist unbestritten. Denn es ist so, dass die Fusionsforschung keine kurzfristigen Lösungen liefert. Das heißt also etwa zu der berühmten Energiewende trägt das nichts bei, kann das nichts beitragen. Wir machen Grundlagenforschung. Das ist das große Fass, das dicke Brett. Wir liefern nicht morgen, wir liefern auch nicht in fünf Jahren, auch nicht in zehn Jahren. Da muss man ganz realistisch sein. Das führt natürlich dazu, dass...
Ich meine, komm on, das 1-Euro-Fighter-Proja.
Ja, ich finde das auch nicht so wichtig.
Fühlst du mal ganz ehrlich, es ist tatsächlich 1-Euro-Fighter-Proja.
Wie viel Fusionsforschung kann man mit einem BER machen, finde ich so die Kategorie.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, das ist ein doofes Jagdflugzeug. Die kosten 120 Millionen.
Das ist ein Jagdflugzeug. Aber na gut, absolut betrachtet ist trotzdem viel Geld. Man könnte damit alle Kirchen Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns renovieren. Man kann es auch in die Kategorie setzen.
Dann nehmen wir halt den zweiten Eurofighter, den wir dafür abschalten.
Insofern ist das schon ein Rechtfertigungszwang. Es liefert nicht unmittelbar etwas. Es hat auch keine nützlichen Nebenprodukte oder so was. Nicht die Handys kleiner machen oder so. Oder nicht die LED, die den Haushaltsbeleuchtet oder so was. Und insofern ist das ein Rechtfertigungszwang. Entsprechend differenziert wird das auch in den Parteien diskutiert. Und wir haben eigentlich in allen Parteien Förderer und auch Gegner. Da kann man sagen durch alle Parteien durch. Es gibt so ein paar Tendenzen. Also nicht so die eine oder andere Partei, die ist so ein bisschen technikfreundlicher und hat weniger Probleme mit technischen Großanlagen. Nicht, denn gibt es andere Parteien, denen sind technische Großanlagen relativ zu wieder.
Habt ihr denn so Probleme mit Leuten, die irgendwie glauben ihr macht hier schwarze Löcher oder imitiert fiese Strahlen?
Naja, also die schwarze Lochgeschichte, die wird auch immer wieder ausgepackt. Seit dem Zern geistert das irgendwie herum. Meine Tatsache, das hat sich auch als Käse erwiesen. Nicht erwartungsgemäßer, aber wir werden damit auch immer mal wieder konfrontiert. Bei uns ist es natürlich noch viel unwahrscheinlicher als am Zern. Nicht einfach bei uns in Hygiene. Schon klar.
Nee, ich meine, ob ihr so mit Leuten zu tun habt, dass die...
Und wir gehen damit um, indem wir sicher sehr transparent sind. Also wir machen... Erstens sind wir sowieso ein offenes Haus. Wir hatten schon 70.000 Besucher hier. Also irrsinnig viele Besucherführungen. Jeder kann sich hier anmelden. Bei unserer Öffentlichkeitsarbeit auf unserer Webseite, das Besucherdienst, kann man sagen, ich würde gerne mal kommen. Dann kann man sich das alles anschauen, kriegt einen Vortrag und so was, kann jede Frage stellen. Und extra zu solchen Sicherheitsfragen haben wir jetzt gerade kürzlich noch mal wieder einen Bürgerabend veranstaltet, wo wir auch wieder gesagt haben, offenes Haus gibt auch eine Führung und gibt Vorträge zu den Sicherheitsfragen. Also Strahlenschutz und sowas.
Weil ich meine, habt ihr überhaupt Strahlenschutzprobleme? Ihr benutzt doch gar kein Trizium.
Naja, nun ist es so, wenn man mit Trizium arbeitet, dann muss man natürlich schon heftig Strahlenschutz machen, weil Trizium ist ein radioaktives Material und so weiter. Wenn wir mit Deuterium arbeiten, in einem kleinen Umfang erzeugen wir Neutronen. Denn auch Deuterium hat nicht viel Lust zu fusionieren, aber ein klein bisschen fusioniert ist. Wie gesagt, wir reden ja mal von den vielen Teilchen. Also das heißt, selbst wenn es ganz wenige von den Deuterium-Teilchen miteinander fusionieren, reicht das, um Neutronenflüsse zu erzeugen, die schon Strahlenschutzrelevant sind. Deswegen haben wir auch die dicken Wände.
Das heißt, ihr seid als kerntechnische Anlage definiert? Seid ihr nichts?
Nein, weil unsere Strahlendosen sind so gering, dass die weit entfernt sind von der kerntechnischen Anlage.
Die dicken Wand und der Neutronendetektor da draußen, die hängen da nur der Sicherheit wegen?
Das ist ganz schlinknormale Strahlenschutzverordnung. Also das heißt, unsere Genehmigung ist nach Strahlenschutzverordnung, die auf dem Atomgesetz basiert, aber wir sind keine kerntechnische Anlage. Aber trotzdem müssen wir Strahlenschutz machen. Wir erzeugen auch Röntgenstrahlung, also durch die beschleunigten Teilchen da drin, also dass die immer um die Kurve laufen, erzeugt auch Röntgenstrahlung, muss man auch beachten. Pieper Po, nicht die ganzen Sekundäreffekte. Das heißt, wir müssen schon einen ganz normalen Strahlenschutz machen, wie im Krankenhaus oder wie ein Beschleuniger in einer Uni oder so was. Also die großen Beschleuniger da in Darmstadt oder in Hamburg, die müssen viel mehr Strahlenschutz machen, um vom Zern ganz zu schweigen.
Hätte ich noch ganz andere Energien.
Jaja, also insofern sind wir dann am normalen Niveau von einer Forschungsanlage und nicht, oder eben wie gesagt, im Krankenhaus. Aber trotzdem, das muss gemacht werden. Und auch diese Fragen gilt es dann zu beantworten. Das ist also jetzt der lokale Aspekt, wenn man jetzt wieder von einem großen Kraftwerk redet, also von unserer Zukunftsperspektive, dann muss man das auch ganz klar sagen, das ist eine Kerntechnologie, das ist eine nukleare Technologie. Und das heißt, man muss sich dort mit Neutronenflüssen, mit starken Neutronenflüssen, mit Radioaktivität auseinandersetzen und muss wieder Strahlenschutz machen. Und auch ein künftiges Fusionskraftwerk ist am Ende seiner Laufzeit aktiviert. Der ganze Stahl ist aktiviert durch die Neutronenflüsse. Das heißt, man hat, glaube ich, die gleiche Situation wie bei einem Spaltkraftwerk. Das heißt, man hat dort einige zigtausend Tonnen Stahl, die aktiviert sind. Und dann muss man sich da ansetzen und dann wird das, so wie jetzt hier in Lübmin das geschieht, wird das alles auseinander geschnibbelt und muss etwa 100-150 Jahre zwischengelagert werden.
Das heißt, es entstehen aber nur Sachen mit relativ kurzer Hardware-Zeit.
Nach 150 Jahren kann man es dann wieder verwenden. Aber das ist eben Zwischenlagerprobleme. Es ist keine Entlagerproblematik, die man bei der Fusion hat, weil ja kein Kernbrennstehen wächst.
Was sind doch so die Isotope, die da entstehen?
Bei der Fusion?
Also ich meine, die Fusion, also wenn der Stahl ist aktiviert, dann ist es...
Also das ist vor allem die Kobalt.
Kobalt, okay.
Kobalt im Stahl, da ist das Problem.
Das heißt, das ist relativ schnell vorbei.
Ja, aber Kobalt ist die Sache schnell erledigt. Aber diese langlebigen Spaltprodukte, die fallen ja bei der Fusion nicht an. Das heißt, Entlagerproblematik gibt es nicht. Dann müssen wir schon entscheidend normales weg. Aber es ist eine Nuklartechnologie. Wenn man jetzt sagt, Nuklartechnologien sind sowieso des Teufels und Großanlagen sind des Teufels, dann hat man natürlich mit dieser Sache ein Problem. Das ist jetzt unabhängig von Parteien.
Aber es ist eigentlich weniger als bei Atomreaktoren, wo man schon ganz konkrete Probleme mit Reaktor schmelze. Diesen Ding ist ja mehr ein philosophisches Problem. Man will lieber dezentrale Energie haben als zentralisierte Energie.
Genau, wenn man in Richtung kleine Netze, dezentrale Energiewende komplett mit einem europäischen Verbundnetz denkt, dann ist die Frage, wie gut Fusion da reinpasst. Obwohl da viele auch der Überzeugung sind, dass man da trotzdem große zentrale Kraftwerke gut gebrauchen kann.
Grundlastkraftwerke bzw. Energiequellen mit hoher Energiedichte. Nicht so lokale Energiedichte.
Und großer Zuverlässigkeit.
Ja, und eben großer Verfügbarkeit und so was. Da muss man auch nicht immer an elektrischen Strom denken. Das kann auch Prozesswärme für chemische Großanlagen sein und so was. Das ist halt einfach ein heißer Ofen.
Und du sagtest vorhin, wenn man dir jetzt 100 Milliarden geben würde und dann sagen würde, ok, baue mal so ein Kraftwerk, wäre das Hauptrisiko ein wirtschaftliches Risiko? Weil die Anlage zu bauen so teuer ist.
Es könnte werden, eine teure Anlage. Und wir könnten nicht wirklich hundertprozentig sicherstellen, dass sie vernünftig funktioniert.
Gut, aber wenn du sie baust, dann nehmen wir mal an, es funktioniert. Wäre sie dann wirtschaftlich?
In dem jetzigen Gefüge, als ein first of a kind, weil man das das erste Mal baut. Ich glaube nicht, beim Bauen würde man zu viele Überraschungen erleben. Nicht so wie wir es jetzt auch haben. Dass es wahrscheinlich Faktor 2 teurer wäre, als der 10th of a kind oder der 50th of a kind. Davon reden wir immer. Wir haben natürlich viele Studien dazu schon durchgeführt. Und da sind außerdem Erfahrungen im Anlagenbau. Ist da so eine Lernkurve denn so mit drin? Wenn man sagt, naja, wenn man eine Anlage das erste Mal gebaut hat, nicht dann passieren alle möglichen Fehler und Ineffizienzen und so was da drin. Man muss da ganz viel Zeug entwickeln. Dann hat man da eben einen bestimmten Faktor, knapp Faktor 2 oder so was nicht, den das teurer ist, als wenn man es schon das zehnte, zwanzigste Mal gebaut hat. Und dann, wenn man es das zwanzigste Mal gebaut hat, dann sieht das schon wieder ganz gut aus. Beim Fusionskraftwerk sind ja dominant tatsächlich die Investitionen, die man tätigen muss, weil der Brennstoff selber, der kostet ja fast nichts. Also der ist ziemlich verfügbar und ist jetzt nichts Exotisches. Die Investitionen sind hoch und die sind auch höher als beim konventionellen Kraftwerk gleicher Größenordnung. Warum? Es ist eigentlich der gleiche Maschinenbau, aber man muss das Magnetfeld bezahlen. Das Magnetfeld bezahlt man mal Volumen. Das ist eine Magnetfeldstärke in Quadrat mal Volumen. Mit einem Vorfaktor ergibt die Euro oder Dollar, die man für ein Magnetfeld bezahlen muss. Und das Magnetfeld kommt obendrauf, denn ein konventionelles Kraftwerk oder ein Kernkraftwerk braucht kein Magnetfeld. Und wir brauchen halt gut 1000 m³ Magnetfeld für ein Fusionskraftwerk und das kommt on top beim Bau.
Das heißt also, ein Fusionskraftwerk wäre wahrscheinlich auch teurer als ein aktuelles Atomkraftwerk? Ja.
Am Anfang ja.
Weil man halt das Magnetfeld bezahlen muss. Und dann kommt die Unbekannte wieder rein, was für Magnetfeldtechnologien stehen zur Verfügung. Also wenn wir jetzt anfangen würden zu bauen, würden wir wahrscheinlich hier nie ab Titan oder nie ab Zinn nehmen und ganz stinknormal einen konventionellen Superleiter wieder nehmen, aus konservativen Gründen. Ja, weil einfach denn die Hochtemperatur-Superleiter noch nicht so weit sind. Aber schauen wir mal 20 Jahre. Also die Fortschritte sind schon ganz beachtlich bei der Hochtemperatur-Superleitung. Wenn ich mir das so angucke, da gibt es auch so Diagramme über Sprungtemperaturen und bei Hochtemperatur-Superleiter.
Also wenn man so Dinge mit Stickstoff bauen könnte statt mit Helium.
Das wäre ein riesen Unterschied.
Das heißt, das wäre so die eine Kerntechnologie, die die komplette Wirtschaftlichkeitsrechnung kippt.
Also die eine Schlüsseltechnologie, nicht die Kerntechnologie. Ja, ja, sicher nicht. Die würde einen starken Einfluss darauf nehmen, klar. Und das ist am Ende sogar schicksalhaft, weil letztlich, wenn man in größeren Mengen die Menschheit mit Fusionskraftwerken beglücken will, dann hätte man Probleme, die alle mit Helium zu versorgen. Es gibt einfach nicht so genug Helium auf der Welt. Also das wird dann schon eng. Die Magnetechnologie, die muss unbedingt vorangetrieben werden. Also die Magnetechnologie und dann im gewissen Umfang auch noch die Materialfragen, die noch zu lösen sind, das sind die beiden schlüsseltechnologischen Bereiche, die als Verbindungstechnologie mit der Fusion entscheidend sind.
Na gut, diese Mikrowellenheizung klingt auch noch so ein bisschen nach... Das kann jetzt nicht hoch...
Da bin ich ja ganz andere überzeugt. Da sind wir eigentlich durch. Mit diesen Dingen, die wir da gebaut haben, sind wir jetzt eigentlich durch die Sache. Nämlich, die liefern jetzt einen Megawatt und das machen sie für eine halbe Stunde. Und mehr braucht man nicht. Nämlich, erstens, diese Röhren, die sind skalierbar. Weil man muss ja einfach viele Röhren haben. Wenn ich 50 Megawatt brauche, habe ich 50 Röhren. Dann pack ich noch 10 in Reserve dazu. Wenn eine ausfällt, schalte ich schnell um auf die. Das heißt, das ist wunderbar. Nicht wunderbar, so modular, nicht kaskadierbar.
Und wenn man das Design an einem hat, ist das dann, sagen wir mal, in Serie herstellbar? Oder ist das alles so?
Wir machen ja auch schon eine Serie in Produktion.
Okay.
Das geht schon ein nach dem anderen. Also es holpert noch ein bisschen in der Serie. Wir haben immer noch wieder mal so komische Ausfälle. Nicht, wo sich alle im Kopf kratzen. Aber trotzdem ist es schon in der Serie drin. Also das ist jetzt nicht sozusagen ein einzelner Prototyp, der zufällig eine halbe Stunde liefert, sondern wir haben ja schon zehn Stück davon. Und das ist schon eine kleine Serie. Also damit sind wir eigentlich durch. Und wir arbeiten jetzt schon da dran, zusammen mit unseren hochgeschätzten Kollegen in Karlsruhe. Das wird den Vorstoß zum 1,5 Megawatt-Gyroton machen. Das heißt, dass wir ein bisschen mehr Leistung rauskitzeln aus dem Ganzen beim gleichen Design. Also gar nicht viel ändern, sondern ein bisschen noch so Reserven rauskitzeln. Und letztlich, wenn man jetzt an ein Fusionskraftwerk denkt, man braucht auch nicht viel mehr. Denn letztlich soll das Plasma ja selber brennen. Das soll sich ja selber heizen durch sein Helium. Und das ist ja eigentlich nur der Fidibus. Also das ist der Streichholz, mit dem man das anzündet. Und dieses Streichholz, das muss etwa 10, 15 Minuten brennen, bis sich das ganze Gleichgewicht anständig eingestellt hat. Das heißt, da regelt man dann immer ein bisschen rum. So ein bisschen mehr Mikrowelle, ein bisschen weniger. Und dann mal hier, mal da. Man kann die auch so steuern, wo die deponiert werden soll über die Spiegel. Dann brennt man da und da und da. Das heißt so, wie man sein Kaminfeuer denn so anzündet. Fidibus rein und dann schaukelt man das alles ein bisschen hin. Und irgendwann brennt es friedlich von sich selber rum. Und dann kann der Fidibus auch gerne ausgehen. Also das heißt im Prinzip mit dem Gyro Truss, damit sind wir meiner Überzeugung nach, sind wir durch. Da können wir schon einen Haken hinter machen. Das ist schon eine wichtige Leistung auch.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben eigentlich alle Fragen, die wir hatten, durch.
Ach so, wir wollten noch nach Crackpot-Technologien fragen. Wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, wir machen Fusion ohne Plasma, was sagt ihr dann?
Kalte Fusion.
Oder kalte Fusion?
Kalte Fusion, der Effekt ist ja nachweisbar. Moderierte Fusion, das ist eben mal so ein Festkörper stattfindender Effekt, aber wieder die gleiche Geschichte ist passiert, viel zu selten. Also kommen wir wieder da an, wo wir am Anfang des Gesprächs einmal waren. Ein bisschen Fusion kann jeder machen. Also so ein paar Neutronen erzeugen, indem da irgendwas mal ein bisschen vor sich hin fusioniert. Und dann so hurra, wir haben einen Durchbruch. Aber das hilft nichts, das bringt eigentlich weiter. Ich sage nur, die Kunst ist, viel Fusion zu machen.
Also Fusion kann man, wie ich auch schon vorhin meinte, quasi im Laden kaufen und die Frage ist halt immer, wie man das hochskaliert, wie man es so hinbekommt, dass man tatsächlich ein Energieoutput hat. Und daran scheitert es dann meistens.
Ja, ich und viele von diesen Crackpot-Ansätzen, die basieren eben darauf, dass da ein bisschen was gemacht wird. Und da wird Heureka geschrieben. Aber das ist ja nicht zielführend.
Ja, würdet ihr euch sehr wundern, wenn morgen ein fundamentaler Durchbruch käme? Oder glaubt ihr, die Technik ist oder die Wissenschaft ist an sich so weit durch? Ich meine, das soll man eigentlich nie sagen, dass man durch ist, aber so erwartet ihr noch.
Fundamentale Durchbrüche sind ja sowieso mehr selten in der Physik. Ich könnte mir eins vorstellen, das ist aber sehr hochspekulativ.
Was kommt jetzt?
Ich könnte mir eins vorstellen, das ist ein bisschen so ein persönlicher Trauma von mir, wenn es einem gelänge, das Turbulenzproblem in den Griff zu bekommen. Das heißt, Turbulenz zu steuern, aktiv zu steuern. Das heißt, Turbulenz hoch zu fahren, dass es turbulenter wird und runter zu fahren, dass es weniger turbulent wird oder gar ruhig wird. Das wäre ein gewaltiger Durchbruch. Nämlich die Größe dieser Maschinen, dass wir hier von 1000 m³ reden, das ist alleine dadurch bestimmt, dass das Plasma turbulent ist. Wäre es nicht turbulent, könnte man die ungefähr von der Größe, ja, würde das hier in diesen Raum reinpassen. Also ein völlig turbulenzfreies Plasma.
Und verhält sich ein Plasma denn sehr viel anders als eine Flüssigkeit?
Ja, nein, es ist eben eine leitfähige Flüssigkeit. Das heißt, es ist eine Flüssigkeit, die elektrisch leitfähig ist und die selber Felder erzeugt, die wiederum in Wechselwirkung stehen mit den Feldern, die von außen angelegt werden. Das heißt also, es ist eine Flüssigkeit plus elektrische Ladung plus Maxwells Gleichung.
Was letztendlich bedeutet, dass man eine riesige Anzahl verschiedener Wellenphänomene und Instabilitäten hat, die so in der Flüssigkeit erstmal nicht auftreten.
Das ist also viel reicher, die ganze Angelegenheit, nicht? Das heißt also viel mehr Tücken, die da drin stehen.
Aber es klingt ja so ein bisschen so, als wäre so die Hoffnung auf mehr Computingpower da durchaus nicht ungerechtfertigt.
Und das ist genau die Ecke für die Turbulenzforschung. Also um bei der Turbulenz voranzukommen, braucht man massives, massives, massives, massives Supercomputing. Das heißt also, die schnellsten Maschinen der Welt, die werden mit dem Turbulenzproblem bis an ihre Haarspitzen ausgereizt. Und immer, wenn wieder die nächste Generation kommt, mit noch mal Faktor 10 mehr Flops da drin, dann ist das überhaupt kein Problem. Dann sind unsere ganzen Theorie-Kollegen nicht ganz schnell dabei, die entscheiden, Parameter zu ändern. Und dann sind sie wieder, pang, wieder am Limit. Dann dauert es wieder zehn Stunden oder zehn Wochen jeder Run. Eigentlich aber nicht mit dieser erhöhten Auflösung oder mit dieser leicht geänderten Fahrgestellung kommt man dann gerade wieder einen kleinen Triple-Shirt voran. Und gerade in diesen Turbulenzproblemen. Und die Reihenfolge muss sein, dass man erst mal dieses Turbulenzproblem verstanden haben muss, was auch immer verstehen meint. Also dass man da wirklich ein komplettes Bild davon sich entwirft, bevor man überhaupt den Schritt gehen kann, es zu kontrollieren. Denn nur was man verstanden hat, kann man ja kontrollieren. Ansonsten ist es ja so ein Gestocher.
Das Problem ist tatsächlich, dass man über viele Größenordnungen simulieren muss. Das heißt von der Gesamtplasma Größe bis halt runter zu mikroskopischen Größen, die halt also tatsächlich sowohl zeitlich als auch räumlich fünf, sechs Größenordnungen auseinander liegen. Und das ist einfach schwer zu machen.
Also es ist ein ekliges Problem, aber wenn es einen Durchbruch gibt, dann da. Alles klar.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Wir können die Tour wärmstens empfehlen, wer Lust hat und nicht zu weit weg wohnt.
Oder wer mal die Ostsee kombinieren will mit ein bisschen Wissenschaft und Technik.
Also Sommer School klingt ja auch sehr schön.
Ja, also herzlich willkommen. Webseite steht alles drauf. www.itt.net, npg.de Wir tun die in die Links-Sendung, da gibt es die Infobox.
Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Gespräch. Das war extrem interessant. Dann noch vielen Dank an die Hörer fürs Zuhören. Und falls ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr auf den Flatter-Button oder jetzt neu auf den Patreon-Button klicken. Und ansonsten vielen Dank.
Und uns das Benzin zahlen.
Genau. Und dann bis zum nächsten Mal.